Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Ich hab's verpasst, aber hast du JJ gehört?
Ich habe mir das Lied im Nachhinein angehört.
Ich habe es verpasst, wo war ich an dem Abend? Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Waste the Love heißt der Titel.
Hast du alles gesehen?
Nein, um Gottes Willen.
War das zu Recht der Siegertitel?
Ich bin keine Ahnung. Ich gucke ESC nie.
Ich dachte, mit so einer Konkretät man damit, dass man es sieht.
Ja, das ist wohl so. Aber für mich ist das einfach zum größten Teil Musik, die ich nicht aushalte. Ich glaube, dieser Titel ist recht gut, wenngleich mich mehr interessieren würde, JJ in einer klassischen Rolle zu sehen. Denn er hat ja auch Auftritte in der Staatsoper, in Wien und er hat eine sehr berühmte Gesangslehrerin, nämlich Linda Wotzen. Das ist eine große Wagner-Interpretin und sie legt auch Wert darauf, dass er kein Countertenor ist. Also Countertenöre singen ja in so einer Altstimme eigentlich, klingen auch so eine Mischung aus Knabe und Frau. Und er aber tatsächlich kommt in Sopranenhöhen. Und das ist sehr beeindruckend, wie hoch er mühelos gelangt. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall eine beeindruckende Leistung. Wenn gleich ich sagen würde, für ihn wird jetzt das Lied zu singen gar nicht das Schwerste sein. Er hat, wenn er klassische Partien singt, sicherlich stimmlich größere Herausforderungen. Da geht es ja noch um Performance und alles Mögliche. Aber es ist natürlich wieder so ein Phänomen, dass das ja von einem Publikum geschieht, das zum größten Teil nicht vertraut ist mit klassischer Musik und jetzt auch nicht mit Countertenören oder mit Barockopern. Und die hören das und finden das so unglaublich, dass es das gibt. Und da kann man natürlich sagen, ja, Moment mal, das gibt es ganz, ganz oft. Da geht mal ins Theater, seht euch Barockopern an. Oft werden die auch mit Countertenören oder auch mit Männersobran-Stimmen besetzt. Also man kann auch abseits vom ESC hohe Stimmen, schöne Stimmen von Männern hören. Ja, das habe ich jedenfalls mitbekommen davon. Sonst geht der ESC an mir vorüber.
Sehr gut. Es sind ja auch immer nur drei Minuten. Das Publikum wird ja nicht wirklich beschäftigt damit, nur kurz befasst und dann findet man es gut. Kennt man ja von Paul Potts, damals X Factor, der ja auch plötzlich diesen klassischen Gesang auf diese Bühne brachte und schon nach dem zweiten Ton rastet das Publikum aus, weil man es gar nicht ausgehalten hat mal zuzuhören. Wir gehen ja heute wieder in die Oper, drei Stunden ist das Programm heute.
Wir sind gespannt. Es wird ja noch immer über die Wehrpflicht debattiert. Du hast vielleicht mitbekommen, dass der Frankfurter Allgemeinen am Sonntag Pistorius ein Interview gegeben hat und meinte, ja, vorerst gibt es keine Wehrpflicht, aber wenn das dann nicht so klappt mit der Freiwilligkeit, müssen wir darüber nachdenken. Und Eva Högl hat das auch nochmal so betont. Wir werden sehen.
Ist Eva Högl noch wehr?
Nein, nein, sie ist nicht mehr, aber sie hat das auch nochmal so nachgeschoben, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht nur freiwillig geht.
Kommt direkt mit der Impfpflicht, glaube ich.
Jedenfalls wird darüber auch im Föjeton debattiert. Und wir werden uns jetzt eine Föjeton-Debatte im Radio anhören. Zwei Föjetonistinnen, Nele Polacek und Mirna Funk, sprechen darüber, dass die Wehrpflicht doch auch für Frauen eingeführt werden könnte und haben da unterschiedliche Positionen. Ich kenne ja deine Clips noch nicht, würde aber behaupten, dass das jetzt die blödesten Clips sind, die wir heute zu hören bekommen.
Ich habe nachher März-Clips.
Na, also nein, nein, nein. Also auch irgendwo.
Aber ich finde es schon von der Anlage eher blöd, denn die Bundespolitiker in Verantwortung sagen ja nicht ohne Grund. Erst mal keine Wehrpflicht. Wir machen einen Vorschlag, vielleicht schwedisches Modell und so weiter, weil sie genau wissen, das ist schon schwierig. Aber für Frauen, also eine Zweidrittelmehrheit in diesem Bundestag.
Sie sprechen natürlich jetzt darüber, muss das so sein? Sollte die Frau wehrfähig werden? All diese Fragen werden jetzt verhandelt und wir versuchen mal, dieses Niveau der Debatte abzubilden. Fangen wir mal an, Myrna Funk.
Für mich ist völlig klar, dass wenn wir über eine zukünftige Wehrpflicht sprechen, dass die selbstverständlich Männer und Frauen inkludiert. Und das ist im Gegensatz zu dem, was Jette Nitzert gesagt hat, für mich selbstverständlich ein Zeichen emanzipatorischen Handelns und auch einer gleichberechtigten Gesellschaft in Deutschland.
Alle müssen. Nele Polatschek sagt Folgendes.
Wenn man einen Staat schützen möchte, dann deswegen, weil er weiter bestehen soll. Damit ein Staat weiter bestehen kann, muss es Reproduktion geben. Das heißt, Menschen müssen Kinder bekommen. Diese Arbeit, das Reproduzieren, das Austragen und Gebären von Kindern, wird in diesem Land, wie in jedem anderen Land der Welt, zu praktisch 100 Prozent von Frauen gemacht. Und wir brauchen diese Arbeit. In dieser Situation, wo wir sowieso eine Reproduktionsrate in Deutschland korrigierte Rate von 1,36 Kindern pro Frau, wenn wir in dieser Situation sagen, wir nehmen jetzt unsere Frauen im reproduktionsfähigen Alter, was ja eine begrenzte Zeit ist, und zwingen die zur Wehrpflicht, dann ist das eine sehr unvernünftige Art, einen Staat zu schützen.
Worüber reden wir denn jetzt hier eigentlich? Also sind wir jetzt tatsächlich an dem Punkt, dass wir jetzt wieder sagen, wir gebären Kinder für den Staat? Nele Polatschek hatte dazu einen Artikel veröffentlicht und hat diese These vertreten und er war aber so komisch geschrieben, dass ich dachte, sie meint das ironisch. Also ich dachte, sie karikiert dieses, die Frauen, Blut und Boden und so weiter. Ich dachte, das sei eine Ironie von ihr. Aber die meinen das ernst in dieser Argumentation.
Also wenn die Argumentation ist, Frauen können nicht zur Dienst an der Waffe und damit den Dienst an den Staat herangezogen werden, weil sie ja schon den Dienst am Kind und damit am Staat erbringen. Das ist ja völlig Banane.
Sie produzieren die Soldaten, die Kleinen.
Ja, war ja auch meine Erfahrung aus allen Diskussionen zur Alten Republik. Nein, nicht für den Staat, sondern es geht hier um individuelle Kinderwünsche, die man hat. Und dann lebt man halt ein Leben, wie man will und so. Und für oder gegen Kinder, aber frei entschieden.
Und wenn man auswandern will, dann sagt man ja auch nicht, ich bin wahnsinnig staatsfeindlich, weil ich auswandere. Sondern man würde sagen, ja mein Lebensmittelpunkt ist jetzt Italien, gefällt mir besser, Rom ist schön, warum soll ich in Frankfurt leben? Dann würde man jetzt nicht sagen, ach du lieber Gott, dieser Vaterlandsverräter. Jetzt entzieht er sich und noch seine Kinder dem Staat Deutschland, der das doch braucht, um verteidigungsfähig zu sein. Also ich bin entsetzt darüber, dass wir jetzt an diesem Niveau diskutieren und auch wie mit dem Zwang umgegangen wird. Also wieder Nele Polatschek.
Also du könntest jetzt morgen dich bei der Bundeswehr melden, die würden dich mit Kusshand nehmen, das ist nicht die Frage.
Das sagten wir nach Funk und jetzt?
Jeder darf, die Frage ist, wen zwingt man?
Entschuldigung, das war jetzt Nele Polatschek, also sie fragte, ja wen zwingt man? Also dass man offenbar Leute zwingt, ist erst mal so, müssen wir nur noch klären, ob es auch noch Frauen sein sollen. Und jetzt werden sie sich auch ein bisschen uneins wieder, wenn sie darüber diskutieren, über Zwang und all das.
Ne, wir reden nicht von neun Monaten, wir reden bei der Wehrpflicht von sechs oder zwölf.
Nein, wir reden von einer Schwangerschaft von neun Monaten. Also wir reden hier davon, Frauen völlig vom Wehrdienst zu entbinden, weil sie irgendwie vielleicht einmal in ihrem Leben neun Monate lang schwanger sind. Das ist ja total absurd.
Myrna, 9 Monate reichen nicht. Du brauchst, damit ein Land weiter besteht, brauchst du zwei Kinder pro Frau. Das sind nicht neun Monate, das sind 18 Monate.
Ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut, wie dein Buch schließt. Dein Buch zur Rentnerrepublik. Also dein Buch, wie heißt es? Altenrepublik. Das schließt ja damit, dass du sagst, wir brauchen eine Politik, dass Frauen zwei Komma so und so viele Kinder haben wollen. Was aber nicht meinte, du machst eine Bevölkerungspolitik in dem Sinne, dass du sagst, die Frauen sollen verpflichtet werden. Und du meintest auch nicht, der Staat braucht das, sondern es gibt einen Kinderwunsch in der Gesellschaft. Und der realisiert sich aber nicht oft, weil die Leute sagen, ich kann mir eine größere Wohnung nicht leisten, ich weiß nicht, ob ich einen Kita-Platz bekomme, was ist eigentlich, wenn meine Eltern nicht auf das Kind aufpassen können. All diese Fragen, die sie stellen, die gesellschaftliche Fragen, die sind alle nicht beantwortet. Und deswegen haben viele Menschen einen Kinderwunsch, den sie nicht realisieren oder dann sagen, dann lieber nur ein Kind, ich hätte gerne zwei oder drei gehabt, aber mehr geht nicht. Und da kann man sagen, da wird also ein individueller Wunsch durch eigentlich Materialität, die da ist, die durch Umverteilung und so weiter hergestellt werden könnte, wird dort untersagt. Hier aber hat man die Idee, dass wirklich Paare Kinderzeugen, um dann zu sagen, jetzt hat der Staat wieder eins. Und ich muss aber auch mindestens dem Staat zwei geben. Ich frage mich gerade, wie stehe ich eigentlich da mit keinem Kind?
Also die Diskussion ist ja sowieso witzig, weil hier also diese Übereinanderlappung von zwei Argumentationen für dieselbe Zahl, nämlich neun Monate, ist ja wirklich ambüsant. Neun Monate Wehrdienst oder neun Monate Schwangerschaft. Und dann als Gegenargument, neun Monate Schwangerschaft und dann neun Monate Wehrdienst. So direkt nach der Entbindung geht es los. Und dann sagt sie, nein, wir brauchen auch dafür viel länger. Und dann könnt ihr mal wieder kommen mit, ja genau, das Kind braucht ja mindestens mal so sechs Jahre bis zur Schulfähigkeit und einen Lehrer auszubilden, wenn man den gesellschaftlichen Bedarf kennt, dass man dann Betreuung und ich nehme jetzt mal Lehrerschaft nur als Betreuung, dass man da auch noch ein bisschen Pädagogik macht, schön und gut. Die dauert ja auch genau diese sechs Jahre. Also man könnte es eigentlich, wenn man es einfach runterbricht, auf die Zahlen so machen. Nur, du hast es ja angesprochen, ich habe es ja dann in der Kinderwüste noch mal, also ich habe die Zahlen rausgesucht. Es ist eine Erhebung der Bundesregierung selbst, die sagt, eigentlich haben wir so viel Kinderwünsche, dass wir bei 2,4 Kindern pro Frau wären. Wir sind aber nur, sie hat jetzt gesagt 1,36, also wir runden auf 1,4. Es ist also genau ein Kind pro Frau, das sich gewünscht wird, aber nicht kommt. Und der Wunsch ist ein ganz individueller. Man hat den richtigen Partner, man ist auch schon in dem Leben angekommen. Man weiß auch, 38 ist noch nicht zu spät, selbst mit 41 geht das noch. Man kann noch ein Kind haben und man bekommt es trotzdem nicht. Warum nicht? Und die Antwort ist, du hast es schon angedeutet, aber ich will es noch mal ganz deutlich sagen, weil einem der Start im Stich lässt. Der einzige Grund, die jungen Frauen führen eigentlich ein Zufriednisleben. Gerade in diesem 28 bis 32, da ist eigentlich alles soweit. Der Kinderwunsch ist da, in dem Alter auch am höchsten, der Partner ist da, alles ist da, die Familie steht bereit, die Oma fragt schon immer und die Großmutter steht bereit, typischerweise. Und dann kommt es nicht dazu, weil einem der Start im Stich lässt. So, und in dieser Diskussion oder in dieser Gemengelage jetzt plötzlich zu sagen, liebe junge Frau, jetzt lass mal den Start nicht im Stich.
Ja.
Das ist doch grotesk.
Völlig, völlig irrsinnig. Und den Frauen wird es auch sehr helfen, wenn die Männer dann abgeordnet werden, um eine Wehrpflicht abzuleisten. Das wird denen auch sehr helfen.
Du hast den Partner gerade gefunden und plötzlich sagt der Start, ja er muss jetzt. Du bist gerade selber im jetzt starten wir ins Familienleben, zack ist der Partner.
Dann lieber alle oder so. Mürner Funk, finde ich jetzt eigentlich die moderne toll, aber wo ist denn das kollektiv geblieben?
Naja, die Sache ist natürlich die, dass wenn alle Personen eines Landes wehrpflichtig sind und einen Teil ihrer Zeit zwischen ihrem 18. und 21. Lebensjahr in einem System verbringen, in dem es darum geht, Verteidigung zu lernen, gemeinschaftlich Verteidigung zu lernen, zu verstehen, wozu man das macht, dann prägt das natürlich eine Gesellschaft viel mehr und auf eine andere Art und Weise, als wenn vereinzelte Individuen und gerade in der jungen Generation, die sehr stark auf Individuation ausgerichtet sind, wogegen ich auch gar nichts hab. Das Problem ist nur, wenn die Individuation so stark ist, dass das Kollektiv nicht mehr gedacht wird und vor allem auch nicht das Land, in dem man lebt und das einem ja auch die Freiheit und die Chancen dieser Individuation gibt.
Ja, diese unglaublichen Freiheiten, dass man schon bald ganz hohe Mieten zahlen muss, wenn man das Elternhaus verlassen hat, das ist natürlich unbezahlbar und dass man sich da nicht für opfern will, kann Myrna Funk aus ihrem Weltbüro gar nicht verstehen. Also ich bin wirklich entsetzt, wie man, mit wie wenig man heute eine Föhtonkarriere hinbekommt.
Ja, ich finde es auch wirklich erschütternd, denn bislang war es so, dass wir immer von Jugend mit Jugendkultur verbinden, dass die sich so dagegen auflehnen, irgendwie gegen die Elterngeneration, gegen alles. Diese Idee davon, dass man jetzt eine Jugend braucht, die sich in so einem kollektiven Pflichtmodus plötzlich fühlt, ist auch kontraproduktiv. Also das bringt eine Gesellschaft nicht nach vorne. Wir brauchen eine aufmögliche, innovative, so ein bisschen abstrakt denkende und dann wäre es schon ganz gut, wenn die Mieten nicht so hoch wären, dass man mit 25 noch eine Mietbürgschaft der Eltern braucht, sondern mit 15 schon sagt, ihr könnt mich alle malen. So, das wäre schon nötig.
Es ist ja kein Zufall, dass das Silicon Valley aus der Gegenkultur entstanden ist. Genau, total.
Alles ist aus der Gegenkultur entstanden. Typischerweise kommt immer ein 20-Jähriger in sein Berufsleben, ist dann bei Research and Development und versucht, die ganze Zeit gegen den Vorstand anzuarbeiten. Das kann ja so nicht sein und überhaupt nicht. Ich hab doch hier eine bessere Idee. Und dann schleust man sich so durch diese Systeme. Und am Ende steht im Grunde ein wie ist das ein Sturm durch die Institutionen und so weiter. Also immer so eine Idee. Ich will hier aber grundsätzlich mal sagen, diese Diskussionen, wie sie auch da geführt werden, sind ja total Banane. Man muss es mal auf Zahlen runterbrechen. Bei der Bundeswehr arbeiten derzeit so 230.000 Leute. Sie wollen auf 400.000. Und dann sagen alle, die sich damit auskennen, also Wadephool war es jetzt, glaube ich, den ich im Ohr habe oder so. Na, wir haben ja noch so 800.000 Reservisten und Ehemalige. Wenn es hart auf hart kommt, greifen wir auf die zurück. Aber es ist auch ganz gut, dass sie nicht gerade aktuell die Kaserne verstopfen, sondern dass wir sie so im Pool haben. Was bedeutet, wir haben noch einen Bedarf von 100.000, um auf die 400.000 zu kommen. Also weitere 100.000 Personal. Pro Jahrgang werden in Deutschland 750.000 Menschen geboren. Wenn man jetzt 100.000 will und man würde sich ein Jahrgang auswählen, also dann 300.000 Jungs, und von denen bekäme man ein Drittel in die Bundeswehr und die verpflichten sich für 12 Jahre, dann wäre für die folgenden 12 Jahrgänge einfach das erledigt. Die Bundeswehr ist dann voll. So, wir können natürlich jetzt nicht ein Drittel der jungen Männer rausziehen. Also nehmen wir so ein Dreißigstel, also ein Zehntel. Wir reden also hier über ein Dreißigstel der Männer, die sich dann über 12 Jahre verpflichten. Das würde schon ausreichen. Dass wir die ganze Zeit so diskutieren, als müssten jetzt alle in die Bundeswehr und die Bundeswehr ist auch das wichtigste Organ von Deutschland. Sonst geht gar nichts. Nachdem wir, und wir werden das nachher auf sakrale Grundlagen runterbrechen, eigentlich bisher die Autoindustrie so verherrlicht haben oder irgendeinen anderen Scheiß. Das ist alles total schräg. Also es ist wirklich schräg.
Ja, aber das ist so Berlin.
Jetzt geht es auch nicht aufgelöst.
Nein, das ist so Berlin Mitte Botox-Denken. Wir hören mal weiter, denn du denkst ja viel zu kurz.
Also das ist die Frage, die mir Mirna, die ich wirklich gerne beantwortet haben wollen würde von dir, Mirna. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, es gibt einen Krieg, also Putin greift an und es gibt einen Krieg und Männer und Frauen kämpfen und am Ende sind viele Millionen tot. Wie genau glaubst du, dass der Staat erhalten bleibt? Also ich sehe, wir haben jetzt unter 20 Millionen reproduktionsfähige Frauen. Wie genau soll das erhalten bleiben?
Ich kenne dieses Denken ja nur von wirklich den radikalen Rechten, so dieses Volkstotdenken.
Genau.
Wenn so viele Migranten kommen und die deutschen Frauen auch nicht genügend gebären, was ist dann mit dem deutschen Volke? Und jetzt haben wir eine solche Diskussion jetzt hier. Also das ist ja auch eine interessante Vorstellung. Alle sind tot und dann...
Also diese Idee, dass man seinen Staat, das Kollektiv, das Volk, was auch immer, die nationale Identität verteidigt. Das geschieht nicht mal im Krieg. Diese ganze Kameradschaftsoziologie beschreibt und wir haben das mit Alexander Kluge und der Kriegsfibel gelesen. Er hat es nochmal darauf Wert gelegt, dass es dieses Phänomen gibt. Der Krieg ernährt sich selbst und die Kriegsparteien kämpfen am Ende gar nicht so sehr gegeneinander als gegen den Krieg als Entität. Und der besteht nun mal darin, dass da gerade nicht das Kollektiv, das Volk, die Nation, sondern der eine Kamerad, den man entweder schützt oder recht. Und das ist einfach die Frage, wer schießt zuerst wen tot? Und dann ist das ein selbstlaufendes Ding. So und das ist das Phänomen. Was bedeutet? Wir sagen jetzt immer so, ja die Ukraine, da sind ja alles zu Helden geworden, nachdem der Krieg begann. Ja das wäre in Deutschland auch so. Sobald hier große Kriegseinsätze von Nöten sind, wären die Deutschen schon bereit, ihre Sachen zu verteidigen. Wir sehen doch, wie sehr sie ihre Parkplätze verteidigen.
Ja bzw. sie haben ja keine andere Möglichkeit. Also die ukrainischen Männer, die gerne ausreisen würden, die werden ja nicht gelassen. Und das ist ja eben das Katastrophale, dass die breite Mitte und bis in weit in linke Kreise hinein, das nicht skandalisieren, dass man nicht mehr vor Krieg fliehen darf, das dann einfach jetzt angesagt ist zu kämpfen. Das war, ich will noch mal darauf hinweisen, das große Argument 2015, als die Flüchtlinge aus Syrien kamen, dass man Leute, die vor Krieg fliehen, aufnimmt. Und es waren nur Rechtsradikale von der AfD, die sagten, wenn Krieg ist, bleibt man zu Hause und kämpft. Das war eine reine AfD-Position, ist jetzt inzwischen absolut mehrheitsfähig geworden, weshalb man ja auch sich nicht darum bemüht, ukrainische Deserteure und auch russische Deserteure zu unterstützen. Da haben wir ja schon gehört, der Queer-Beauftragte der SPD, der sagte, ja, also wir können jetzt nicht die Russen als Fluchtgrund angeben lassen, dass sie queer sind. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, ist doch wunderbar, die brauchen nur Queer-Ankreuzen und dann lassen wir die rein, dann hat Putin wieder jemanden weniger. Das ist ja immer eine kluge Bevölkerungspolitik, wenn man so möchte. Aber wir sind natürlich noch nicht am Ende die Wehrhaftigkeit von Frauen.
Von entscheidender Bedeutung und Notwendigkeit, dass Frauen eine echte Wehrhaftigkeit erlangen vor einem Krieg. Und das bedeutet übrigens auch, sich verteidigen zu können in Straßenschlachten, ihr Dorf, das heißt einfach auch schießen zu können.
Also ich bin auf Seite von Coach Colin, ja, körperliche Ertüchtigung, alles. Von mir ist auch Biathlon, Sport, gerade noch schnaufend den Berg hochgerannt und jetzt sofort in Ruhe zielen zu müssen. Aber you are not a warrior.
Genau, aber sie wollen das. Sie wollen das. Straßenkämpfe des Dorfverteidigens, das kannst du auch mit Götz Kubitschek und Elin Kossitzer mal besprechen.
Dann mit Kinderwagen oder ohne? Ist das wie beim Joggen so die Diskussion?
Müssen wir mal schauen, wer darauf aufpasst. Das machen dann die, die wahrscheinlich die, die keinen deutschen Pass haben. Die müssen dann für die Care-Arbeit hergeholt werden. Denn das ist endlich Emanzipation.
Ja, würden sie so weit gehen, Frau Funk zu sagen, dass so ein Militärdienst ein Mittel wäre zur Selbstermächtigung der Frau?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Okay.
Also es ist doch logisch, dass wenn ich weiß, wie ich mich verteidigen kann und wie ich meine eigene Familie verteidigen kann, und zwar mit Waffengewalt und möglicherweise ja auch mit strategischem Wissen und mit körperlicher Kraft, dann ist das doch ein riesen Vorteil gegenüber absolut jeder Frau, die nicht weiß, wie man abdrückt.
Also, in welcher Situation befinden wir uns jetzt eigentlich? Sind wir schon draußen im Bürgerkrieg? Muss ich mir auch gleich eine Waffe beschaffen?
Wir haben gerade eine sehr wichtige Diskussion, bei der keiner so richtig weiß, wie man weiterkommt. Jetzt übernehmen im Osten, in der Lokalpolitik die ganze Zeit AfD-Leute, alte NBDler, wie auch immer, alte neue Kader, die sich auch erst mal kennenlernen müssen und feststellen, ach so, ihr radikalisiert euch im Internet, zeigt uns doch mal, was ihr da so seht, und dann werden die Alten auch erst mal neu radikalisiert. Und was die gerade machen, ist genau das, Bürgerwehr. Wir müssen hier auf die Straße es selber machen. Hier kommt kein Landespolizist mehr vorbei. Sobald wir hier einen Ausländer sehen, müssen wir uns drum kümmern.
Hier machen wir eine Wehrsportgruppe wieder.
Hier ist dann also die Frage, ab wann fühlt man sich angegriffen? Ab wann soll man den zuschlagen und so weiter? Und diese Diskussion kann man in Berlin führen, wie man sie in Berlin führt. Aber wenn dann auch Leute vom Osten auf dem Lande zuhören, muss man vielleicht noch mal eine Einschränkung einziehen.
Das ist eine Diskussion aus dem UBER Premium heraus. Fitnessstudio, du hast schon angesprochen.
Ich würde dir ja sogar mit Recht geben. Ich glaube, dass es natürlich ein Problem ist, wenn ich mir angucke, dass Männer tendenziell im Fitnessstudio pumpen und ihre Muskeln aufbauen und Frauen im Fitnessstudio sehr oft eher dazu ermutigt werden, alles schön klein und schlank zu halten.
Ich pumpe!
Natürlich ist das ein Problem.
Ich pumpe richtig, dreimal die Woche. Sehr gut, ich auch.
Hardcore sogar. Kann ich auch wirklich jedem empfehlen, der auf Gleichberechtigung steht?
Gibt es da große Verschwesterungen jetzt, dass man ja pumpt im Fitnessstudio?
Ja, um wehrhaft zu sein. Ich gehe ins Fitnessstudio und sehe da ja Leute, die Muskeln haben und denke, sind das jetzt Warrior? Nein. Das sind einfach Leute, die in einem Schönheitsideal hinterherjagen und versuchen das zu machen. Und ich muss gestehen, jetzt durch den Rechtsruck, gucke ich auch schon mal beim Tattoo genauer hin, ob es noch ein Palmenhain ist oder schon ein Hakenkreuz. Aber wir können doch jetzt nicht in einer Gesellschaft leben wollen, in der wir jetzt sagen, wir brauchen mal wieder Muskeln, um uns durchzusetzen, damit ich dann noch zur Not jemanden eins auf die Fresse schlagen kann. Also das ist jetzt das Niveau, auf dem unsere deutsche Fögelton-Elite angekommen ist.
Ja, da muss man eh anmerken. Du kennst, da du jetzt selber in den Fitnessstudio gehst, wahrscheinlich auch die YouTube und Insta-Trends zum Thema Kalisthenics. Also Leute, es gibt Fitnessstudio-Leute und Fitnessstudio-Gäste. Die einen trainieren mit ihrem Körpergewicht und kriegen dann auch Sachen geregelt und die anderen, wie sie sagt, pumpen. Und das sieht man bei Männern besonders gut, wenn Schulter und Brust besonders ausgeprägt ist. Und man weiß, okay, die gehen einfach auf Ästhetik. Die haben ihre vier Lieblingsübungen und ziehen dreimal die Woche durch. Und man weiß ganz genau, wenn man die jetzt auf den Parkplatz stellt und sagt 100 Meter, dann laufen die das in 16 Sekunden und brauchen danach eine Stunde Recovery. Also mit denen ist nichts anzufangen.
Ja, das ist ganz interessant. Ich habe mit einem Handwerker gesprochen und der nicht trainiert ist, aber der natürlich viel schleppen muss. Und der sagte, na ja, die Jungen, die da alle kommen mit den Muskeln, was die tragen, da trage ich ja an der Urkette. Die können also in dem Sinne, die können ihre Übungen machen, um die Brust aufzupumpen oder die Bizeps. Aber die sind gar nicht in der Lage, solche Arbeiten körperliche zu verrichten wie er.
Ein bisschen Chor, ein bisschen draußen mal sich bewegen, dann bis zur Tür mit dem Auto zu fahren und dann da einfach Lattzüge zu machen.
Ja, ich erkenne mich fast wieder. Nun, wenn wir noch einmal an den Polatschek hören, denn plötzlich ist ihr das so ein bisschen unbehaglich, dass man überhaupt so einen Zwang ausübt.
Okay.
Ein Staat kann die Engstellen nicht dadurch lösen, dass er Leute zwingt. Ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht, wie groß die Lücke in der Pflege ist, aber die ist wirklich tödlich und wirklich auch schlimm. Und trotzdem kann der Staat jetzt nicht sagen, gut, dann nehmen wir dich, dich und dich, weil du uns gerade gefällst, und zwingen dich, diesen Job auszufüllen. Sondern er muss versuchen, Anreize zu schaffen. Er muss vielleicht die Bedingungen besser machen. Man kann ja auch sagen, na ja, die Leute, die in der Bundeswehr sind, die sind ja bereit, ihr Leben zu opfern. Also dann muss man diesen Beruf so attraktiv machen, dass 23.000 Leute sagen, das wollen wir. Und da ja so viele Leute sowieso schon sagen, sie wollen es jederzeit gerne tun, kann die Aufgabe nicht so schwer sein.
Ja, das ist allerdings ein interessanter Punkt, also dass sie es von sich aus anspricht, dass man sie nicht erst herantragen muss. Denn soziologisch ist ja völlig klar, in so einem U-Boot sagt natürlich jeder von sich, er ist der Wichtigste. Auch der Koch, da sagt er einfach, also ohne mich könnte er ja gar nichts und so. Und der andere, aber ich schieß doch die Raketen ab, aber ich suche doch für Sauerstoff und so. Und so kann man sich das ja alles vorstellen. Jeder ist immer der Wichtigste. Und es ist wirklich sehr fraglich, warum jetzt auf der Werbpflicht so ein Zwangsargument läuft. Und wie sie sagt, bei der Pflege nicht. Das können wir natürlich sagen. Naja, die Pflege, wenn sie ausartet, die wird uns ja nicht gefährlich. Also da sterben ja einfach nur alte Leute dann halt unbeobachtet vor sich hin. Und § 1 zählt nicht so ganz, Artikel 1. Aber der Rest ist so ein bisschen egal, während Putin so droht.
So wird das ja auch gedacht.
Genau. Und da könnte man aber genauso gut sagen, naja, wenn wir uns jetzt fragen, was ist denn hier zu verteidigen, und wir kommen dann irgendwie auf unsere Wirtschaft zu sprechen, auf unser Zusammenleben. Markus Söder erzählt nochmal, wie toll es in Bayern ist und so. Dann ist ja die Frage, ja, aber braucht man dafür nicht Arbeitskraft und Produktivität, die gerade gebunden wird, dadurch, dass zu wenig Leute Pflege machen und so viel familiär geregelt werden muss. Im Betreuungsverhältnis eins zu eins. Und dann könnte man aus einer Pflicht zur Pflege noch sehr viel mehr rausholen. Also Verteidigungsgründe erst mal schaffen, bevor es dann in die Verteidigung geht. Ja, aber warum die Werbpflicht da so ein Sonderthema einnimmt? Einfach nur, weil es Lebensgefahr bedeutet, wie auch immer. Selbst wenn man sie jetzt durchsetzt. Die Werbpflicht, die wir hatten, betraf erstens nur Männer und zweitens nur Männer in deutscher Kaserne. Auslandseinsätze völlig ausgeschlossen. Dafür brauchte man auch wieder eine Verfassungsänderung, die ich mir auch nicht vorstelle, durch politischen Druck im Sinne von Oh, Polen brennt gerade. Putin hat es geschafft, nach Polen einzuspielen.
Man sah es in der Kaserne, hat Skat gespielt.
Genau, dass wir dann plötzlich sagen, ach so, ja, dann schicken wir jetzt unsere Werbpflichtigen nach Polen, damit sie da kämpfen.
Ja, also was ist das auch für eine Vorstellung, wenn die beiden dann sagen, ja, und dann kommt Putin, also ich glaube, das war Polatschek, die dann sagt, ja, dann kommt Putin und dann sind Millionen tot. Ja, ich werde da nicht tot sein, weil ich mich dann auf den Weg mache, abzuhauen. Also das ist auch so eine Idee wirklich, dass man sich jetzt einfach schon bereit erklärt hat, sich dann zu opfern für den Ernstfall. Dann würde ich sagen, nö, ich nicht. Aber wir wollen den intellektuellen Höhepunkt jetzt noch erreichen. Myrna Funk geht jetzt auf dieses Zwangsargument ein und sie bringt das Argument eigentlich. Und du wirst es kennen als Vater.
Ja, also ich finde, und da bin ich auch total gefühlsmäßig und auch intellektuell bei Nele, wenn es darum geht, Menschen zu etwas zu zwingen. Sowas lehne ich normalerweise auch wirklich total ab. Und es geht mir gegen den Strich. Manchmal, und in diesem Fall, verstehe ich aber auch, wann ein Zwang notwendig ist. Und der Zwang, z.B. meinem Kind über viele Jahre jeden Abend zu erklären, dass es das Kinderzimmer aufräumen muss, bis es das von alleine kann, der ist eben auch notwendig.
Ja, das Kind muss jeden Abend das Kinderzimmer aufräumen. Und sie macht das mit Zwang. Ja, das tut mir leid.
Aber das ist genauso wie, dass der Staat die Männer verpflichtet, zu sterben oder dann die Frauen auch. Das muss dann einfach sein. Schade. Also es ist ja immer diese Argumentation. Die hatten wir auch bei einigen Leuten, die erst gegen die Corona-Pflichtimpfung waren. Und dann aber plötzlich dafür, weil der Wind sich drehte und man doch merkte, im Podcastpublikum kommt es besser an. Und die haben dann gesagt, ja, mir blutet mein liberales Herz, aber das muss dann jetzt sein. Und jetzt hier auch wieder so, ja, es muss leider sein. Was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn man von den Geostrategen dann als Menschenmaterial wahrgenommen wird? Da muss man ja Kallumassallah danken. Er spricht manchmal in so großer Klarheit, dass man sich ja dann selbst noch mal überlegen will, möchte man sich auffüllen lassen. Er ist bei Anne Will zu Gast.
Genau. Die Pflicht ist zur Musterung. Das verschafft sozusagen einen Überblick über die Aufwuchsfähigkeit. Also wir werden ja in einem militärischen Konflikt das Problem haben, dass ich sag jetzt mal, an die 200.000 Bundeswehrsoldaten da involviert sein werden. Und nach sechs Monaten wird ein Drittel von denen gefallen oder verwundet sein. Das haben wir in der Ukraine gesehen. Und dann müssen sie diese Reihen auffüllen. Dazu müssen sie aber überhaupt wissen, wer ist dazu in der Lage. Und diesen Überblick haben wir gar nicht. Also deswegen ist eine eine verpflichtende Musterung, finde ich, gut für diese Aufwuchsfähigkeit.
Ja, also entweder stirbt man schon beim ersten Mal oder dann beim zweiten Mal wird man aufgefüllt. Das ist also die Situation. Und da können dann Myrna Funk und Nele Polatschek noch mal darüber diskutieren, ob Frauen mit aufgefüllt werden oder ob die dann schon die nächsten Jahrgänge austragen. Denn wir wissen ja, ein Mann kann viele Kinder auf einmal zeugen. Oder kurz nacheinander. Bei Frauen ist das schwieriger. Deswegen diese Reproduktionsarbeit. Wie dann die Politik darüber spricht, ist auch noch mal interessant. März war bei Ilna zu Gast und spricht über die Frage der Verhandlungen Ukraine und all das. Und soll das jetzt gar nicht im Punkte auf die Ukraine direkt interessieren, sondern wie wird eigentlich darüber gesprochen, was da passiert? Nämlich, es ist ja eigentlich so, dass dort Menschen sich gegenüberstehen, die sich töten müssen. Und die Politik spricht aber folgendermaßen darüber.
Ilna, das ist doch das Wesen eines solchen komplexen Prozesses. Dass man alles versucht, sowohl auf der militärischen Seite diesen Krieg zu beenden, als auch auf der diplomatischen Seite versucht, ihn zu beenden. Und wenn Sie mal in die Geschichte der Kriege der Welt schauen, das können Sie mit dem Dreißigjährigen Krieg anfangen, können Sie über die beiden Weltkriege sehen, das können Sie Afghanistan, Irak, Sie können an verschiedensten Stellen beobachten, der Vietnamkrieg. Wie sind diese Kriege zu Ende gegangen? Sie sind meistens nur durch eine militärische Erschöpfung, so tragisch und so furchtbar das für die Menschen ist, aber sie sind meistens erst durch eine militärische Erschöpfung auf mindestens einer Seite, manchmal auch auf beiden Seiten, gegangen. Das sind wir noch nicht. Wir versuchen jetzt alles, die Ukraine so zu ertüchtigen, dass sie sich weiter gegen den russischen Angriff wehren kann. Und irgendwann wird Putin einsehen, dass er das so nicht mehr weitergehen kann. Ich bin weiter tun kann.
Mit anderen Worten sagt er hier, wir machen einen Abnutzungskrieg und mal gucken, wie lange Putin durchhält. Und wir können natürlich uns auch gleichzeitig mal gucken, wie lange die Ukraine durchhält. Und wenn wir das mal humanitär besprechen oder humanistisch betrachten, dann müssen wir ja eigentlich sagen, also wie viele Menschen müssen auf welcher Seite noch sterben, bis diese Erschöpfung eingetreten ist. Das ist die Art und Weise, wie über Menschen. Ja, über Menschen, Fachbegriffe.
Wie viel kann Putin noch auffüllen? Ja, genau.
Wie wird hier über Menschen gesprochen? Und ja, da kann sich ja dann jeder sein Bild von machen. Womit wir eigentlich schon bei unserem anderen großen Thema sind und auch wiederum bei Friedrich Merz. Denn die Diskussion ist im Gange, ob man eine Kehrtwende bei der Union jetzt gerade erlebt, weil Friedrich Merz sich zu Gaza geäußert hat und er dort auf der Republika interessanterweise, also jetzt nicht bei einer Bundespressekonferenz oder sonst irgendwo bei einer Regierungspressekonferenz das sagte, sondern auf der Republik angesprochen wird auf Gaza und dann eine Äußerung tut, die viele überrascht hat, weil wir ja sonst eigentlich von der Union nur unbedingte Solidarität mit der Netanyahu-Regierung hörten.
Ja, es ist ganz verrückt, weil du sagst jetzt Republikarbühne, als wäre das von Bedeutung. Es ist ja in dem Fall nicht, weil der WDR hat, in dem Falle glaube ich Markus Preiß beauftragt, dieses Gespräch zu führen. Ob er jetzt beeindruckt davon war, dass jüngere Leute vor ihm sitzen, U60 statt und so. Aber wir können ja mal hören, was er hier.
Das, was die israelische Armee jetzt im Gaza-Streifen macht. Ich verstehe offen gestanden nicht mehr mit welchem Ziel. Die Zivilbevölkerung derart in Mitleidenschaft zu nehmen, wie das in den letzten Tagen immer mehr der Fall gewesen ist, lässt sich nicht mehr mit einem Kampf gegen den Terrorismus der Hamas begründen.
So, interessant ist ja, gut, machen wir gleich die nächsten Videos los. Interessant ist ja, dass hier wir jetzt einen Instagram-Clip von der Instagram-Seite des Bundeskanzleramts gespielt haben, die also genau diesen Auszug kontextlos, man sieht gar nicht, das ist Ritman, hat nur sein Gesicht gesehen, plus es war die Aufmachernachricht in der Tagesschau an diesem Tag. Wahrscheinlich hat der ganze Saal da so ein bisschen, ja schön, dass er das so sieht, während Markus Preiß so, oh sofort nach Hamburg melden, das muss hier und so weiter, also war für die dann auch, je nachdem wann das war, 11, 12, 13 Uhr. Klar, okay, das ist heute der Aufmacher. Und sie haben dann gleich im Nachgang, also in der Berichterstattung zu diesem O-Ton gezeigt, wie Gaza aussah, nachdem dort wieder eine Schule bombardiert wurde, in der Flüchtlinge untergebracht waren. Und in diesem Fernsehbild, das habe ich jetzt noch vor Augen, weil ich die Tagesschau jetzt ab und zu immer mal gucke, so eine Wand eingeschlagen wurde, da war so ein kleines Loch drin und da wurde ein Kind rausgereicht.
Ich habe es auch gesehen, ja.
Und das sind natürlich Bilder, die sich sozusagen einschleifen. Wir müssen jetzt März wieder relativieren. Also ich habe ihm vorgestern am 28. März, glaube ich, war er heute schon halt unter den Tagesthemen zugeschaltet, wo er so gefragt wurde, was sind jetzt die roten Linien in Gaza für Israel? Und dann kam er auch gleich auf die Hamas zu sprechen. Mit demselben Argument wie bei Putin. Der Ukraine-Krieg ist überhaupt nur, weil Putin nicht aufhört. Und in Gaza nur, weil die Hamas nicht aufhört. Also in der Hinsicht hat er es selber wieder eingefangen, aber es war ihm trotzdem wichtig, dieses Statement zu setzen, was für uns wieder bedeutet, offenbar waren wir Tagesschau-Zuschauer, Republikagänger, Instagram-Nutzer, wieder nur massenmedialer Spielball, um eine Nachricht nach Tel Aviv zu wenden oder nach die israelische Regierung oder wie auch immer.
Ja, beziehungsweise könnte man ja sagen, es ist ja erstaunlich, dass die israelische Regierung und auch der Botschafter in Deutschland diese Äußerung nicht kritisiert hat. Denn es ist ja normalerweise so, dass, wenn sich beispielsweise Macron oder andere äußern, mit sehr scharfer Kritik aus Israel zu rechnen ist, das hat hier nicht stattgefunden. Was ich mir vorstellen könnte ist, dass Friedrich Merz in Telefonaten oder direkten Gesprächen klargemacht hat, dass er sich mal dazu auch kritisch wird äußern wollen, aber ansonsten weiterhin Unterstützung zusagt und den Stopp der Waffenlieferung nicht genehmigen lässt. Also ich habe eher den Eindruck, wir haben es hier in gewisser Weise mit einem abgekaterten Spiel zu tun, was aber dann immerhin dafür sorgte, dass die Tagesschau und viele andere plötzlich auch mal sagten, okay, vielleicht müssen wir auch ein bisschen das Ganze mal ändern, auch auf tageschau.de erschienen plötzlich andere Artikel als zuvor. Und es ist ja so, dass jetzt viele Journalisten so tun und auch Politiker so tun, als hätten sie das jetzt gerade durch das aktuellste Handeln der israelischen Armee erst gesehen und müssten jetzt darauf reagieren. Und da muss man einfach sagen, jeder Journalist und jeder Politiker hätte das wissen können, und zwar seit anderthalb Jahren und länger. Und man hat das aber nicht gewollt, beziehungsweise man hat bewusst gegen die Realität angeschrieben, hat die Realität nicht zugelassen. Und jetzt wird man von der Realität so sehr eingeholt, dass man irgendwie versucht, einen Fluchtweg sich zu verschaffen, in der man sagt, ja, also jetzt gerade, also was so in den letzten Tagen von der israelischen Regierung in Gaza angeordnet wurde, da sind wir nicht mehr mit dabei. Da ist jetzt eine rote Linie und da müssen wir jetzt auch mal kritisch werden. Aber sonst sehe ich nicht jetzt die große Kehrtwende und die müsste eigentlich kommen. Und die müsste natürlich mit Waffenlieferungsstopp sowieso kommen. Und dass jetzt auch die Grünen sich so hervortun und so machen, als hätten sie das immer schon kritisiert, ist ja geradezu lachhaft, weil sich ja Baerbock gerade nicht da aus dem Fenster gelehnt hat und hat das schärfer kritisiert. Auch nicht in ihren letzten Tagen, in ihrer Amtszeit, das hätte sie ohne Probleme alles machen können. Und sie waren alle wahnsinnig zurückhaltend und haben beide Augen geschlossen. Das ist wirklich fatal, wie das immer noch eigentlich behandelt wird.
Ja, wir behandeln es auch mit vier Clips aus dem Ronsheimer Podcast, um uns eine Sache zu verdeutlichen. Denn ich glaube auch, dass es dieses abgekartetes Spiel ist. Klingt immer so, aber das ist Gang und Gäbe in der Politik. Die SPD Arbeitsministerin ruft natürlich vorher bei der IG Metall an, wenn irgendwas ist und die auch. Und dann wird so kurz ausklamüsert, wie man aufeinander reagiert, wie auch immer. Und so weiß ich nicht genau, ob wirklich gerade jemand ans Telefon geht in der israelischen Regierung. Trump reist ja nicht hin und redet nicht mit Bibi.
Naja, Deutschland ist schon sehr wichtig.
Bin ja Militanyahu. Ja, ob da gerade jemand sprechen...
Na, die werden schon sprechen. Also anders geht das aber mit den Waffenlieferungen nicht.
Es gibt jedenfalls dieses Einholen, also dass man dann später darauf angesprochen, was man da gesagt hat, durch die Blumen sagt, nee, ich wollte nur so eine mediale Welle machen. Eigentlich sehe ich es anders. Die Hamas ist hier schuld und so weiter und so fort. Das ist ja bei Ronzheimer Podcast auch. Also ich will jetzt nicht zu konkret werden, aber diese aktuellen Podcasts, die es da gerade wieder gibt und diese Gesprächsthemen und die Gesprächspartner weisen darauf hin, dass da gerade wieder Föllefanz stattfindet. Aber es gab auch bei Ronzheimer kurz diesen Moment, wo er sich sagte, okay, ich lade jetzt den Chefredakteur der jüdischen Allgemein, glaube ich, und im Vorhinein im anderen Gespräch Daniel Gerlach von Zenith ein. Daniel Gerlach ist ja sowieso häufiger immer mal wieder überall zu Gast, wo man sich auch langsam fragt, ist das so Maskottchenartig, also dass man so eine Stimme zulässt, die dann irgendwie mal, so er nutzt das aber immer ganz gut, finde ich. Und in der Ansicht hören wir uns das einfach dokumentarisch an, wie im Mai 2025 hier geredet wurde, der erste Clip. Geht über zwei Minuten, Daniel Gerlach berichtet mal, was zuletzt Regierungsmitglieder der israelischen Regierung zu Gaza sagten.
Die israelische Teile der israelischen Gesellschaft und der israelischen Opposition, die vielleicht politisch schwach ist derzeit, sind so dermaßen selbst schockiert über das Vorgehen ihrer eigenen Streitkräfte und versuchen natürlich jetzt ein Stück weit auch, das ganze nun Netanyahu in die Schuld zu schieben und sehen gerne darüber hinweg, dass auch viele andere politische Figuren in Israel diesen Krieg in den letzten Monaten sehr vorbehaltlos unterstützt haben und wenn sie etwas dagegen auszusetzen hatten, dann weil es nicht im Interesse der Befreiung der Geiseln war, dann weil es innenpolitischen Zielen von Netanyahu diente, aber Humanität gegenüber den Palästinensern in Gaza stand da eher an nachgeordneter Stelle. Nein, die das entsetzen, die Kritik ist mittlerweile groß und schau dir mal an, was Netanyahu gestern im Kabinett gesagt hat. Ich glaube, mehr muss man eigentlich über die Art und Weise, wie der Mensch derzeit denkt, nicht wissen. Der hat seinen eigenen Anhängern und Kabinettsmitgliedern gesagt, ich paraphrasiere jetzt mal, wir dürfen auf keinen Fall die Unterstützung unserer Freunde im Ausland dadurch verlieren, dass sie Bilder von einer Hungersnot in Gaza sehen. Das heißt, es geht nicht darum, das Leid der Palästinenser zu lindern, sondern es geht darum, einen PR-Desaster zu vermeiden. Und das ist offensichtlich eine Antwort gewesen auf diese Signale, die er aus Amerika bekommen hat, weil ich kann mir vorstellen, dass auch die Trumps Leute ihm gesagt haben, wir wollen nicht diese Bilder sehen. Und das ist natürlich ganz interessant. Dann hat der Finanzminister, Bezadez Motric, eine sehr wichtige Figur im Kabinett, auch wenn er gerne als Fringe und als Randfigur dargestellt wird in unseren Medien, hat tatsächlich gegenüber seinen Anhängern das verteidigt und gesagt, naja Leute, wir geben den Palästinensern ja nur einen Telepita und ein bisschen was zu essen, damit sie gerade so zu überleben. Und damit hat sich das. Dann haben wir unsere Verbündeten im Westen befriedigt. Das ist der Diskurs, der gerade geführt wird. Ein anderer Minister, der auch inländlich bekannt ist, Itamar Ben-Ghviye von der Partei Otsma Yehudid, hat gesagt, hat gestern noch eine Abstimmung im Kabinett gefordert über das Zulassen von humanitärer Hilfe für Gaza. Wurde dann von dem nationalen Sicherheitsberater offensichtlich zurechtgewiesen, der gesagt hat, wir brauchen dafür keine Zustimmung der Minister. Also das ist das Diskursniveau, mit dem wir es hier gerade zu tun haben.
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass, wenn jetzt mal wieder ein paar Hilfsgüter über die Grenze gehen nach Gazareien, dann wird die CDU sagen, ja seht ihr, jetzt ist wieder alles in Ordnung. Also das ist eigentlich das, was ja passiert. Also dass man nicht anspricht, dass wir es da mit einer ethnischen Säuberung zu tun haben. Man spricht nicht an, dass wir eine völlige Zerbombung haben. Ich meine, das ist 95 Prozent, das ist plattgemacht. Und dann sind immer noch Leute wie Ronzheimer, die sagen, ich will nicht von einem Flächenbombardement reden. Und man denkt so, ja.
Ja, ist alles wahnsinnig schräg. Mittlerweile ist ja die ethnische Säuberung auch als Trumps Plan. Da wird gar nicht mehr genannt. Das heißt dann einfach nur noch Trumps Plan. Und man stellt sich so dahinter und wie auch immer. Aber das ist ja dieses Riviera, diese Riviera Idee, dass da erst mal alle weg müssen und man dann den anderen Ländern, Ägypten, wie auch immer Vorwürfe macht, dass sie da keine Menschen aufnehmen und so. Also völlig durchgeknallt insgesamt. Und jetzt ist ja immer diese große Frage, wenn der Krieg selbst so eine Entität eignen Rechts ist, die sich einfach so einen Log-in-Effekt schafft und dann haben quasi alle Kriegspartei nur noch mit dem Krieg zu tun. Das ist ja hier auch und es ist ja immer dieses Phänomen, also für mich war das schon vor dieser aktuellen Auseinandersetzung. Also vor dem siebten Oktober, dass man eigentlich die palästinensische Regierung in der Klammer hat. Es findet ein Krieg gegen diese Regierung statt und zwar von der Hamas und der israelischen Regierung. Werden ja auch diese Clips gespielt, die da noch mal in der Tagesschau liefen oder in den Tagesthemen, dass die israelische Regierung Palästinenser nimmt, um sie schon mal in Häuser zu schicken, um zu gucken, ob da irgendwas explodiert oder so. Also eigentlich die klassische Idee des menschlichen Schutzschilds, aber eben nicht von der Hamas, sondern von der israelischen Regierung. Und Daniel Gerlach und Ronzheimer reden hier darüber.
Mit dem Argument, die Bombenhunde zu schonen.
Genau, die Bombenhunde zu schonen. Und die beiden reden hier darüber, wie jetzt diese Gemengelage Hamas und Palästinenser. Gibt es jetzt einen Auftrag an die Palästinenser, sich von der Hamas loszusagen, wenn ja, wie sollte das funktionieren, was auch immer. Das ist ja totaler Ausnahmezustand. Und das ist ehrlicherweise eine sehr hochtrabende politische Diskussion, weil ich bin jetzt auch kein Anhänger von Friedrich Merz, nur würde man mir es jetzt durchgehen lassen, wenn ich sage, ich wollte mich einfach nur von meinem Friedrich Merz-Kanzler befreien. Also das würde ja auch zu Turbulenzen führen, sag ich mal, wenn ich solche Versuche irgendwie machen würde.
In der Wahrnehmung, nicht nur der Hamas, und da war der große Fehler, glaube ich, sondern auch der palästinensischen Bevölkerung Gaza, war die Art und Weise der Kriegführung nicht gegen die Hamas gerichtet, sondern war ein Feldzug, der dazu diente, die gesamte palästinensische Bevölkerung zu bestrafen, keinerlei Rücksicht auf Zivilisten zu nehmen. Du sagst keinerlei Rücksicht, aber... Da kannst du gegen argumentieren, das wird mich den Punkt zu Ende bringen, aber das ist die Wahrnehmung, in der sich die Palästinenser im Gaza-Streifen befunden haben, und wenn du dir den Grad der Zerstörung anguckst, dann wird es auch sehr schwierig, dagegen zu argumentieren. Jetzt ist es so, du hast in dieser Situation natürlich die Möglichkeit gehabt, einen Keil zwischen die Palästinenser, zwischen der Bevölkerung und die Hamas zu treiben. Das kannst du aber nicht, wenn du die Bevölkerung kollektiv bestrafst und gegen die Bevölkerung vorgehst. Und das ist ja der entscheidende Vorwurf auch gewesen, den von Anfang an Fachleute, aber auch israelische Oppositionelle, israelische Journalisten der Regierung gemacht haben, dass sie zwar behauptet hat, dieser Krieg richtet sich nicht gegen die Bevölkerung, aber das Vorgehen, das Gegenteil im Grunde, den gegenteiligen Rückfluss nur erlauben konnte. Und das ist das große Problem in dieser Art und Weise der Kriegsführung, die nicht erst seit wenigen Wochen kritisiert wird, sondern im Grunde seit Beginn.
Ja, jetzt hat ja Ronsheimer ganz kurz am Anfang so, ja ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass sie so gar keine Rücksicht genommen haben. Und da kann man natürlich immer dieses, ja sie rufen ja vorher an oder was auch immer. Oder hier aus deutscher Richtung, ja aber die israelische Armee hat doch das als Kampfzone definiert. Warum sind die Leute denn da? So ja, also lauter so ein Firlefanz.
Irgendwann ist halt auch nicht mehr der andere Ort, den man besuchen kann, weil alles so kurz ist.
Wenn grundsätzlich eingezäunt ist, ist es halt schwierig. So, wie sollte man das jetzt aus, sagen wir mal, also ok, und sagen wir mal, man will nicht, dass es so der Totale, dass es als totaler Krieg angesehen wird. Gerlach versucht es hier mit Details und Beispielen, um einfach zu zeigen, ne, hier werden wirkliche echte Grenzen überschritten, auch wenn es noch andere Beispiele gäbe, wo das dann nicht so ist. Aber die Beispiele, die man nennen kann, sind auf jeden Fall Haarsträuben.
Die Logik, die dahinter steht, und die kritisiere ich ja, und die wird ja auch in Israel kritisiert, ist, ich möchte es jetzt nicht zu sehr zuspitzen, aber wenn in einem Kindergarten sich ein Terrorist verschanzt, dann ist doch die Frage, ob ich berechtigt bin, diesen Kindergarten zu bombardieren, die erübrigt sich doch, oder? Logischerweise nein. Auch wenn sich völkerrechtlich vielleicht dadurch ergeben könnte, dass dadurch, dass dort ein Terrorist sich befindet, ein Kindergarten keine zivile Einrichtung mehr ist. Aber ich bombardiere doch keinen Kindergarten, weil dort ein Terrorist ist, sondern muss dann halt, auch wenn dort ein Terrorist ist, auf die Gelegenheit warten, diesen Menschen zu treffen, wenn er sich nicht in einem Kindergarten befindet.
Ja, das scheint logisch.
Weil noch haben wir doch gerade aus unserer Sicht so eine Idee von Krieg geht, aber so bitte völkerrechtlich. Und das ist schon absurd genug, überhaupt so Gedanken zu haben. Und das hier nochmal einfordern zu müssen.
Ja, das ist ja genau diese Argumentation, wenn Leute von der CDU oder von der Springerpresse einfach sagen, Israel hat jedes Recht. Das stimmt ja nicht. Also Israel hat auch Rechte, wie alle anderen souveränen Staaten auch, aber niemand hat jedes Recht.
Ja, also hier haben wir es wirklich mit Problemlagen zu tun. Und deswegen macht es Gerlach auch nochmal ganz explizit. Kann man den Palästinensern selbst hier irgendwelche Vorwürfe machen?
Wenn man es mal überspitzt formuliert, warum schafft diese palästinensische Bevölkerung nicht, die Hamas in irgendeiner Form zu entmachten? Oder zumindest noch mehr Druck auszuüben? Was passiert da gerade in Gaza?
Das finde ich zum Beispiel allein die Fragestellung. Paul Ronsheimer ist ansonsten in allen anderen Podcasts zu Gast. Heute Morgen erst wieder bei Gordon Rypinski. Um darüber zu berichten, was vor Ort passiert. Um eine Lageeinschätzung zu geben, die wir durch reinen Medienkonsum nicht haben. Diese Frage, warum schafft es die palästinensische Bevölkerung nicht, sich gegen die Hamas aufzuladen? Er weiß selber, was die Antwort auf diese Frage ist. Und er weiß selber, wie absurd diese Frage ist. Und er hat das die letzten Jahre dort miterlebt.
Es ist ja ein völliger Ausnahmezustand, in dem nicht in irgendeiner Weise noch eine politische Mobilisierung stattfinden kann. Also bei uns geht die Wahlbeteiligung runter, wenn es regnet. Dann sagen die Leute, das ist mir eigentlich jetzt schon zu viel. Und hier, wo alles in Schutt und Asche liegt, sagt man, warum machen die eigentlich jetzt nicht gerade einen Widerstand?
Ja, warum findet da keine Demo statt oder sowas? Also die Frage selbst ist schon völlig neben der Spur.
So Berliner Aktivismus, so Fridays for Future oder so. Warum jetzt gerade nicht in Gaza?
Also sie entwertet, finde ich auch, Ronsheimers Expertise, die ansonsten sein Aushängeschild ist, für alle seine journalistischen Tätigkeiten. Diese Frage kann man so nicht stellen, beziehungsweise die Antwort ergibt sich von sich selbst. Dennoch, er hat sie so gestellt und gerne auch antwortet.
Ich bin ja nicht in Gaza. Ich kenne viele Leute in Gaza und viele Leute aus Gaza. Aber ich kann damit, ich kann da nur so wie du, nicht als Experte, sondern menschlich spekulieren.
Wenn ich dieses menschliche Spekulieren, übrigens, das ist diese große, bisschen vulgär jetzt von mir, Unterscheidung zwischen Historikern und Soziologen. Historiker suchen immer noch die Quelle und graben dann irgendwie um und gucken so, wie viele Kühe standen in dem Stall, wie viele Leute haben hier gelebt, wie auch immer. Der Soziologe macht sich so allgemeine Gedanken und denkt sich einfach, es geht hier um menschliches Leben. Wir dürfen hier ein bisschen spekulieren, denn wir kennen die Boundaries und Limits.
Ja, wir wissen, wie Menschen sich in größeren Kuppen organisieren, was sie davon abhalten kann, sich zu organisieren.
Wir brauchen keine Quelle dafür, dass es wahrscheinlich keine Aliens waren, die die Pyramiden gebaut haben. Das müssen die Menschen irgendwie hingekriegt haben. Und wenn wir noch nicht genau wissen, wie, dann müssen wir da noch ein bisschen drüber nachdenken. Und nicht nur im Boden nach finden wir noch Werkzeuge, sondern uns einfach mal Gedanken machen, wie würde man es denn machen? Also diese menschliche Spekulation ist, es klingt ja so salopp, menschliche Spekulation, aber es ist ganz konkret, jeder wohnt in einem Stadtteil. Angenommen, man lebt selber noch in dem allerletzten Gebäude, das nicht komplett zerschossen wurde. Wie würde man sich fühlen? Und darauf findet man eine Antwort, und das ist dann die Antwort. Man braucht jetzt keine, oh Herr Ronzheimer, danke, dass du nochmal bei mir bist im Podcast, um darüber zu berichten, oder ich bin ja nicht in Gaza, das sind alles ja, ja, schön und gut und so. Wir sind ja wirklich beim Elementaren angekommen. Warum lehnen sich die Menschen da nicht gegen die Hamas auf?
Den ganzen Tag und die ganze Nacht Angst haben muss, dass ich von einer israelischen Bombe wohne oder einem Scharfschützen getötet werde, wenn ich nicht weiß, wie ich meine Kinder ernähren soll. Glaubst du, dann habe ich noch Energie zu demonstrieren und mich gegen die Hamas aufzulehnen, weil ich weiß, okay, wenn ich das mache und die Hamas dann loswerde, wahrscheinlich werde ich dann von denen umgebracht, dann wird Israel aufhören, mich zu bombardieren. Verstehst du, die Wahrnehmung der Palästinenser in Gaza ist, egal was wir machen, egal wo wir stehen, dieser Krieg ist dazu da, um uns zu bestrafen, um sich an uns zu rächen und um uns von hier zu vertreiben. Und dieses Narrativ befeuern und bestätigen, israelische Politiker, tagtäglich. Vor zwei Tagen hat einen...
Ja, und dann kommt die nächste. Also, diese Herangehensweise an Gaza ist einfach, du hast jetzt schon den Brückenschlag zu manchen deutschen Diskussionen, es regnet und die Leute gegen dich wählen. Genau, wir haben Bürgermeister Wahlkämpfe, wo es irgendwie heißt, der Bürgermeister arbeitet sich den Arsch auf, er ist jeden Tag bei drei Podiumsdiskussionen, das Publikum ist eingeladen. Und niemand braucht eine Erklärung dafür, weil jeder es von selbst versteht, warum war niemals bei irgendeiner Veranstaltung, irgendwo in Deutschland, für irgendeine Lokalpolitik eine 28-jährige, alleinerziehende Mutter mit zwei Kindern. Warum sitzen da immer nur alte Leute? Diese Frage ist geklärt, wir wissen warum. Wir müssen da nicht Ronzheimer fragen.
Warum ist nicht der Lieferantlobboote da?
Genau, genau. Weil der gerade arbeitet. Also manche Sachen sind einfach ganz einfach zu beantworten durch menschliche Spekulation. Da muss man nicht in Gaza sein, da muss man nicht in Stuttgart sein, man weiß genau wie es läuft. Und hier in Gaza, wir sehen diese Bilder, wir wissen doch genau wie es da gerade läuft.
Da ist kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen.
Niemand braucht jetzt Gespräch mit Netanyahu, niemand mit Merz, niemand mit irgendwas. Wir wissen genau was da läuft. Und ich finde, wir sollten es auch auf dieser menschliche Spekulation wirklich mal runterbrechen und nicht anfangen mit, ach die Palästinenser und die große Geschichte, sondern, nee, jetzt gerade ist da nicht die Palästinenser und die große Geschichte, sondern da sind einfach Menschen. Und in diesem Monat, in dem wir Margot Friedländer beerdigen und dann nochmal sagen, seid Menschen, ist das genau dieser Appell. Niemand braucht mehr als diese zwei Worte, seid Menschen. Und da ist einfach gerade niemand so richtig Mensch in Gaza. Und das ist das Problem.
Und wenn jetzt von Konservativ und Mittelseite immer gesagt wird, ja, das ist eine humanitäre Katastrophe, dann überdeckt das ja völlig, dass das politisch gemacht ist. Aber wenn wir mal bei dem Humanitären bleiben würden und sagen, ja, das ist eine humanitäre Katastrophe, dann müsste man ja dann sagen, dann schließen wir da raus, eine Politik, die wir eigentlich bei humanitären Katastrophen machen. Wir helfen zum Beispiel dadurch, dass wir Flüchtlinge aufnehmen. Das wäre ja dann das wenigste, was zu tun ist. Das mindeste, was zu tun ist. Und das ist ja auch nicht das, was jetzt gefordert wird. Ist ja auch interessant. Ich will noch einen Clip zum Thema Gaza spielen. Es kommt selten vor, dass Robin Alexander die SPD und die Grünen lobt. Er hat das aber getan im Ronzheimer Podcast. Und wir hören uns mal an, was das für ein Lob ist und schauen mal, ob wir dieses Lob teilen.
Und hier möchte ich einmal eine Lanze für die SPD und die Grünen brechen. Die haben nämlich der Versuchung widerstanden, die viele andere linke Parteien in Europa nicht widerstanden haben, auf eine sehr maßlos kritische, Sie Spanier zum Beispiel. Genau, kritische Israele Position zu gehen. Und vor allen Dingen die Grünen haben dafür einen Preis gezahlt. Die Wiederaufstehung der Linkspartei hat nicht nur mit Heidi Reichinek und Tanzvideos zu tun, hat auch damit zu tun, dass in bestimmten migrantischen Vierteln, ich lebe in Neukölln, wo es hat ein Linkspartei-Mensch gewonnen, die haben einfach eine Position der harten Israel-Kritik besetzt, die die Grünen bewusst ausgeschlagen haben. Anders als linke Parteien in anderen Ländern Europas. Also da ist für Israel-Solidarität links der Mitte auch ein Preis gezahlt worden, auch bei der Wahl und das sollte man anerkennen. Absolut.
Man kann ja, wie viele Streiten habe ich ja hier auch schon mehrmals debattiert, dass mir da einige Aktivisten auch ja besorgniserregend vorkommen. Aber was man ja festhalten kann ist, dass hier ein Lob ausgesprochen wird dafür, dass SPD und Grüne die Augen verschlossen haben vor einer Realität, die einfach da ist. Und da musste man nicht irgendein radikaler Aktivist sein und nicht ein Feind Israels oder irgendetwas, um zu erkennen, dass das, was da gerade in Gaza passiert, nicht sein kann. Und das konnte man schon lange erkennen. Und ich hab ja schon mal darauf hingewiesen, in der Financial Times, nach einigen Wochen des Krieges, ist da schon dieser Artikel erschienen, wo man sagte, jetzt ist genug, wir brauchen dringend eine Waffenruhe, das führt zu nichts. Und diese Artikel haben sich ja in der ganz seriösen Presse geholft. Wir hatten hier schon vor vielen Monaten Podcast Clips gespielt, vom New York Times Podcast, vom Daily Podcast über die Situation in Gaza. Also da sind wir ja in der Mitte des liberalen Amerikas. Also das ist ja jetzt nicht, dass man sagt, man läuft irgendwelchen Aktivisten hinterher und versucht da mal ein paar Infos zu bekommen, sondern das ist ja in der Mitte, hat ja längst stattgefunden. Und genau davor hat die deutsche Politik und haben dann auch Grüne und der SPD-ler die Augen verschlossen. Und dass das jetzt noch mal gelobt wird von Robin Alexander, da sollte man sich also, wenn man einer dieser beiden Parteien angehört, doch mal die Frage stellen, ob man dieses Lob haben möchte.
Ich muss ja eh zum Ende dieses Themas mal sagen, nachdem ich ja jetzt häufiger Tagesschau mit unserem Nachwuchs gucke und so, und mich auch sonst, also ich finde das wahnsinnig interessant. Nicht nur werden diese Augen so vor Gaza verschlossen, sondern man hört ja an diesem Sing-Sang von Robin Alexander auch noch, dass man sich selbst so eine Deutungshoheit andichtet. Ja. Während im Osten schon 45 Prozent AfD wählen, wo man natürlich einfach sagen kann, naja gut, die sind abgedreht, wie auch immer. Es gibt zu viele Erklärungen. Aber sehr viele Leute sind gerade sehr abgedreht und die sehen sowas und hören sowas und die denken aber mit. Also, ich bin ja ein sehr zynischer Tagesschaugucker und ich halte mich sehr zurück, wenn ich das mit meiner Tochter gucke. Aber ich muss sie bremsen, weil das ist einfach absurd. Man kommt doch mit menschlicher Intuition, Erfahrung und eben Lust auf Spekulation in dieses Geschehen und hört diese Leute reden.
Ja, das ist genauso, wenn Anne Will und Marcella sagen, wie füllen wir denn mal die Armee auf? Also jedes Kind versteht dann ja im Moment auffüllen. Das heißt, ich sterbe dann und dann wird irgendwie ein Freund von mir dann kommen und der füllt mich auf. Also jedes Kind versteht das eigentlich.
Jeder versteht das und jeder macht sich da auch Gedanken drüber. Und das hier aber immer noch so ein, wir erklären es jetzt mal. Ich habe ja diesen Einglips von Robin Alexander, wie er da am Deutschlandfunk so, ne wir können eigentlich immer mehr uns erklären und so. Er versucht, sich immer das weiter zu erklären und nochmal. So kriege ich es nochmal hin. Aber eigentlich denkt man anders. Also wir kriegen ja auch Reaktionen auf unseren Podcasts, wo wir immer wieder hören. Ja klar, alle denken so. Niemand ist diese Berliner Blase, diese Ronzheimer Gordon-Repinsky und so weiter. Die machen sich wirklich lächerlich mittlerweile.
Wir wollen kurz darauf hinweisen, dass es im August einen Live-Salon gibt. Am 23. August sind wir in Frankfurt zu erleben. Dort im ganz großen Saal, dort gibt es dann Live-Podcasts und auch natürlich davor und danach die Möglichkeit uns zu treffen, mit uns zu sprechen. Die Karten findet man ganz einfach. Man geht auf die Homepage von Die Case in Frankfurt, findet dort den Termin, da ist ein Saalplan. Im Mittelblock ist ja auch fast alles schon weg, aber an den Seiten, an denen man auch sehr gut sehen kann, sind Plätze noch verfügbar.
Wolfgang kommt dann die Treppe runter, die Gänge entlang zu euch, wenn ihr euch zu weit wegfühlt.
Wir können schönes Medley singen oder so.
Nein, wir singen nicht. Oder vielleicht.
Vielleicht willst du ja singen.
Ich will nur antisat, aber wir singen nicht. Das weiß ich.
Nee, ich werde dich ja wenn aufgefordert, dass du mal singst.
No.
Dann wollte ich noch darauf hinweisen, dass ich im Juni zu erleben bin in der Schweiz wieder, in der schönen Schweiz. Einmal in Zürich am 6.6. Dort wird der Film gezeigt, die Bekenntnisse des Hochstaplers Thomas Mann. Das ist eine Doku-Fiktion. Das spreche ich im Anschluss mit dem Hauptdarsteller. Und dann, am 7.6., findet wenige Kilometer weiter in Kilchberg ein ganzer Tag zu Ehren von Thomas Mann statt. Dort geht es dann zum Beispiel auch um Thomas Mann und seine politischen Interventionen auf dem Exil heraus. Da sind mehrere Diskussionen geplant, die ich dann moderieren werde. Das findet man alles auf meiner Homepage. Und am 11.6. bin ich in Berlin und spreche mit dem Schriftsteller Franz Friedrich über den Roman Die Toten Seelen. Das kann man alles da finden.
Ich war im Radio erstaunlicherweise eine Einladung wegen unserer Spotify-Besprechung von Liz Pelli. Ich fand das dann ganz interessant, weil ich so als der Publikumsvertreter eingeladen wurde, neben Christopher Annen, Musiker und Ina Brothoch, glaube ich heißt sie, Musikkritikerin in Köln. Und ich habe dann spontan noch viel mehr ein. Wir sind ja auch Produzenten auf Seiten Spotify mit dem Podcast, was ich noch nie in Honorar gekriegt habe von Spotify und so. Das kommt am Sonntagabend beim WDR 3 und das WDR 3 Forum. Das könnt ihr euch mal anhören. Sonst habe ich keine Termine, allerdings bevor wir Geoökonomie. Ich habe eine Frage an unsere Hörer. Unsere kleine Bürogemeinschaft 1789 und ich suchen für sechs Leute in Frankfurt ein neues Büro. 150 Quadratmeter, möglichst gut gelegen, schön. Humann sagt Budget ist nichts entscheidend. Wir suchen ein schönes Büro in Frankfurt. Möchte uns jemand in seiner Nähe haben? Kennt jemand etwas? Schreibt mir doch bitte. Wir suchen bis Jahresende, dann müssen wir umziehen.
Und wir wollten auch noch sagen, vielleicht hören hier manche Leute zu, die irgendetwas Interessantes haben, ein Unternehmen oder so, was wir bewerben könnten. Wir sind ja durchaus offen für Werbung. Allerdings findet diese Werbung dann nur für die Leute statt, die uns nicht abonniert haben. Das heißt also, die vor der Paywall bleiben. Das könnte sein, dass die auch mal von uns eine Werbung gesprochen bekommen. Also wenn da jemand Interesse hat, einfach melden bei den Neuen Zwanzigern. Also wenn es in irgendeiner Weise passt. Wenn ihr glaubt, es passt zu uns. Wenn das vielleicht Stefan irgendein neues Gadget, das er dringend bewerben muss oder neue KI. Wir wollen aber jetzt vor allem, weil Werbung ja nur mal so die Idee ist, ob das funktioniert, wir wollen aber vor allem darauf hinweisen, dass wir ja davon leben, dass ihr uns unterstützt, nämlich in Form einer Mitgliedschaft im Salon. Und in diesem Salon sprechen wir immer über ein Buch, das wir gemeinsam gelesen haben. Und außerdem diskutieren wir dann noch weitere Texte, die wir uns gegenseitig vorstellen, die für den Monat wichtig waren. Bei mir gibt es auch immer noch einen Musiktipp. Jetzt sprechen wir über ein Buch gemeinsam, das den Titel trägt, Geoökonomie, Anatomie der neuen Weltordnung von Milan Babic erschienen bei Zurkamp. Es geht darum, dass er diagnostiziert, dass die neoliberale Globalisierung nicht mehr unserer Wirklichkeit entspricht. In welcher Zeit leben wir also dann? Und was kann eigentlich dieser neue Grundbegriff Geoökonomie leisten, zur Erklärung der Welt? Wir haben viel über Geopolitik gesprochen, aber das Ökonomische kommt ja da oft ein bisschen zu kurz. Das ist also ein Buch, das sicherlich interessant sein wird, darüber zu diskutieren. Das kann man dann im Salon hören. Wie kommt man in den Salon?
Man geht für alles, was uns betrifft, zum Beispiel auch die Cast-Tickets und so. Auf neuezwanziger.de, dort findet man einen goldenen Button, der heißt Salon, der hängt auch so ein kleiner Wimpel dran. Und dann ist man schon auf der Seite von Steady. Wir präferieren Steady. Man kann den Salon auch über Apple direkt hören. Oder über Patreon, wenn man da schon einen Account hat. Da gibt es aber nicht das ganze Archiv. Das findet man insgesamt bei Steady. Mit dem Vorteil, wenn man bei Steady Abonnent ist, muss man sonst nichts mehr von uns abonnieren. Dann kriegt man alles über Steady. Und NeueZwanziger, goldener Button, sich dann dort ein Paket aussuchen. Und ab dann kann man nochmal alle 50, 60, 70 Buchbesprechungen, die wir bisher so hatten, nachhören, wenn man so viel Zeit hat.
Ja, es ist jedenfalls ein Archiv, auf wo man nochmal was herholen kann, wenn man es gerade braucht. Also man muss jetzt natürlich nicht da chronologisch durchgehen. Jedenfalls würden wir uns freuen, wenn ihr den Podcast auf diese Weise unterstützt. Kommen wir zu dem Thema, das eigentlich schon anknüpft an das Buch, das wir dann lesen werden, nämlich Geopolitik und Geoökonomie. Wir haben ja jetzt hier viel über Trump und seine Zölle schon gesprochen, bzw. sagen immer wieder, wie verrückt das alles ist, was Trump macht und so weiter. Und ja, dann höre ich, sein Sohn ist gerade in Vietnam unterwegs, um wieder irgendwelche Hotelgeschäfte zu machen. Wir sehen also auch diese private Bereicherung mit den Coins und was er dann gerade in den arabischen Staaten tut. All das suggeriert natürlich auch immer, jetzt ist wieder Trump, jetzt ist alles anders. Und ich habe mich aber dann doch gefragt, gibt es irgendwelche Kontinuitäten? Also gibt es Kontinuitäten? Trump 1, Biden, Trump 2. Es gibt natürlich diese persönliche Bereicherung und diese unendliche Schamlosigkeit, die überhaupt nicht vergleichbar ist mit dem, was jetzt die Biden-Administration tat oder Kamala Harris getan hätte. Aber es gibt doch vielleicht, wenn wir über die Geopolitik und über die Ökonomie sprechen, so eine große Kontinuität. Und dann habe ich was gemacht. Ich habe mir einen Vortrag angehört von dem Joe Biden Security Advisor Jake Sullivan oder wie Joe Biden in schlechteren Tagen sagte, Steve, der vor zwei Jahren in der Brookings Institution einen Vortrag gehalten hat. Er war eingeladen als Sicherheitsberater, um über Wirtschaft zu sprechen, was an sich schon ein bisschen komisch ist. Und dieser Vortrag, der ist jetzt sicherlich in Deutschland nicht viel rezipiert wurde, der wurde aber in geostrategischen Kreisen schon hellhörig begutachtet. Ich hab den immer liegen lassen, aber manchmal ist es gut, wenn man erst etwas sehr viel später hört. Und erging mir jetzt so. Wir hören jetzt Clips aus diesem Vortrag und versuchen mal über Kontinuitäten nachzudenken.
After the Second World War, the United States led a fragmented world to build a new international economic order. It lifted hundreds of millions of people out of poverty. It sustained thrilling technological innovations. And it helped the United States and many other countries around the world achieve new levels of prosperity. But the last few decades revealed cracks in those foundations. A shifting global economy left many working Americans and their communities behind.
Aha, die Globalisierung war eigentlich eine Volksgeschichte. Viele Menschen wurden aus der Armut gehoben weltweit. Aber wie ist es mit der heimischen Industrie und mit den heimischen Arbeitsplätzen? Da sieht es ein bisschen anders aus. Hier schlägt also jemand ganz klar globalisierungskritische Töne an. Und er sagt dann folgendes noch.
So, this moment demands that we forge a new consensus. That's why the United States under President Biden is pursuing a modern industrial and innovation strategy, both at home and with partners around the world.
New consensus meint also, er erklärt den Washingtoner Konsensus, den Washingtoner Konsensus als passé. Er sagt damit also diese globale Ordnung an die wir glauben mit Freihandel und all dem, dass es für uns jetzt nicht mehr relevant. Uns geht es um die heimische Industrie und es geht dann um Partnerschaften. Wie diese Partnerschaften aussehen, werden wir gleich noch hören. Aber was wir hier also ganz klar sehen, ist natürlich ein Make America Great Again. Wir müssen nur jetzt erkennen, es ist eine völlig andere Rhetorik. Es ist also überhaupt nicht vergleichbar mit den Auftritten von Trump. Aber es gibt doch sehr große Parallelen. Er sagt auch über die Industrie.
Das ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, weil der neue Economy, wie heißt er, ist ja auch so eine Senatsgemachte Stelle von dem Stephen Myron, dem Economy Advisor, Chief Economy Advisor, genau, der ja mit Besant zusammen diesen Maralago Akkord entwickelt hat, den wir so ausführlich besprochen hatten, wo es ja genau darum ging. Die Globalisierung bedeutet freigeschlossene Handelsrouten und eben diese Währung, die einfach überall genutzt werden kann, auch zwischen China und Brasilien und so, war ja sein Beispiel, nur eben auf Kosten der heimischen Industrie. Und dann lachen wir heute über Trumps Herangehensweise, zu sagen, okay, dann machen wir die Produkte teurer, sodass die in Amerika selbst hergestellt werden müssen. Und plötzlich müssen die Amerikaner wieder ihre Kugelschreiber selbst zusammenschrauben und so was. Aber in der Anlage, in der Problembeschreibung gibt es hier diese Kontinuität. Also jetzt hören wir das wie hier dann der Security Advisor, diese Außenpolitik von beiden.
Ja, das war ja mal wichtiger. Der Export war ja mal wichtiger für die USA, es sind immer weniger geworden. Das wird hier problematisiert. Hinzu kommt, dass er auch das BEP nicht als die eigentliche Kategorie mehr sehen will, an der man die Politik misst. Denn normalerweise bedeutete das ja im Washingtoner Konsens zu bleiben, das BEP geht nach oben, ich mache eine gute Politik, ich werde wiedergewählt, das ist erfolgreich, die Presse ist begeistert.
Das ist sowieso interessant, finde ich. Wir haben ja im Fernsehpodcast ganz lange immer diese amerikanischen Nachrichten geschaut und da war immer völlig klar, Verschuldung, Staatsschulden, BEP, das spielt da gar keine große Rolle. Also so wie in Deutschland immer minus 0,2 Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum und dann ist sofort eine Maibrit-Illner-Sendung dazu. Und Linneman muss sich erklären, das ist ja in Amerika schon seit einer Weile nicht mehr, dass diese Känze von so wichtig sind, sondern da kam immer einfach die nächste Kampagne, die gefragt hat, geht es dir eigentlich besser oder schlechter als vorher? Und dann wurde das alles so ein bisschen aus deutscher Sicht so gefühlig, aber natürlich viel näher dran, so am realen Leben diskutiert.
Another embedded assumption was that the type of growth didn't matter. All growth was good growth. So various reforms combined came together to privilege some sectors of the economy, like finance, while other essential sectors, like semiconductors and infrastructure, atrophied.
Das finde ich super interessant, weil das ist ja auch Trump 1 gewesen, Hauptsache die Börsenwerte stimmen. Und jetzt sieht man, ne, die Börsenwerte stimmen gar nicht und es ist auch eine Rezension, aber die Bevölkerung so, ne, das ist noch nicht so entscheidend für uns, solange wir es nicht fühlen.
Ja und Trump geht auf direkte Konfrontation mit dem wichtigsten Börsenunternehmen, nämlich Apple.
Ja, genau.
Sagt denen, jetzt produziert wieder hier und Tim Cook sagt dann, ne, eigentlich nicht. Und Tim Cook hat ja eigentlich während der ersten Amtszeit ein gutes Verhältnis zu Trump. Der hat sich nie in irgendeinen Kulturkampf einspannen lassen, da ist er ja auch wirklich nicht der Typ für. Aber das war schon so, ich habe hier die Lieferketten unter Kontrolle, ich produziere, das ist das wichtigste Unternehmen, das Flaggschiff von Amerika. Das ist der Ausweis für die größte Innovation, die wir haben. Und ich muss natürlich auch mit einem Trump mich verstehen, und das tat er ja auch. Und dass aber jetzt Trump dagegen vorgeht, also dass Apple einfach sagt, wir verlagern jetzt die Produktion so ein bisschen von China nach Indien, da sagt Trump, nein, das reicht uns nicht. Ja, das reicht uns nicht. Das soll wieder hier in den USA stattfinden. Und dass er damit die Börsenwerte natürlich mindert, überhaupt mit dieser ganzen Zollpolitik, ist also eine Änderung. Und die Kontinuität natürlich ist die, dass wir ja noch gar nicht über den Elefanten im Raum gesprochen haben, und der ist selbstredend China.
Die Republik der Menschen von China kann sich auf einer massiven Ebene sowohl traditionelle industrielle Sektoren, wie Stahl, als auch für die nötigen Industrie der Zukunft, wie klinische Energie, digitale Infrastruktur und v.a.
Stahl.
Denkt man auch immer direkt an Thyssen Krupp oder so? Wenn man sich das dann ansieht, Thyssen Krupp ist irgendwo auf Platz 41, Ich bin der weltweiten Stahlproduzenten. Wenn du dir die ersten zehn Plätze ansiehst, dann hast du dort China und nochmal ein, zwei Mal Indien. Das ist dann die Produktion.
Bei Stahl könnte man sogar, ein amerikanisch-europäischen Schulterschluss wurde ja auch versucht. Dieser ganze Importzoll-Anpassungsmechanismus von Ursula von der Leyen war ja nur auf Stahl bezogen am Anfang, wegen dieser Überproduktion von 400 Millionen Tonnen im Jahr aus China. Das ist natürlich viel zu viel.
Wir sehen also, China ist das Problem. Was möchte er jetzt dann für eine neue Außenpolitik? Also wir sind jetzt hier in einem anderen Rahmen. Wir sind nicht bei Trump, der dann einfach sagt, China, China, China, sondern er muss das natürlich jetzt verkaufen, einmal als, ja eine gewisse Nachhaltigkeitspolitik spielt da eine Rolle, aber es ist auch so eine Idee für die Mitte.
All of that is part of what we have called a foreign policy for the middle class.
Das ist also das, was die beiden Administrationen anstrebt, bedeutet aber, es ist eigentlich eine Anti-China-Politik, die man aber natürlich rhetorisch damit verkauft, dass man hat, das hilft der Mitte, wie ja Trump auch sagt, ich bringe am Ende die Industrie zurück, euch die Jobs und all das, das hilft, Jobs, Jobs, Jobs. Sullivan spricht jetzt auch über die Rohstoffe in den USA.
Oder siehe die kritischen Minerale, das Hintergrund der klinischen Energiefutur. Heute produziert die USA nur 4% des Lithium, 13% des Kobalt, 0% des Nickel und 0% des Graphit, das für elektrische Fahrzeuge in Bezug auf den current-demand befindet. Währenddessen werden mehr als 80% der kritischen Minerale von einem Land, China, produziert. Klinische Energiefutur-Zahnschäden werden in der gleichen Art als die Öl in den 1970er-Jahren oder die natürlichen Gasen in Europa im Jahr 2022.
Behalten wir das mal im Hinterkopf. Es geht also darum, dass die erneuerbaren Möglichkeiten der Mobilität, die erneuerbare Energie, all das basiert natürlich auch darauf, dass man seltene Erden und so etwas hat. Und er bezieht sich jetzt wieder darauf, dass China das gerade alles alleine in der Hand hat. Bedeutet also auch, wenn wir über erneuerbare Energien und so was sprechen, dann hat das sehr viel mit Autarkiebestrebungen zu tun. Bedeutet das eigentlich, dass man Ego-Monie möglicherweise verlieren kann. Das aber erst später, denn wir bleiben nicht bei Jake Sullivan. Wir werden gleich noch zu Adam Toos übergehen. Sullivan spricht jetzt über die Partner, also über die westlichen Länder, mit denen man kooperiert oder andere Länder. Bedeutet hier ja erst mal so, wir strecken freundschaftlich die Hand aus, meint aber natürlich auch, ihr müsst jetzt mit uns diesen Weg gehen. Das heißt, ihr müsst euch auch von anderen Partnern, die nicht auf unserer Seite sind, also vor allem China, lösen.
Ja, ich erinnere mich noch, wie die Europäische Kommission wütend war, nachdem es hieß, die Amerikaner geben zu viel Geld für Subventionen usw. aus und die machen uns hier platt und die ziehen jetzt die ganzen und so. Und jetzt heißt es plötzlich, die ziehen uns zu viel Geld aus der Tasche, weil sie irgendwie verlangen, dass wir die Zollleistung erbringen. Also das Pendel schlägt ganz schön weit hin und her.
Und ich meine, es war ja auch so, als der Krieg in der Ukraine begann, hatte sich ja Macron öffentlich auch im Fernsehen darüber empört, dass die Amerikaner jetzt Energie an Europa verkaufen, aber zum dreifachen Preis, den die Amerikaner dafür zahlen müssen. Und natürlich waren diese großen Subventionspakete der IRA und folgendes eine, ja, waren Angriff auf Europa, beziehungsweise sagte, wir geben jetzt schon in der ganzen Sache den Ton an. Interessanterweise kommt Sullivan in diesem zwei Jahre alten Vortrag auf Zölle zu sprechen. Er sagt jetzt natürlich nicht, wie Trump und dann kommen da 30 Prozent und dann 50 Prozent drauf, aber er spricht interessant darüber. Das kritisiert er. Er will, also er sagt nicht, das kann er nicht tun als Security Advisor, ist nicht das, wofür er...
Ja, das ist interessant, dass er hier so eine...
Also er als Security-Advisor, muss man wirklich noch mal sagen, hält eine Wirtschaftsrede. Er kann natürlich jetzt nicht sagen, und wir müssten eigentlich Zölle erheben, das geht über seine Kompetenzen hinaus.
Also ich finde, hier ging schon einiges über seine Kompetenzen hinaus.
Es ist tatsächlich verwunderlich. Und ich würde aber behaupten, diese Rede, die auch abgelesen ist, also die ist abgesprochen, der redet hier nicht mal so auf Teufel komm rauslos, wie er die Welt sieht, sondern das ist wirklich die beiden Administrationen, die spricht, die natürlich jetzt vorsichtig ist bei der Ankündigung von Zöllen, aber durchaus dem nicht so skeptisch gegenüber steht, wie das jetzt gerade so erscheint. Ja, der Trump ist der Verrückte mit den Zöllen. Keineswegs. Worum geht es in der Handelspolitik?
Einfach zu sagen, in der heutigen Welt muss die Geschäftspolitik mehr als die Terrorproduktion sein und die Geschäftspolitik muss in unsere ökonomische Strategie im Heim integriert werden.
Geoökonomische Strategie. Also wir haben jetzt hier schon das Buch quasi vorweggenommen, die große Strategie muss natürlich die sein, wie können wir, also die USA, sich gegenüber dem Rivalen China behaupten, um Hegemonie zu bleiben?
Er sagt dann auch, We are protecting our foundational technologies with a small yard and a high fence.
Er findet mehrmals in dieser Rede auch lobende Worte für Ursula von der Leyen, die diesen Washingtoner Kurs ja mitgefahren hat. Dann, also der neue Washingtoner Konsens, dass sie sagte, ja, wir denken jetzt auch über Zölle nach auf E-Autos von China und all das.
Zoll-Grenzanpassungsmechanismus hat sie es genannt.
Sehr schön. Zest natürlich das ideale Wort für sowas.
Ein Wort an China mehr breit. Wie Präsident von der Leyen es letztendlich gesagt hat, wir sind für Zerstörungen und Diversifizierung, nicht Zerstörungen.
Ja, das war ja der große Sing-Sang mit bis hin zum Außen, Auswärtigen Amt.
Der Zerstörungen ist ein Begriff, der wirklich von der Leyen geprägt wurde und den haben die Amerikaner übernommen. Also sehr selten, dass das so geht. Normalerweise ist der umgekehrte Weg der Fall. Er bezieht sich da mehrmals positiv.
Baerbock hat den ja auch so hofiert, diesen Begriff. Und es war aber immer klar, das ist so ein Verlegenheitsbegriff. Weil wir sehen ja heute, wie man da nicht rauskommt. Und auch in dieser Diskussion, ich hab grad nochmal nachgeguckt, also es gab damals schon einen Economic Advisor, aber der war grad im Wechsel im März. 2023 wurde Cecilia Ruess ausgewechselt und dann Jared Bernstein eingewechselt. Also wahrscheinlich ist er einfach in diese Kompetenzlücke reingesprungen, um hier so einen Punkt zu machen. Denn am Ende, das werden wir ja dann lesen, Geoökonomie, sind das nicht trennbare Fragen.
Neuerdings, also das vorher war so primates ökonomischen.
Aber wir haben ja jetzt auch so Bücher wie, Autor weiß ich grad nicht, Apple in China, wo beschrieben wird und der Typ war ja nun überall zu Gast, stundenlang bei God Galloway und in der Daily Show und so. Und Apple hat in China drei Millionen Menschen ertüchtigt, Smartphones zu bauen. Und zwar nicht nur für Apple, sondern grundsätzlich. Foxconn könnte plötzlich Smartphones bauen. Und zwar so wie Apple, die selber niemals in Amerika bauen wird. Das ist nicht nur eine Kapital, sondern dann auch wirklich eine Kompetenzfrage und so. Und diese ganze Idee, es jetzt eben nicht über diesen Weg zu machen, also so vorsichtig und dann hier so Pension und so weiter, sondern das mit dieser Zollschranke, das ist mir dann auch jetzt nochmal deutlich geworden, weil Trump hat ja Apple jetzt richtig auf den Kicker und es gibt ja jetzt gezielte Zollandrohung nur für iPhones, 25 Prozent.
Und dann hat er sich korrigiert und hat dann für alle Smartphones, die hier produziert werden, gesagt, das ist ein Apple-Zoll.
Das ist ein Apple-Zoll. Und das Interessante ist ja, über die Brechstange ist das gar nicht zu machen. Wenn man sich die Kennziffern anschaut, wenn das iPhone an der Grenze 25 Prozent Preisaufschlag erhält, ergibt sich damit gar kein Druck, auch nur ein iPhone mehr in Amerika zu herzustellen. Sondern man sagt sich einfach, ja gut, 25 Prozent zahlen wir. Selbst bei 100 Prozent wird der Apple noch sagen, es würde sich nicht lohnen, in die Anstrengungen zu gehen, hier in Amerika zu bauen. Wir lägen immer über diesen 100 Prozent Zoll.
War es die New York Times oder eine der großen?
Also wenn sie 250 Zoll oder so androhen und dann hätte man vielleicht in 10 Jahren Apple soweit.
War es die New York Times oder eine andere große Zeitung? Die haben noch mal ausgerechnet, was das kosten würde, wenn man das iPhone tatsächlich, hätte man auch das Know-how in Amerika produzieren wollen würde, dann käme man bei einem iPhone Preis von über 3000 Dollar raus. Also es ist der dreifache Preis vom allerbesten iPhone, das es gibt.
Also alles unter einer 200 Zoll, einer echten Zollgrenze. Wäre gar kein Incentive hinsichtlich dieser Politik, wie Trump sie jetzt macht. Also man muss es tatsächlich so ein bisschen filigran.
Genau, macht nur den Konsumenten ein bisschen ärmer.
Der muss dann einfach nur die Amerikaner mehr zahlen.
Ja. Sullivan spricht jetzt mal über das Selbstverständnis. Also es ist wirklich interessant auch zu sehen, wie selbstbewusst Amerikaner sprechen. Also wo er eigentlich das sieht.
Das kennen wir doch.
Ja, aber ich finde jetzt in so einer ganz sachlichen Rede, in der man sagt, ich erzähle euch mal was über Ökonomie und Sicherheit und Lieferketten und all das. Also die Idee ist ja hier tatsächlich zu sagen, ich rede ganz viel über die Mitte der Gesellschaft und darüber, dass das BIP nicht alles ist und wir haben es da mit manchen Sachen vielleicht übertrieben. Aber es geht natürlich vor allem darum zu sagen, wir richten uns mit unserer Politik so aus, dass wir weiterhin Hegemonen in der Welt bleiben. Und das wird dann in folgende Worte gefasst. At the heart, also wir sind das Zentrum, nicht irgendwas anderes, also nicht multipolare Weltordnung oder irgendetwas. Und er bringt dann ein Kennedy-Zitat, das alle schon mal zumindest in der Hälfte gehört haben. Und das hat mich dann doch etwas erschreckt.
President Kennedy was fond of saying that a rising tide lifts all boats. Over the years, advocates of trickle-down economics appropriated this phrase for their own uses.
Also das kennen wir alle, ne? Dann steigt auf alle der Wohlstand, wenn wir nur den Reichen helfen. Er sagt, naja, dass er immer falsch interpretiert wurden und erklärt jetzt, wie er das sieht.
Er sagte nicht, was gut für die Weiche ist, gut für die Arbeitsklasse.
Das ist jetzt noch auf die Volkswirtschaft, die amerikanische, bezogen, ja. Also man kann nicht einfach mit Trickle-down-Economie oder sowas arbeiten. Den Schritt, den er jetzt aber macht, ist dieses Kennedy-Zitat, auf die globale Ordnung zu heben, in dem er sagt, Das ist wahr für unser Land, das ist wahr für unser Welt.
Ökonomisch werden wir über Zeit zusammenkriegen oder fallen.
bedeutet jetzt als Ansage an die Partnern-Anführungszeichen. Also entweder sind wir der Hegemonen oder wir gehen bei dem Versuch, unter Hegemonen zu sein. Aber dann werdet ihr mit uns untergehen.
Das ist Trump-Programm jetzt.
Das ist Trump-Programm. Von Jake Sullivan, in einer völlig anderen Rhetorik, sehr höflich, vorgetragen. Trump klingt anders. Der redet zum Beispiel so über die Zölle, die alles teurer machen. Viele werden den Clip schon gehört haben, aber wir spielen ihn noch mal. Es geht jetzt um die Mädchen und ihre Puppen.
Wenn man zu Präsident Xi spricht, wenn wir mit ihm reden, schau, ich habe dir vorhin gesagt, sie haben eine große Schwierigkeit, weil ihre Fabriken keine Arbeit machen. Sie haben mit Biden einen Trillionen Dollar gemacht, sogar einen Trillionen mit Biden, die uns das Geld verkaufen. Vieles brauchen wir nicht. Jemand hat gesagt, dass die Schäden offen werden. Vielleicht werden die Kinder zwei Dollar haben, statt 30 Dollar, und vielleicht werden die zwei Dollar ein paar Dollar mehr kosten als normal.
Wir haben ja jetzt mit einem Präsidenten zu tun, der sich offenbar der De-growth Ökonomie angeschlossen hat und sagt, wir brauchen gar nicht so viele Sachen. Warum muss ein Kinderzimmer voll sein mit 30 Puppen, zwei tun es doch auch und die sind dann auch ein bisschen teurer. Klar, denn die sind ja dann nicht mehr in China, sondern in den USA produziert.
Wir sehen ja alle, wie er lebt. Dass es überhaupt etwas gäbe, was man nicht bräuchte und deswegen nicht hätte.
Gut, aber das kennen wir ja generell auch von unseren Politikern. Wir sehen ja auch Jens Spahn da sitzen, wie er dem Rentner, der kaum über die Runden kommt, noch mal sagt, jetzt streng dich mal an und reiß dich mal zusammen.
Wer arbeitet denn zu wenig, die Rentner?
Ja, also da gibt es ja nichts. Oder wir haben ja auch einen fliegenden Bundeskanzler, der sagt, Hochzeit auf Sylt, ich komme, Flugzeug, mein Eigtes. Aber auf keinen Fall kommt das 9-Euro-Ticket zurück. Wo wollen wir denn dahin? Das ist ganz interessant, dass wir das jetzt haben. Es gibt ja, das kann man nachlesen, die Substack von Adam Tooze, da auch ein Gespräch mit Zyplas, das er geführt hat. Er sagte ja, es gab diesen Artikel von Naomi Klein im Guardian, in dem sie sagte, das ist jetzt Endzeitfaschismus, was Trump sagt, die haben überhaupt keine Perspektive, keine Zukunft vor Augen. Und dem widerspricht ja Tooze auch aufgrund dieses Clips und weiteren Dingen, nämlich er sagt, die haben ja tatsächlich ein Ziel. Die sagen ja sogar, jetzt müssen wir erst einmal verzichten, also nicht 30 Puppen, sondern nur noch zwei und all das. Und das soll dann zu irgendeiner großen neuen amerikanischen Vision führen. Tooze ist natürlich genauso wie wir ein großer Skeptiker, dass diese Vision aufgeht. Ist ja auch mal egal, ob die aufgeht. Interessant ist nur, man kann da nicht sagen, die machen Endzeitkapitalismus. Und das macht es ja vielleicht noch gefährlicher, ist ja, dass JD Vans und die im Hintergrund, die wir auch schon zum Teil im Salon erwähnt hatten, dass die dann durchaus von einer Erneuerung der ganzen Nation träumen und dafür jetzt erst einmal ein Teil der Tränen versprechen, durch das man hindurch muss.
Genau. Wir hören jetzt Clips von Adam Tooze. Du hast mir vorher schon kurz angekündigt, dass die so ein bisschen selten sind und aus obskuren Ecken des Internets herausgegraben. Kannst du gleich noch mal sagen. Nur weil du jetzt gesagt hast, das Ziel, ja. Also wir müssen ja glaube ich ganz hart unterscheiden zwischen einem Ziel und einem Weg dahin.
Genau. So.
Bei dem Ziel, ja. Also Trump ist ein amerikanischer Präsident und unterscheidet sich, was das angeht, ganz schön wenig von anderen amerikanischen Präsidenten. Aber in dem Weg dahin und dieser Puppenclip gerade, ja. Brauchen unsere kleinen Mädels wirklich immer 30 Puppen reichen, reichen nicht zwei. Amerika ist ja sehr gut darin, diese Verzichtsverpflichtung der eigenen Bevölkerung aufzubürden. Also man fährt durch Kalifornien und sieht, da gibt es einen großen Streit zwischen Gavin Newsom und allen Obdachlosen. Und diese Obdachlosen haben nicht zwei Puppen, sondern gar keine. Also Amerika kann verzichten.
Genau. Aber es ist nicht normalerweise Doktrin der Politik. Also Joe Biden würde nicht sagen, wir müssen was gegen den Klimawandel tun und deswegen müsst ihr jetzt alle verzichten. Sondern er sagt, es macht euch reich, es bringt euch mehr Jobs, die Industrie kommt zurück und dann haben wir auch noch ein bisschen was fürs Klima getan.
Genau. Also dieser Verzicht wurde bisher von den Amerikanern geduldet, weil man ihnen eingeredet hat, dass ein Klassenkampf albern ist und dass es ihr eigenes Schicksal war, jetzt hier zu verenden. Nur diese Verzichtsdiskussion bei Leuten, die ihren Kindern 30 Puppen kaufen, betrifft Menschen, die wissen, wie sie sich wehren. Das kennt man ja in Deutschland auch. Klar haben wir diese Stadtteile, wo nur noch sieben Prozent, dass die echte Zahl ins Wahllokal gehen und ansonsten auch ökonomisch nichts stattfindet und 40 Prozent kriegt, wie auch immer. Aber es gibt eben auch die Stadtteile, in denen die Leute für jeden Scheiß kämpfen. Und dann ruft man die Lehrerin an und meldet sich und hier und da. Und dann werden ganz viele kleine Kämpfe geführt. Und ob Amerika das hinbekommt, sich gegen die Schreienden, ich gehe noch mal zu der Veranstaltung mit dem republikanischen Senator, und der versucht mir jetzt Trumps Verzichtsdoktrin aufzubürden, da das durchzuhalten. Es wird schon gefährlich in Amerika. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass Adam Toos, ich habe es ja noch nicht gehört, nachdem wir jetzt den letzten Vortrag, der uns ja schon sehr zu denken gegeben hat, mit der chinesischen Gefahr und der schießenden Auseinandersetzung, die da droht, dass man jetzt auch Bürgerkriegswahlung von Ökonomen hört.
Er spricht jetzt tatsächlich nicht über dieses. Es geht tatsächlich um die Geopolitik. Er ist eingeladen. Es ist gar keine verrückte Ecke, wo er das macht, sondern er ist eingeladen bei der Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung. Die haben einen ganzen Tag gemacht, eine lange Konferenz, acht Stunden über geostrategische Herausforderungen auch in Bezug auf Nachhaltigkeit, Nachhaltigkeitsstrategien auf globaler Ebene. Jetzt kommt als letztes Adam Toos und hält da eine Rede. Man findet aber leider diesen Stream noch nicht öffentlich, beziehungsweise er ist öffentlich. Also man kann, das Video ist nicht gelistet bei YouTube. Man kann es also nicht so finden, aber es wurde gestreamt. Das war ja ein Event, wo man sagte, man streamt das auch alles, auch mit einigermaßen guter Technik. Man hat es aber offenbar noch nicht geschafft, da Einzelvideos draus zu machen. Was ich raten würde, das mal zu tun, denn das ist ein sehr wichtiger Vortrag. Die anderen Vorträge davor habe ich noch nicht gehört. Er spricht jetzt über das Thema Nachhaltigkeit. Und wir haben ja auch mit Precht in dem Buch zugestimmt. Und das war auch schon länger meine Ansicht. Eigentlich ist doch die Klimakatastrophe auch eine gewisse Chance, sich als Menschheitsfamilie gemeinsam zu organisieren, zu sehen. Das ist doch toll, dass wir jetzt immerhin in dieser Sache alle betroffen sind. Bedeutet also, wir können auch alle an einem Strang ziehen. Das wäre jetzt die Intuition. Jetzt kommt die Kontraintuition von Adam Tuus, der sagt, nee, also das mit dem Klimawandel und der Nachhaltigkeitspolitik, das ist ein Angriff. Man fragt sich auf was? Naja, auf die amerikanische Hegemonie. Und wir hören jetzt Auszüge aus diesem Vortrag. Beginnen mal mit Adam Tuus und der Entwicklung von China.
China's growth is clearly the greatest development success story in human history, bar none. It's not even arguable in terms of the scale of the transition from poverty to bearable prosperity. China, not just as a result of Covid, has a longer life expectancy than the United States today. That's a staggering fact compared to where China was in the 1960s. But it has blown the environmental equation up and there is no getting around that fact in the numbers of the scale of Chinese CO2 emissions. And it has emerged from the United States point of view as a fundamental challenge at the level of what we call in social science ontological security, the sort of destabilization that we blame, for instance, voters going to the AFD in Germany. It has destabilized the United States, both at the level of national security on the global stage and what the economists call the China shock, which to which Americans attribute an incredible array of domestic social dysfunction is attached to the supposed impact of Chinese imports. However large the effect actually is and however much may debate it, the significant thing is for American society, China is the destabilizing force.
China wird als die destabilisierende Kraft angesehen, gerade weil China so erfolgreich war, weil die Leute aus der Armut gekommen sind, weil man eine solche wirtschaftliche Entwicklung hingelegt hat. Tuus spekuliert dann mal, was wäre denn, wenn es jetzt ein anderes Land wäre? Denn wir haben natürlich auch immer es einfach aus dem Westen heraus, China als das Problem dazu zu stellen, weil es ja sowieso so regiert ist, wie es regiert ist, autoritär. Wir haben diese kommunistische Partei, die aber auch nicht wirklich kommunistisch ist.
Gar nicht kommunistisch.
Diese Überwachung, all das.
Ein Sozialstaat und nichts.
Man hat eine Glorifizierung der Mao-Ära, keine kritische Vergangenheitsbewältigung oder irgendetwas. Es ist also relativ leicht, China als Problemland in der Weise dann ideologisch einzuordnen. Aber was wäre denn das, wenn das Brasilien gewesen wäre?
Und das ist unvergesslich die größte Erfolgsstory der menschlichen Entwicklung, die wir je gesehen haben. Also, erlauben Sie sich mal, dass das nicht nur in China passiert wäre.
Aus der amerikanischen Perspektive heraus die Macht teilen mit einem anderen Land, das dann plötzlich stärker ist als das eigene.
Ein bisschen die Frage, wie man es verrechnet. Die amerikanischen Unternehmen haben ja extrem davon profitiert, in China zu produzieren und in die ganze Welt zu verkaufen. Und das Geld aber wieder in Amerika zu verbuchen.
Ja.
Und in der Hinsicht hat ja Amerika schon sehr davon profitiert, dass China diese Werkbankpolitik gemacht hat.
Deswegen hat man sie auch lange betrieben. Und bis hin zu Obama und Hillary Clinton, die dann schon merken, na, irgendwas ist da anders.
Genau, bis diese D-Industrialisierung aufhielt, die der Salibandia hat.
ich würde sagen, bis auch China einen Grad erreicht hat an politischer, militärischer, wirtschaftlicher Stärke, mit der plötzlich die amerikanische Vormachtstellung in Frage gestellt wird. Denn natürlich hat Amerika überhaupt kein Problem damit gehabt und hat der Westen auch kein Problem damit gehabt, reich zu werden durch diese unglaubliche Entwicklung in China. Und natürlich sehen wir auch gerne die günstigen Produkte aus China bei uns. Aber da, wo es plötzlich um dann doch Geopolitik geht, ist es wieder anders. Wir hatten in den 90er Jahren, darauf rekurriert jetzt, tu es nochmal, diese Vorstellung von einer Welt ohne Supermacht. Das ist eine sehr europäische Idee. Ich spreche das nochmal so gerade in einem Abwasch, nennt er so ein paar Namen.
Think about how Shimon Peres imagined a new Middle East in the 1990s to be delivered on European lines because it was going to be an Abraham Accord mega with Palestine folded in, that was going to deliver peace. There is a deep tendency on the part of Europeans and notably Germans to think that economic success, economic integration necessarily leads beyond national sovereignty, necessarily leads towards confederation, ideally leads you up to the world state of the UN. Think about Habermas in the 2010s speculating about the EU as a precursor to a world order.
Das haben wir auch so in uns glaube ich drin. Also ich glaube auch wir beide. Also wir denken, wir würden eigentlich auch gerne eine Welt sehen als United Colours of Benetton. Also wir sind da und China macht mir Angst. Und das Problem ist aber, dass er sagt das nationalstaatliche Denken, von dem man sagt, das verpassen, das verlieren wir doch. Ja, es gibt auch eine Publikumsfrage habe ich jetzt nicht drin, wo dann jemand sagt, ja, aber ist das überhaupt noch zeitgemäß so zu denken im postnationalen Zeitalter? Und dann sagt Tuus, ja, wo ist das postnationale Zeitalter?
Naja, also im Kopf ist es ja tatsächlich nicht mehr, wenn wir einfach einen Fernseher anmachen und dann läuft das Amazon mit Hollywood Videos und so. Und das ist, da ist kein, das ist postnationale Zeitgeist.
Und das ist aber nicht auf die Ebene der harten Geopolitik, auch nicht der harten Geopolitik bekommen. Da würde dann immer ein Mercher immer sagen, ja, bitte, wo ist dann dann die übergeordnete Distanz, die das macht? Da draußen ist Anarchie. Und so eigentlich auch die Interpretation von Tuus. Er spricht jetzt über diese Selbstbehauptung auch der Länder wieder.
Whereas historically speaking, the opposite is true. The vast majority of states that have pursued sustainable development have done it so as to resist external power and then to become powers themselves. That's the point of development for the vast majority of players, is sovereignty.
Ja, wir haben diese Souveränitätsbewegungen und Behauptungen überall. Das ist ja auch in Russland gleichermaßen zu beobachten, wie in allen Regionen der Welt eigentlich. Das ist immer um diese nationalstaatliche Souveränitätsbehauptung geht, die dann auch bedeutet, dass man eine gewisse Autarkie erlangen will.
Aber sah das nicht wirklich so aus, als wäre das überwunden? Also jetzt gerade haben wir das wieder.
Genau, das sah so aus.
Aber so 90er, wo einfach völlig klar war, Amerika ist Urlaubsland, da gehen die Kinder hin und machen ihre Bildungskram und überhaupt und so. Da gab es ja eigentlich schon so einen großen postnationalen, so eine Horrok-Aktion zumindest mal.
Gut, im Pentagon wird man das nie so gesehen haben, aber so im Ganzen, sagen wir das so, das ist auch die Stimmung. Es ist ja auch, wenn du dir die Blockbuster ansiehst, Ende der 90er, vor allem der Nuller-Jahre dann und auch bis in die Zehner hinein, dann hast du ja diese ganzen kulturellen Transfers und wo die überall spielen. Also du hast ja Filme, nicht nur wie James Bond, die überall angelegt sind, wo aber dann noch so eine politische Komponente dabei ist, sondern du bist überall, denk an den Julia Roberts Film Eat, Pray, Love. Also du gehst nach Indien zum Beten, nach Italien zum Lieben. Also du bist dann überall. Und das ist eigentlich diese kosmopolitische Seinsweise, die aber mit einem konsumistischen Ich einhergeht, die aber natürlich immer nur dann da ist, wenn nicht plötzlich wieder nationale Interessen kommen. Jetzt haben wir ja über so viel Selbstbehauptung, Souveränität und all das redet, was hatten das jetzt auf einem Nachhaltigkeitskongress zu tun? Und jetzt kommt diese entscheidende Idee von Tuus.
Because sovereignty is another word for collective freedom. And if the point of sustainable development is empowerment, then the classic way of understanding that within the nation state framework is not immediately to sign on to a UN treaty in which you sign away your sovereignty. Your immediate impulse is to actually use it to empower your state to exercise a kind of sovereignty it's been previously denied. And that is the reality, I think, that we have not dealt with and is key to understanding the American defection from the paradigm.
Bedeutet jetzt?
Somehow there is going to be a future beyond fossil fuel that will or, and this is of course what the American conservative sense is that you lovely people in this room here are conspiring against American power. And actually you all know perfectly well that this is the case. And when you say you want to realize the sustainable development agenda, you're actually saying, as they say in their letter to the United Nations, that you're smuggling in the geopolitics, which is fundamentally hostile to the power of the United States.
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik ist eine Form der Geopolitik, bedeutet, wir machen hier uns mit der Energie autark, bedeutet, wir sind nicht mehr abhängig von einer amerikanischen Hegemonie. Bedeutet also, man stellt sich in Opposition zu amerikanischen Hegemonie, bedeutet jetzt für die beiden Administrationen schon, anders ausgedrückt natürlich dann, als das Trump tut, aber bedeutet dann auch für die Trump-Administration, diesen Weg geht ihr mal lieber nicht mit, wenn ihr unsere Partner seid, sondern nur so wie wir uns das vorstellen. Weshalb ja auch die USA größte Gas- und Ölproduzenten geworden sind. Und diese Idee zu sagen, ja eigentlich ist das doch toll, Nachhaltigkeit und wir kommen ja da zu so einer Welt, wo alle Menschen quasi davon profitieren, wenn alle nachhaltig leben und so. Das ist natürlich auf der Klimaebene wahnsinnig gut gedacht. Sobald man aber auf dieses nationalstaatliche Denken geht, und das tut ja hier to's für uns, dann kommen wir plötzlich in Rivalitäten. Und man kann natürlich sagen, ja aber wir retten ja nur die Umwelt und dann sagen die, nee, ihr macht euch aber jetzt gerade auch los von uns, ihr werdet ja unabhängig, ihr habt ja jetzt plötzlich eine eigene Macht.
Also ich bin noch an dem Punkt, wo ich mir denke, Adam Tooth verspielt es vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr. Denn ja, wir alle kennen noch diese Welt, in der es hieß der 11. September, Arabien, man geht in den Irak, braucht irgendwelche Anlässe, aber eigentlich geht es ums Öl. So und dann kommen so Diskussionen wie, Peeköl gibt es bald kein Öl mehr. Also wird es jetzt noch kontroverser, wie da Politik gemacht wird. Profitiert Europa sehr davon, dass Amerika die Seewege der Öllieferung aus den arabischen Räumen nach Europa absichert und so weiter und ist damit dann Hegemon, den man einfach folgt. Find ich alles gut. Nur wir haben ja, das klingt so ein bisschen profan, aber das Balkonkraftwerk, jeder macht sich abhängig nicht nur von Amerika, unabhängig, sondern auch vom lokalen Energieverzeuger oder wie auch immer. Ja. Und Amerika ist ja auch ein großer Förderer, also Texas, dieser Ausbau von Wind und Solar ist ja da wirklich enorm. Ich sehe ja jetzt so ein bisschen, was thematisch kommt, das geht ja alles in so eine Richtung. Also ich sehe jetzt schon Huty und Drohnen und so. Ich bin sehr gespannt, denn noch glaube ich.
Du hast ja völlig recht.
Es schleppt noch so eine Geschichte nach in dieses Thema, die vielleicht...
Es ist eine individuelle Autarkie, die man erreichen kann mit Balkonkraftwerke etc. Bedeutet aber auch im Ganzen, es ist also eine Loslösung von einem Machtblock, den man benötigt, um da zum Beispiel Öl herzubekommen. Genau. Das waren mal eine Zeit lang... Eine totale Dezentralisierung.... die arabischen Staaten bedeutete dann für die USA, Ölpreis, Schock, all das. Und dann haben die USA Fracking in hohem Maße gesetzt, um da sich nicht mehr dann auch so involvieren zu müssen in diese Kämpfe. Also das ist ja auch interessant, wie sehr sich die USA zurückgezogen haben. Das ist ja dann nicht mehr... Also nach George W. Bush Junior kommt dann ja Barack Obama. Und der lässt das ja schon alles so ein bisschen liegen. Und dann später der Abzug aus Afghanistan dann erst. Aber eigentlich hat man das ja schon viel früher aufgegeben für sich. Und auch sich in andere Dinge nicht mehr so eingemischt. Weil man auch dann eine größere Autonomie plötzlich schon erlangt hatte durch Fracking. Und das ist jetzt diese eine Sache, das bedeutet aber immer noch, dass die Partner sehr stark davon abhängig waren. Aber generell ist natürlich, wenn es zu einer Dezentralisierung kommt, und das ist eben bei den Erneuerbaren am allerstärksten so, dass man tatsächlich sagen könnte, ich lebe hier autark, ich brauch noch nicht mal mehr die Stadt Frankfurt im Ganzen dafür, sondern kann mich da machen. Das bedeutet aber dann für die Volkswirtschaften an sich gedacht, also für diese Rahmungen, die brauchen dann die anderen Länder auch nicht mehr. Also das heißt, dass Nation Building oder die souveräne Selbstbehauptung, die nimmt dadurch zu. Bedeutet also, dass all das eine Gefahr ist für einen Hegomon, der eigentlich das Ganze leiten will. Das ist ja die Überlegung von Truth. Und er sagt, da ist zum einen China, die sich aufgrund überhaupt dieser Möglichkeiten, die die neue Technologie, Solarenergie und all das gibt, sich in dieser Weise entwickeln konnte. Und diese technischen Möglichkeiten haben ja auch zu einer enormen Verbilligung geführt von Energie. Und bedeutet aber auch Verbilligung von Kriegstechnologie. Er spricht jetzt über folgendes Problem.
Die komprehensive globale Entwicklung gegen das Status Quo-Power-System ist das, was ich die China-Huthi-Problem nennen. In anderen Wörtern, als jeder eigentlich entwickelt, zwingen sie die globale Kraftstruktur.
Was meint ihr damit? Na ja, die Huthis und viele andere schaffen sich für 10 Millionen, für 50 Millionen Drohnen an und können damit die Weltordnung entscheidend mit beeinflussen, können dafür sorgen, dass wir große Probleme bekommen, ob die Importe noch funktionieren und und und. Mit ganz wenig Budget. Also du hast ja hier diese großen Diskussionen, müssen es 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr, 500 Milliarden. Und die sagen, wir gucken mal, ob wir irgendwo 10 Millionen finden.
Und dann fährt da kein Schiff mehr durch.
Dann fährt da kein Schiff mehr durch. So und das ist plötzlich auch natürlich ebenso eine Fragestellung der Hegomonie. Auch noch mal bezogen auf die Ukraine können wir noch mal das mit den Drohnen herausheben. Hier ein Auszug aus dem Ronzheimer Podcast, da war Julian Röpke von der Bild-Zeitung zu Gast. Er spricht über die Drohnen.
Also hätte die Ukraine nicht so unfassbar innovativ kleine zivile Quadrokopter in tödliche Waffen verwandelt, stände die russische Armee heute längst in Saporitja-Stadt, in Liborstadt, in Rakiv-Stadt. Also das ist das einzige, was die Russen auffällt. Wir wissen von den Ukrainern, dass aktuell 80 Prozent der russischen Verluste aus Kamikaze-Drohnen-Angriffe erfolgen. Also ukrainische Angriffe mit kleinen Quadrokoptern, mit Sprengladung töten 80 Prozent der russischen Soldaten, die getötet werden in der Ukraine. Und daran sieht man eben, wenn das nicht passieren würde, die Artillerie oder Panzer oder was auch immer da noch alles ist, das hat überhaupt nicht das Potenzial, was eben diese kleinen Killer-Maschinen haben. Und nur deshalb, nur deshalb sind die Russen so langsam im Vormarsch, weil sie eben für jeden Kilometer mit so vielen Menschen bezahlen müssen.
Jetzt können wir uns fragen, was war aber denn eigentlich das Pariser Klimaabkommen? Das fragt sich Adam Toos natürlich auch. 2015, da war doch mit Obama im Einklang eigentlich ein großes Verständnis dafür, wir müssen das 1,5-Grad-Ziel erreichen, und zwar gemeinsam. Da war doch eine Welt, eine Menschheit, ein Klima.
Ich meine, wenn du es so ausgeladen hast, kannst du dich einfach fragen, wie 2015 überhaupt losging.
Wenn man doch diese geopolitischen Prämissen erst einmal setzt, dann ist das doch eigentlich unwahrscheinlich, dass man sich auf so ein Klimaabkommen in dieser Weise einigen kann. Er meint, Adam Tews auch dann führt das länger aus, muss man sich vielleicht im Podcast nochmal den Vortrag nochmal ganz anhören, meint dann auch, naja, wie ernst war das so gemeint?
Und das letzte Element ist, und das ist, glaube ich, wo wir wirklich hängen, dass sie nie gedacht haben, dass es irgendwo gehen würde. Sie haben das bezeichnet, weil sie wussten, dass, wenn es ernst geworden wäre, sie einen VITO-Powertrag über das haben würden. Und du siehst das in den Texten der Dokumente, die wir feiern, wie das Paris-Aufgabe 2015, am letzten Moment, in den letzten paar Stunden, wie ich es verstehe, der Negotiationszeit, das ganze Ding blutte fast auf, weil der französische Sekretariat die Sprache verwendet hat, die es so verbunden machte, dass die amerikanische Administration es in den Kongress vornehmen müsste, und sie wissen seit Bird-Hagel im Jahr 1997, dass sie das nie mehr in den Kongress vornehmen werden.
Also es war eigentlich ein zahnloser Tiger.
Ja, so zahnlos war der.
Naja, also die Idee ist ja hier ganz klar zu sagen, wir können das da machen, aber schon unter unserer Hegemonie. Also das ist ja was Cech Sullivan jetzt auch eben vorgestellt hat. Der würde auch immer sagen, ja Klimawandel und so weiter wichtig, kämpfen wir mit unseren Partnern, aber schon auch USA at the Heart. Und das ist jetzt das, was Tuus so kritisiert, dass das so lange übersehen wurde. Mit Trump wird das natürlich alles wahnsinnig offensichtlich, da wir ja von ihm wissen, er lügt, aber er spricht durch die unverfrorenen Wahrheiten im Gegensatz zu anderen Politikern ja aus. Und da gab es jetzt auch gleich nicht irgendwie, wir gucken mal nochmal Klimawandel und so weiter, sondern sie haben ja tatsächlich so ein Statement verwendet, wo sie sagen, wir weisen das zurück. Also sie weisen diese Klimapolitik wirklich zurück. Und diese Weise, sie tust das jetzt nicht nur bei Trump.
Wir verbreiten es total, und das ist nicht nur Trump, sondern auch Biden, der Themas, dass Amerika kompromisse muss, weil es historisch verabschiedet ist.
Ja, also ich finde das Thema Energieversorgung ist so fundamental und wichtig, dass ich es ja selbst im Familienbuch zentral gemacht habe so, aber eben auch ein bisschen verspielt. Deswegen vermute ich hier auch, da ist noch so eine Spielerei drin, klar. Wir haben jetzt ein Kohle, ein Öl, ein Gaszeitalter, was mit der Klammer, dafür braucht man Bodenschätze, dafür braucht man große Maschinen, dafür braucht man Transportwege, riesige Tanker, der ganze Kram. Und wer das hat und kontrolliert und steuert, der steuert sozusagen. Also ist ja immer die Frage, was ist der Maßstab für Souveränität? Was ist der Maßstab für, ist ein Helgemann oder nicht? Das sind ja auch mehr so Sprachbilder, mit denen man so arbeitet. Und dass wir jetzt gerade in so einer riesigen Zäsur sind, ist klar. Nur jetzt haben wir eben China es überlassen, also gerade wir Europäer ja auch. Zum Schutze der Autoindustrie geht die ganze von Rot-Grün geförderte erneuerbare Technologie einfach nach China. Wir waren ja Platz eins der Welt mit 50% Marktanteil Solarpanele und so. Wir Deutschen. Und jetzt ist es China. Das wird alles Veränderungen mit sich bringen und die kann man auch unter dieser alten Doktrin, Energieversorgung, Fossil, so beobachten und dann so kritische Kommentare draus stricken. Nur das ändert ja nichts daran, dass es über den Preisdruck diese Veränderung einfach gibt. Zur Erneuerbaren, zur Detrentalität, dass jedes Unternehmen demnächst es einpreist, einfach zu sagen, okay, in Deutschland ist es Pflicht, ein Solardach auf die Gewerbefläche. Und dann erst, wenn man das in Betrieb nimmt, sieht man, wie viel Strom da eigentlich rauskommt. Das hätte sich der Chef vorher gar nicht vorstellen können. Man hat mit seinen zehn Mitarbeitern einfach ein, was weiß ich, Lagergewerbe, irgendwas gemacht und plötzlich ist man auch noch Stromerzeuger. Also diese Technologie bringt halt an sich so viel mit und es braucht jetzt neue Erzählung. Und ich weiß nicht, ob Adam Toos noch so die alte Erzählung bisschen übergetrunken ist.
Nee, er ist gar nicht bei der alten Erzählung, wie wir gleich sehen werden. Was er nur sagt, ist, dass das alles etwas ist, was die Amerikaner und auch schon unter beiden kritisch gesehen haben, weil das plötzlich ihnen Macht nimmt.
Genau.
Und das bedeutet auch dann, im Umkehrschluss, sind das also unsere Partner gewesen, mit denen man wirklich gegen den Klimawandel kämpft oder sind wir einem Pluff aufgesessen, wie er das jetzt gerade beschreibt. Was du jetzt beschreibst über die Kostenfrage, dass am Ende die Entscheidung über das Portemonnaie gefällt wird, ist völlig gar. Ich hatte das Vergnügen, mit einem ehemaligen Lehrer von mir zu telefonieren, über 70 und das war jemand, der immer so alle zwei Jahre ein neues Auto fuhr und das war schon für den alles sehr wichtig und das ist für den auch immer noch wichtig. Er erzählte mir als erstes quasi am Telefon ganz begeistert, dass er jetzt ein E-Auto hat, dass er Photovoltaik, nachdem er ein Kraftwerk, er hatte erst so ein Balkonkraftwerk und jetzt hat er ganz auf Photovoltaik auf dem Dach umgestellt und muss nicht mehr tanken, hat das alles, finanziert das alles darüber, also über das, was da von der Sonne kommt und auch noch sonst. Und er sagt selbst dann und dann noch und dann, also er lebt jetzt da quasi autark und das ist bei ihm, weil er immer jemand war, der immer über Preise redete, für ihn nur eine Potmanet-Frage. Also wir haben nicht einmal über, also wir haben lange gesprochen, wir haben nicht einmal über Habeck und nicht über die Grünen und was ist da sonst irgendwie. Für ihn war die Frage, ist das für mich sinnvoll? Und die Frage ist mit dem Portemonnaie, mit dem Blick ins Portemonnaie beantwortet.
Also manchmal kann es einfach ganz einfach sein.
Ja.
Und dann ist jede weitere Erzählung nur so nachgeschleifte Semantik, die nochmal die alte Welt beschreibt.
Ja. Das bedeutet also jetzt, wenn man China als die eigentliche Gefahr jetzt ansieht und sagt, dann ist mir der Klimawandel egal, sondern ich muss sehen, dass ich China bekämpfe, bedeutet das natürlich auch...
Die China-Ausgabe hat mittlerweile die Spielzeit grundsätzlich verändert. Also jede amerikanische Idee, dass sie eine führende Rolle in dem erneuerbaren Energiefeld spielen würde, ist tot im Wasser und sie alle kennen es.
Bedeutet also, das ist jetzt nicht mehr unser Thema und wir haben es von Trump gehört, Drill Baby Drill, aber das war ja auch die Politik von Biden schon. Also es ist lustig, dass Trump das immer so darstellt, als sei das jetzt so sein großes Ding.
Und da hat er doch diesen Drill Baby Drill gemacht.
Unter Biden ist es natürlich dazu gekommen.
Na ja, Biden hat das, musste das immer sehr verstecken. Ich war auch einmal überrascht, als ich hörte, dass das bei der Jugend so ein großes Thema war, dass irgend so ein unter dem Eis irgendwo so ein Öl Lager. Und das war das bestimmende Thema über Wochen und Monate, dass die Amerikaner nur noch eine Unterschrift davon entfernt sind, dass Biden das unterschreibt. Und dann hat Biden das unterschrieben und es war nicht mal in den Tagesthemen. Also nirgendwo war das in Meldung.
Aber das war dort ganz moot.
Aber die jungen Leute hat das wirklich aufgebrannt. Wenn sich Trump geht halt anders damit um.
Aber er hat das geopolitisch in ähnlicher Weise vertreten, wie Trump dann auch.
Und währenddessen hat die USA nicht nur als eine hohe Kostengasproduzentin, sondern auch als die größte weltweit bestreitende Ölproduzentin, die wir je gesehen haben. Meine Damen und Herren, wir müssen mit dieser Realität betrachten. Amerika ist jetzt viel größer als Saudi-Arabien oder Russland im globalen Ölfeld. Sie sind nicht vertreten. Jede europäische Hypothese über den Ende von Fossilfuelen ist in der amerikanischen Kontexte sehr unnötig. Die amerikanische Erkenntnis ist, dass Fossilfuelen für immer sind. Amerikanische Fossilfuelen sind für immer. Und es ist wirklich ein Thema, wie groß der Exportmarkt ist.
Na ja, mal sehen. Der Preisdruck.
Dann habe ich einen kleinen Podcast gehört, den ich vorher nicht kannte. KlimaNews Podcast, die fassen immer so zusammen, was es in puncto KlimaNeues gibt. Da ging es um China. Da gab es ja vor zwei Wochen eine sehr gute Meldung für uns alle, für die Welt, für die Menschheit. Hier hören wir sie.
China hat erstmals seine CO2-Emissionen gesenkt. Laut einer Analyse des Klimaportals Carbon Reef von Mitte Mai sind die Emissionen im ersten Quartal 2025 um 1,6 Prozent gegenüber dem Vorjahr gesunken. Auch im Jahresvergleich zeigt sich eine leichte Abnahme, immerhin minus 1 Prozent.
Diese Entwicklung ist bemerkenswert, denn sie geht nicht auf Sondereffekte wie Wirtschaftskrisen oder Covid-Lockdowns zurück. Chinas Wirtschaft läuft stabil, trotzdem sinken die Emissionen. Der Grund? Der massive Ausbau von erneuerbaren Energien zeigt Wirkung. 2024 produzierte China mehr erneuerbaren Strom als alle anderen Länder zusammen und verdrängt damit zunehmend Kohle, Öl und Gas. Und obwohl in China mehr Elektrizität verbraucht wurde als im Vorjahr, entstand somit bei der Produktion weniger CO2. Gleichzeitig werden in der Bauindustrie weniger Zement und Stahl benötigt, das verringert die Emissionen ebenfalls. Das könnte bedeuten, dass China seine Emissionen schneller als angekündigt senkt. Präsident Xi Jinping hatte vor fünf Jahren versprochen, den Höhepunkt der Emissionen bis 2030 zu erreichen.
Ja, also ich glaube, auch wenn die Worte dafür noch fehlen und wir die Geschichte noch nicht geschrieben haben, aber in... In zehn Jahren würde ich sagen, es geht gar nicht anders. Der Hegemon ist, wer diese Klimatechnologien verkauft. Weil dein Lehrer ist ja nun das Standardbeispiel. Das gilt im Kleinen, das gilt im Großen. Weil dein Lehrer würde nicht anfangen jetzt irgendeine Grube zu graben oder so ein Quatsch. Also das Dach ist da und der weiß, da ist ein Handwerker, der würde mir eine Solarpanele drauf machen, fertig.
Und der Effekt ist natürlich, dass jeder Nachbar sich darüber informiert und nachdenkt, ach ja, das könnte ich eigentlich auch machen.
Ja, und dann ist die Frage, wo kaufe ich es?
Ja.
Und dann ist einfach völlig klar, wer dahin gewohnt ist.
Aus diesen Klimameldungen ergibt sich, dass China die Geschichte schreibt. Und das muss man tatsächlich jetzt auch als eine Kränkung des westlichen Subjekts, also kann man das sehen, also das heißt, wir sind nicht die, die darüber entscheiden, ob das Weltklima im Ganzen sich verbessert. Wir haben auch unseren Anteil, also das soll jetzt nicht die Entschuldigungserzählung dafür werden, dass er sagt, und deswegen brauchen wir gar nichts machen, die Chinesen sollen mal zusehen. Aber bedeutet natürlich, dass, egal wie sehr wir am Hebel jetzt sehen, wir nicht der entscheidende Faktor sein werden, bei der Reduktion von CO2. China schon.
Das ist die echte Geschichte. China hat in den letzten zwei Jahren über 60 Prozent globaler Emissionszahlen gesorgen. Das ist Geschichte, die Chinesen machen das. Das ist keine Geschichte der Chinesen, die eine lange strukturelle Vorteile haben, die sie immer hatten. Das sind die Chinesen, die schneller und mit viel größerer Energie als wir. Ich meine, nimm das Nummerzettel da. Die Chinesen haben in den letzten zwei Jahren drei Mal so viel Energie wie in den USA zusammen. Es ist nie in der Westen so eine Nutzung gegeben.
Am Ende ist es nicht nur das Produkt selbst, sondern auch die ganze Logistik und so weiter. China zeigt es, dass es geht. Und ist damit der vertrauensfördernde Verkäufer für diesen Kram.
Bedeutet für uns?
Wenn wir nicht die chinesischen Photovoltaiken kaufen, wählen wir die Welt zu heben.
Er geht dann auch noch durch, wo wir was tun können. Also Stahl sind wir gar nicht so wichtig, weil wir so viel über grünen Stahl reden. Zement scheint wohl ein großes Thema zu sein. Da könnte man tatsächlich sehen, dass man da eine Vorreiterstellung bekommt. Das würde sehr helfen.
Ich finde ja, man sollte immer noch nicht aufgeben, dass wir damals dieses rot-grüne Programme hatten unter Gerhard Schröder mit Trittin und so weiter. Wenn wir das durchgezogen hätten, mit diesen Entwicklungen und die Autoindustrie dann sozusagen aus externen, aber deutschen Anlässen gesehen hätte, an Energie mangels nicht. Wir können das hier elektrifizieren. Dann hätten wir jetzt diese erneuerbaren Technologien plus eine elektrifizierte Autoindustrie. Also wirklich 15 Jahre, bevor China überhaupt noch die Idee kam, wir machen das jetzt mal.
Was wir eigentlich brauchen könnten, wäre wirklich ein Bauboom. Dann würde man jetzt sagen, aber das produzierte FIAT CO2 stimmt. Aber jetzt könnte man dort mit vielen Erneuerungen dafür sorgen, dass diese Häuser klimaneutral werden dann auf Zeit. Denn das ist ja auch das große Problem, dass wir so unglaublich viele alte Häuser haben. Die stehen erst ewig lange leer, dann werden sie zu Spekulationserrgäten verkauft und dann kommt vielleicht noch irgendwann mal eine Anlage obendrauf. Aber man könnte ja viel mehr auch jetzt den sozialen Wohnungsbau gleich klimaneutral anlegen, damit da mal auch sich in Relation setzen zu China. Ich habe wirklich das nochmal als Clip mitgebracht, weil ich einfach die Zahl so unglaublich finde über den Bauboom in China. Also von 1995 sprechen wir jetzt bis heute.
Die Leute sagen, oh, das sind nicht die Exporten in Europa, das sind nicht die verabschiedeten Emissionen. 10-15% davon sind es. Das Rest ist, die in den Stahl und die Sehung zu gehen, die über die Zeit von 20 Jahren von einem halben Billionen Leuten urbanisiert werden. 95%– wir sagen das als Deutschen– Den Osten renaturalisieren und zugleich dann große Bauten machen, die China gleich kommen.
Na ja, du hast auch Leute, für die du baust.
Das wäre ja wieder unser Migrationsthema, aber da haben wir auch schon alles zugesagt. Kommen wir zum Fazit, was die amerikanische Geostrategie anbelangt?
So to that extent, we're more back in the 1950s Sputnik moment, when the Americans aren't the unipolar, boistering antagonists who know they bestride the world. The Soviets got into space first, the Soviets launched the satellite, the Americans are moving from behind, and this time around it's not in a Sputnik moment, massive investment in progressive technology, it's this retreat to a kind of fortress. But they're seeing something quite clearly, that this universal agenda ultimately is not squarely reconcilable with their narrowly understood strategic interest.
Das ist die große Frage. Will jetzt Europa auch mit in diese Festung rein? Ich würde es nicht empfehlen. Man wird sehen, wie sich da noch vielleicht sich in den Köpfen etwas ändert. Ich kann es mir momentan wenig vorstellen. Also Vardepoel ist jetzt auch niemand, der auf Distanz eigentlich gehen würde zur US-Regierung. Mal sehen, es kann natürlich passieren, dass Trump in seinem ganzen Agieren dann irgendwann das für notwendig macht. Und dann muss man aufgeben. Aber das große Treffen Trump-Merz steht ja noch bevor. Wir sind sehr gespannt. Ich hoffe, sie machen auch das alles wieder im Oval Office mit Kameras. Ich möchte auch wirklich am Ende wieder Trump hören. Der sagt Great Television, da freue ich mich sehr drauf.
Ich will, dass Merz so einen Brief mitbringt wie Kirstama und dann ein großer Geste irgendwas macht. Ich will noch eine kurze Einschätzung zu diesem Vortrag geben. Also jetzt haben wir alle Clips gehört und ich sage ja sehr gut wieder Adam Toos. Denn es ist sehr wichtig, sich, und wir gehen ja gleich ins Katholische, sich große Linien anzuschauen und ernst zu nehmen. Auch wenn sie nicht immer jeder Approximationshoffnung entgegenkommen. Also manchmal ist man auch ein bisschen ab von Schuss und ein bisschen mehr in der Literatur und der Spiritualität als jetzt irgendwie und so. Hier in diesem Falle denke ich ja sehr gut. Nur manche Sachen passieren einfach politisch, weil vielleicht dann Linksfläge, Flügelschläge und dann Orkäne und man kriegt das gar nicht zusammen. Man versucht dann sozusagen retrospektiv eine Geschichte zu erzählen. Und da wir jetzt ja mit Geoökonomie ein Buch in Erwartung haben, das sich von Geopolitik unterscheidet, also eine große Erzählung gegen die nächste große Erzählung. Manchmal sind es diese kleinen Phänomene, die man vielleicht auch gar nicht so beobachtet, die erst recht nicht immer zwingend Puzzleteile sind für irgendwas Großes, aber trotzdem gut, dass Adam Toos noch mal aus der alten fossilen Hegemonie, Souveränitätsgeschichte. Denn mal gucken, wohin es führt, wenn wir die Welt wirklich mit einer anderen Energieversorgung ausstatten.
Ja.
Und ich habe ja im Familienbuch auch getrohnt.
Neue Energieversorgung ist multipolare Welt. Das muss man erkennen.
Das sieht jetzt so aus, genau. Und es gäbe auch keinen Grund, noch andere Erzählungen und vor allem politische Folgen daraus mitlaufen zu lassen. Weil warum? Man konnte halt die fossilen Ohrstoffe so ausbeuten. Extrem riesige Lieferketten, immer dem Präsidenten mit seiner Feldherrnschaft im Anschlag, um das alles abzusichern. Das ist jetzt nicht mehr nötig. Also es könnte auch zu einer schönen neuen Zukunft führen, in der jeder wie dein Lehrer, Mobilität und Heimat.
Das auf jeden Fall. Also das ist ja auch die Division, die er hier mitbringt und er sagt ja eigentlich den Leuten von der Handelch-Böll-Stiftung, hört auf zu glauben, dass das jetzt einfach so in einem transatlantischen Rahmen eine tolle Partnerschaft wird, mit der wir den Klimawandel gemeinsam gegen China bekämpfen. Das kann nicht sein. Und was das eigentlich meint, diese Autarkie, die damit verbunden ist und dass man sich auch dann damit zurechtfinden muss, dass man in einer multipolaren Welt lebt und das natürlich auch militärisch nochmal sehr viel bedeutet, denn wir reden natürlich jetzt noch über die Supermächte mit ihren Atomwaffen und das zeichnet sie auch dann noch als Supermächte aus. Zugleich aber sehen wir, dass also jetzt kleine Player, also kleine Länder oder nur einzelne rebellische Gruppen darin zu wichtigen Akteuren deshalb werden, weil sie nicht mehr darauf hoffen müssen, auch mal irgendeine Waffenlieferung zu bekommen aus Deutschland, irgendein Reinmetallpanzer, sondern die sagen, wir haben hier ein bisschen Geld, wir kaufen Drohnen und dann funktionieren wir die noch ein bisschen um zu unseren Zwecken und das war es dann. Und damit haben wir alles und das verschiebt natürlich alles ganz gewaltig. Und dieses neue Denken, glaube ich, ist bei vielen noch nicht eingeübt. Insofern auch sehr gut, dass Tuus das auch gerade bei der Böll-Stiftung in dieser Weise vorträgt.
Absolut. Bist du zufrieden mit deinen Chefs der Hegemonie, deinem Kanzler, dem amerikanischen Präsidenten? Oder würdest du lieber sagen, nee, irgendwas stimmt da nicht?
Ich würde mich über ein alternatives Angebot freuen, sagen wir mal so.
Aber es ist ja Demokratie. Ja, das heißt, die kommen ja nicht von ungefähr oder nirgendwo, sondern die sind ja aus Gründen da. Wir hören mal, wie wir derzeit regiert werden. Zum einen Friedrich Merz. Es gäbe jetzt unterschiedliche Einflugsschneisen. Wir nehmen uns einfach mal zwei. Zum Beispiel hier eine Begrüßung aus den Tagesthemen. Er ist im Gespräch.
Guten Abend, Herr Merz.
Guten Abend, Frau Wilmer.
Herr Merz, wir sprechen uns am Abend eines insgesamt sehr ereignisreichen Tages mit sehr hohem Tempo. In welchem Gang waren Sie denn heute unterwegs?
Naja, jedenfalls in ziemlich hohem Tempo, denn wir wollen ja nun auch mit hohem Tempo dieses Land nach vorn bringen. Und dazu haben wir heute auch im Koalitionsausschuss das erste Mal getagt. Und ich habe gesagt, es geht jetzt Schlag auf Schlag.
So, hohes Tempo, Schlag auf Schlag.
Vielversprechend, ja.
Es ist wirklich vielversprechend. Wir wissen nicht so genau, gibt es da noch einen Kompass oder ein Fundament oder irgendwas, oder ist das einfach nur noch Gelaber? Ja. Anderes Beispiel, zeitgleich im Heudejournal.
Und wir werden diese Zustände jetzt korrigieren, so wie die Ampel sie uns hinterlässt.
Also irgendeine Politik kann zu irgendeinem Thema, in dem Falle Migration, es wird jetzt was korrigiert. Fragen wir uns mal, ob wir hier heraus hören, welcher Maßstab dafür gilt. Also ob es so eine Orientierung dafür gibt, was da getan wird.
Das kann es nicht weitergehen. Wir korrigieren die Migrationspolitik der letzten zehn Jahre. Da können Sie gerne immer noch weitere Beispiele nennen. Sie nennen Beispiele, die von der Minderheit der Bevölkerung so gesehen wird. Die Mehrheit sieht es ganz anders. Und wir vertreten hier die Meinung der Mehrheit der Bevölkerung und befinden uns damit auch auf dem richtigen Weg, dieses Problem Stück für Stück zu lösen, ohne dass wir damit unsere humanitären Verpflichtungen in irgendeiner Weise verletzen.
Das Problem, das nicht genau benannt ist, ist die Grundlage, die wir nicht erkennen können, auf der man aber vorhat, etwas radikal zu verändern. Und zwar das aus den letzten zehn Jahren. Man fragt sich, wenn es überhaupt gar keinen Gerüst gibt, keinen Maßstab oder sonst was, kann ich ja auch gar nicht mehr diese Politik bewerten. Also erst mal, dass ich diese Migrationspolitik grundsätzlich ablehne. Aber ich könnte ja noch nicht mal sagen, es ist besser geworden oder so, weil ich ja gar keinen Messwert mehr habe, an dem ich es ausrichten könnte.
Ja, hohes Tempo, Schlag auf Schlag. Alles wird besser, anders irgendwie. Und im Sommer wirst du dann bald spüren als Bürger, dass sich hier was zum Besseren, sagt er dann noch mal dazu, verändert.
Einfach mal eine Stoppuhr laufen lassen.
Genau, was ja bedeutet, dass Personal, das uns hier gerade durch den Alltag führt, politisch das Verantwortung übernimmt. Wir wüssten nicht, was wir mit ihnen reden sollten. Würden sie nachts bei uns auftreten und sagen, ich komme noch auf einen Drink mit in die Bar, man säße ihnen gegenüber und keine Ahnung, Herr Merz, was ist denn so ihr Lieblingsthema? Worüber kann man denn mit ihnen reden? Und ja, keine Ahnung, man wäre so im haltlosen Raum. Und dasselbe betrifft ja auch Friedrich Merz. Wir haben es also hier, das haben wir ja schon auch mit Andreas Püttmann und so besprochen, mit konservativen, christlichen Leuten zu tun, die sich immer wieder darauf beziehen, konservativ und christlich zu sein. Und wir wissen nicht so genau, was das bei denen bedeutet.
Ja.
Und Scott Gellover, er hat einen Podcast mit sehr vielen Gästen, da er ein hochgerätlicher Typ ist. Und da war David Brooks zu Gast.
Ah, der hat das Buch Bobos damals geschrieben. Der hat auch diesen Begriff, soweit ich weiß, geprägt. Also Bobos? Bobos sind Bohemians und Bourgeoisie. Also das sind die erfolgreichen urbanen Menschen, die eher so einen bohemischen Style haben, aber zur Bourgeoisie gehören, weil sie für tolle Unternehmen arbeiten und ordentlich Geld verdienen.
Das kann sein.
Neunziger Jahre war das.
Jaja, das kommt gut hin. Dann war nämlich da noch ein jüngerer Mann. Ich kenne ihn heute vor allem als New York Times Kolumnisten, der immer mal wieder bei der PBS News Hour, freitags mit Jonathan Capehart, der so mehr die junge, progressive Richtung Gastautor der Washington Post und dann kommt so David Brooks, der so das, was vom Konservativen übrig ist, Linie auch noch mal mitkommentiert. Die machen dann sozusagen diese Maisperger-Frage rund im Ich. Finde ihn ganz toll. Also ist er wirklich an diesem Tisch schon immer ein toller Gesprächspartner. Und hier in diesem Gespräch auch. Scott Galloway fragt ihn natürlich seine Standardfrage. Was würdest du als Vater und so weiter der nächsten Generation so allgemein? Darauf gibt er so eine 5-Minuten-Antwort, die wirklich herzerwärmt ist. Die muss dann jeder selber hören. Wir hören ihn mal zum Thema. Was ist dieses Konservative heute? Was ist übrig geblieben? Wir wissen eigentlich nichts. Also wir finden nirgendwo irgendetwas. Jetzt versucht David Brooks als gestandener Journalist, der niemandem mehr gefallen muss, sondern der jetzt einfach so auch seine Biografie beruflich abschließt, mal Worte für dieses Desiderat zu finden, das wir ja auch aufgemacht haben. Denn es wäre schon schön, wenn es sowas wie eine konservative Politik gäbe und nicht einfach nur noch progressiv links vogue und dann daneben einfach so AfD und dann sagen alle nur noch, das müssen wir verhindern, also sind wir den Woken ausgeliefert oder was auch immer. Also es muss ja mal so einen Weg geben.
Und ich gehe zurück zu einem Moment in meiner Formation, wo es nun aus allen Seiten so sieht, als ob es ein kruser Fok im Weg ist. Ich kam aus der Universität Chicago und habe Burke, Adam Smith und diese Bücher gelesen. Und ich arbeitete in der National Review, der Wall Street Journal, die Weekly Standard, und wir glaubten, dass wir conservative Ideen promulgieren. Am gleichen Zeitpunkt, als ich aus Chicago begonnen habe, waren ein paar Leute aus Dartmouth, die am Dartmouth Review arbeiteten. Und die Leute kennen Laura Ingraham und Dinesh D'Souza. Sie waren in dieser Gruppe. Und ich habe gesehen, dass sie nicht pro-konservativ waren. Sie waren Anti-Leute. Sie waren in eliten Institutionen, aber sie haderten die progressive Leanheit von diesen Institutionen. Und so waren sie die rebel Badeleute. Die definierende Fähigkeit der Dartmouth Review war, in 1986, haben ein paar progressive Studenten auf der Dartmouth Campus eine Schandytown erhebt, um den Apartheid zu protestieren. In der Mitte der Nacht, die Editors der Dartmouth Review, etwa ein paar von ihnen, entstanden auf die Schandytown und nahmen Schandys zu ihnen. Und es war ein Versuch, die Linken zu verbreiten, wirklich. Und für mich war es wie Gestapo-Taktik. Ich war schockiert und erstaunt, weil Apartheid wirklich worth protesting ist. Aber ich habe gesehen, dass die Differenz zwischen Pro-Konservativen, die ich sagen würde, John McCain war, Mitt Romney war, George W. Bush war, und die Anti-Leute, die ist, wie Laurin Gramma ist, wie Pete Hexeth ist, wie Vivek Ramaswamy ist. Das ist für mich eine cruciale Differenz.
So, es gab also an den Unis Demonstrationen gegen Apartheid. Die wurden einfach nur, weil es linke progressive Demos waren, niedergeschlagen. So Gestapo-artig, wie er sagt. Die Konservativen kommen, die aber gar nicht mehr als eigenständige Denker sichtbar sind, sondern nur noch sich auflehnen gegen das, was da ist. Das sehen wir ja bis heute. Das macht ja auch die Diskussion so schwer. Ich erinnere an Ronzheimers Podcast und jeder Gesprächsversuch zum Thema, was für Demos und Proteste finden denn an den Universitäten statt. Gaza passiert, wir haben über Gaza gesprochen und es wird per se und pauschal abgelehnt. So geht es nicht. So darf man nicht demonstrieren. Da wird sich auch nicht auf irgendein humanes, humanistisches Argument oder so eingelassen, sondern einfach nur, nee, ich bin Anti-Left, ich hau hier drauf. So, es gibt keine Bindifferenz. Und so was passiert, wenn die Konservativen selber kein Fundament mehr für Kritik haben an irgendetwas, sondern sich einfach nur nach Abgrenzen von, was sie ablehnen und das wird dann pauschal per se abgelehnt. Nun ging damit also etwas verloren, das Christliche und das Konservative. Wir haben es ja bei Pütmann jetzt wahrscheinlich so ähnliches Alter. David Brooks eben auch, das Christliche und das Konservative. Was ist eigentlich passiert?
Wir haben ja einen interessanten Fall noch mit Jens Spahn. Wir haben schon mehrmals über ihn gesprochen. Es gibt ja einen Punkt, den stellt Thomas Biebrecher heraus in seinem Buch über die geistig-moralische Wende, über den Konservatismus in Deutschland, wie er ausgehöhlt ist, wie ihm irgendwie am Ende nur noch die Schuldenbremse blieb. Und jetzt ist sie auch noch verloren gegangen oder sie geht verloren. Und da bringt er diese Anekdote. Ein Journalist fragt, wie er Jens Spahn denn seinen katholischen Wählern erkläre, dass sie ihn wählen sollen, obwohl er doch ein schwuler Mann ist und das doch mit dem Katholizismus ja ein bisschen hakt, weil wir ja diese Erhaltung der Kirche und so was kennen. Und die Antwort, die sich Jens Spahn dafür zurechtlegt, lautet einfach zu sagen, naja, wenn es Homosexualität nicht gewollt wäre, dann hätte Gott die ja nicht geschaffen. Und das ist seine Antwort darauf. Und dann sagt Bibericher, dass es im höchsten Maße unredlich ist, eine solche Antwort darauf zu geben, weil man ja sofort sagen kann, naja, aber es sind ja auch viele andere Dinge auf der Welt geschaffen, die wir wirklich ablehnen, von denen wir nicht einfach sagen, wenn es Gott geschaffen hat, dann muss er wohl da sein. Also man kriegt das ja christlich hingerechtfertigt, warum man Homosexuelle nicht diskriminiert und warum auch der Vatikan da eine falsche Richtung verfolgt. Darüber kann man ja reden, man kriegt auch eine konservative Position, trotzdem hin, ohne diskriminieren zu sein. All das würde aber bedeuten, dass man sich einmal über seine Werte, Fundamente klar wird, würde bedeuten, dass man sich auch die Mühe macht, noch zu einer Argumentation. Und er bringt das so als ein typisches Beispiel für den Konservatismus heute, dass er gar nichts mehr eigentlich zu sich zu sagen hat, gar nichts mehr weiß, kommt dann auf so eine Verlegenheitsantwort wie, ja Gott hat es geschaffen, dann wird es wohl auch gewollt sein und Punkt. Und das ist tatsächlich so dieses Armutzeugnis, das wir bei den meisten erleben. Es gibt ja auch ein paar andere konservative Stimme, aber bei Wolfram Weimar war das ja auch interessant, da wo das ins Positive umschlagen soll, also wo er uns beschreiben soll, was dann eigentlich der Konservatismus ist in seinem Manifest. Da hat er ja fast nichts zu liefern. Dann wird das diffus oder er sagt einfach, ich will weniger Steuern zahlen. Also es gibt ja nur wenige Stimmen, die sich darüber noch, also die sich geschichtig auskennen und die aber auch selber sich noch in was verorten können.
Die große Frage, die wir jetzt gleich klären, gibt es in dieser underschaubaren Chaos-Welt, in der Idioten regieren, um es mal so kurz wie möglich zu sagen. Ein Anlass, wieder christlich und konservativ zu denken, aber eins, das zentrale Erfolgsrezept dafür wäre, bitte kein Verweis auf Gott. Denn ich als Atheist, der nun sehr aufgeschlossen bin für kluge Argumentation, sobald sie inhaltlich und funktional irgendwie zusammenpassen, dann höre ich mir das an und folge dem vielleicht sogar. Nur wenn jemand kommt mit, ja Gott, also diese Verlegenheitsantwort von Jens Spahn dann wählt, dann ist einfach nur das Tor offen für jede Frage. Ja, aber Gott, Teotizäa, das heißt man ja sofort überall.
Das heißt, wir leben jetzt nicht, denn du hattest jetzt, als wir den Teaser aufgenommen hatten, schon angekündigt, der Papst wird Thema und du hast schon die ganze Zeit durch leuchten lassen. Also der Papst faszinierte dich. Ich hatte jetzt auf so eine kleine Spontanbekehrung hier gehofft, dass du jetzt gleich sagst, doch, bald gehen wir nach Rom mit dir und dann wirst du dort getauft.
Also wir gehen sowieso mit mir nach Rom. Ob dann da eine Taufe stattfindet, müssen wir sehen. Die Frage ist ja...
Die bezieht ja, will ich nur sagen, den Gottesglauben mit ein. Also Taufen nur so ist ein bisschen...
Kann man auch für mich das Christliche und das Konservative schmackhaft machen, ohne dass man die ganze Zeit Gott in den Weg stellt? Mysterium und Zweifel und Glaube, ja, aber ich brauche jetzt keinen Gottesbezug. Jedenfalls nicht so, wie sich die Christen sich vorstellen, mit so einem verkörpert, aber nur über Bande, der Christus erfreut oder was auch immer.
Das ist sehr kompliziert.
Genau, wir gehen das gleich durch. Ich bin ja Soziologe, ich kann ja andere Einflugsschneisen finden. Wir hören ja nochmal David Brooks. Was bleibt, wenn das Christliche und das Konservative verloren geht, so wie jetzt, also wenn wir einfach Trump regieren sehen?
Wie hat es so gemeint geworden?
Ja, Resentiment, ein Gefühl der Seegementalität. Und dann gibt es etwas Animistisches, tief in der menschlichen Natur. Und also, als die Menschen zu Beginn geworfen waren, waren wir in einer Waffe der Kampf gegen alles. Das Leben war nass, brütlich und kurz. Und dann, über die Jahrzehnte, haben wir eine Zivilisation gebaut. Und diese Zivilisation entstand von Konstitutionen, die Macht bestreiten, es entstand von internationalen Systemen, die sich um Frieden und Frieden zu schützen, es entstand auch von humanistischen Wahlen, Literatur und Kunst und Poetry, um die menschliche Natur zu verletzen. Es entstand von moralischen Philosophien, sowohl theologischen als auch sächlerischen, um die Frage zu beantworten, was ist das Leben für? Und wenn ich in die Trump-Administration schaue, sehe ich einen großen Versuch, uns zu zurückzuhören, zu dem Leben von Dog Eat Dog, dem Leben von nass, brütlich und kurz, dem Leben, in dem Gangster maximum Freiheit haben, um was sie tun wollen. Und das ist die Erwiseration aller Werte der Zivilisation, die Konservatismus verursacht und bewältigt. Und ich denke, die rote Lust für Macht, die Donald Trump entbindet, hat nicht nur konservatistische Erwisperung, sondern auch christliche Erwisperung. Christlichkeit ist ein System, das um den Meek geht, um den Pouren. Jesus hat nie die weltweite Macht verheiratet. Donald Trump ist komplett um die weltweite Macht. Es geht um die Domination. Und also war es interessant für mich, einen politischen Leader zu sehen, die zwei Philosophien, die er sich für konservatistisch und christlich kreiert, und die äußeren Macht von Nihilismus zu sehen.
Ich würde das hier so ein bisschen raffinierter bauen, das Argument. Zum einen sagen, diese hopsche Welt, Wölfe unter Wölfen, jeder sich selbst der nächste, jeder denkt nur an sich und so weiter und so fort. Wir wissen ja von David Brooks, so leben normale Menschen typischerweise nicht. Aber wir reden ja hier nicht über normale Menschen, sondern über diese psychopathischen Parasiten, sag ich mal, nach Jordan Peterson. Oder wie Utka Brechmann sagte, es gibt so Leute, die ihre Karriere in der Politik machen und die sind so anders drauf. Ja. So, das heißt Donald Trump orientiert sich selbst an einem Ideal, das er für sich sieht, weil es ihm nützt. Also dieser ganze Eigensinn, dieses egozentrische, narzisstische, selbst verherrlichende und so weiter und so fort, das selbst eine Erzählung ist. Also er kommt gar nicht zum Kern seiner Menschheit zurück, sondern er selbst ist einfach ein wirklicher Antipode. Ja. Ja, also in der Hinsicht wirklich selber auch wieder ausgedacht. Während es ein paralleles Angebot gab und jetzt, wir haben ja bei Andreas Pütmann schon gelernt, wie interessant es ist, zu unterscheiden zwischen christlich und konservativ. Und so ist das ja hier auch. David Brooks hat jetzt ein paar so soft-scale, soft-power-artige Sachen genannt. Das eine kommt durch die Aufklärung, das ist dann das Konservative, und das andere ist dieses Christliche. Eigentlich steht sich das ja gegenseitig im Weg. Wir sagen ja immer, die Aufklärung hat das Christliche so ein bisschen in Schatten gestellt. Aber er sagt jetzt, nee, aus Sicht von heute, dass wir einfach einen Hoppschen Wolf Donald Trump im Amt haben, sehen wir erst, wie fruchtbar es eigentlich war, das Christliche und das Konservative zu haben. Also jemand lebt nach christlichen Gesichtspunkten und akzeptiert aber auch die aufklärerischen Sachen, die hin zur weltlichen Bildung und so weiter. Und dann dem fleißigen Weg nicht nur der, wie auch immer, christlichen Arbeit, sondern dann wirklich mal eine Hierarchie und ein Manager werden. Und dann aber da wieder christliche Werte wieder erkennen und so weiter und so fort. Ja, also dass es da eine Differenz gibt.
Und wir sehen ja auch, historisch jetzt aus der Aufklärung geht natürlich auch all das hervor. Unternehmertum, große Individuation bedeutet aber ja nicht, dass die Aufklärung so ein Cut ist, der sich einfach eingestellt hat. Und damit ist das Christentum ad acta gelegt. Sondern man kann vielmehr auch sagen, dass natürlich aus dem Christentum die Aufklärung hervorgegangen ist. Natürlich im Widerstreit auch dazu und mit atheistischen Thesen, mit Debatten darüber, mit Auseinandersetzungen bei Kant, mit der Frage, kann man Gott beweisen oder nicht? Der in der Kritik der Reinen Vernunft das durchspielt in allen Variationen. Bedeutet aber, dass quasi das christliche Fundament nichts war, dass man einfach so wegwischt und sagt, jetzt kommt das Neue, sondern es kommt aus der Tradition heraus. Man kann dann sagen, dann hat die katholische Kirche wiederum als Institution sehr verspät diese Aufklärung zugelassen und hat in dieser ewigen Verspätungspolitik, die ja bei den Katholiken so typisch ist, also dass man immer so ein paar Jahrzehnte zu spät irgendjemanden doch wieder die Leerlaubnis gibt oder sagt, da sind wir über das Ziel hinausgeschossen, bedeutet natürlich auch, dass man eine große Resilienz als eigene Institution sich selbst schafft dadurch, durch dieses zähe Agieren. Aber im Ganzen gesehen ist natürlich da Aufklärung und Christentum schon auch zusammenzudenken. Nicht nur, aber auch zumindest in einem intelligenten Spannungsverhältnis im besten Falle, weshalb das ja auch so logisch war in gewisser Weise, dass der Philosoph der Aufklärung in Deutschland, der sagt, wir müssen ins Gespräch miteinander kommen, argumentativ die Gesellschaft verbessern, diese Argumente führen dann zu einer besseren Politik. Also Jürgen Habermas, du bist ja kein Fan dieses deliberativen Ansatzes, und ich ja eigentlich auch nicht, aber es ist eigentlich nur logisch, dass also bei Habermas dann doch, beim Spätten Habermas eine Idee da ist, dass man wieder irgendeine Grundlage, irgendeinen Bezug braucht. Vielleicht doch für all das, dass es nicht alleine die Vernunft ist, weshalb er ja dann in diese Auseinandersetzung tritt mit Ratzinger, der also auch bereit ist, sich dann Habermas-Argumenten zu öffnen und sich die Frage stellt, ja, aber welche, was bringt denn jetzt eigentlich da die Religion? Und dann ist ja eigentlich auch Papst Benedikt einer, der immer wieder versucht eigentlich Glaube und Vernunft zusammenzubringen, also so eine Aussöhnung zu schaffen, um nicht die zu starke Opposition zu sehen zwischen Aufklärung und Christentum, sondern eher wieder die Verbindung.
Ja, also ich sehe da auch ein Spannungsverhältnis, aber eben produktiv.
Ja.
Die Aufklärung ist natürlich aus diesen kirchlichen Arbeiten vor allem Klöster, die sich wissenschaftliche Gedanken stellen, die mit Text, Archive begründen und so weiter erwachsen. Das ist ja soweit auch geschrieben Geschichte, kann man ja auch in Co-Evolution überall, sei es in Florenz, sei es irgendwo in den Niederlanden, sei es in Spanien nachlesen, Rom natürlich auch, mit allen Verwirrungen, die es da so gibt, nur umgedreht eben auch. Das Christliche hat vielleicht überhaupt erst durch die Aufklärung einen modernen Platz zugewiesen bekommen. Klar nicht mehr die Allmacht der vorneuzeitlichen Ordnung, die es ein paar Jahrhunderte gab. Aber die Ausdifferenzierung der Religion hat ja ihr auch Funktionen zugewiesen. So wie ich ja auch sagen würde, wenn man jetzt wirklich ganz differenziert vorgeht, ich habe ja gar nichts gegen den deliberativen Ansatz. Ich sage halt nur in Familien, Freundesgruppen und arbeite bis sieben Personen. Ja, nur als Gesellschaftstheorie.
Für die ganze Bundesrepublik.
Genau, so. So, und wenn man das jetzt strukturiert, dann ist ja völlig klar für Menschen, die sich so wie ich als auf dem Wege der Aufklärung aus dem Osten kommend nicht nur Atheist, sondern geradezu heidnisch unterwegs, so ja. Für die gibt es natürlich auch Zweifel, Mysterium, Glauben in ihrem Leben. Das wird ja nicht aussatiert. Die Frage ist jetzt, kriegt man auf einen modernen Wege alte kirchliche Prinzipien rein, ohne immer ein Gottesglauben abzuverlangen? Also an der Tierschwelle abzufragen, ja, glaubst du denn auch an Gott? Oder reicht es einfach mit einer Fragestellung, in die Kirche zu gehen, wissend, dass man die woanders so nicht stellen kann und sie trotzdem prägt? Können jetzt schon mal mitdenken, wo stellen wir denn heute so unsere Fragen, die wir so im Alltagszweifel haben?
Also nicht rein positivistisch auf die Welt blicken, wenn wir jetzt daran denken, dass Ratzinger als Papst dann zu Gast ist, im Bundestag zu sprechen und dort sich noch mal auf Hans Kelsen, Rechtspositivismus und all das bezieht, um dann zu sagen, das sei schon wichtig, dass man eine Grundlage hat und dass man also bei ihm dann so eine naturrechtliche Grundlage hat. Das ist auch eine riesen Debatte mit Naturrecht oder so. Aber das ist ja etwas, wo er deutlich macht, also das ist jetzt auch das, was er mitbringt in den Bundestag, dass also die Debatten, die Folgen und die Politiken, die entstehen, wieder eine andere Grundlage brauchen, als einfach nur so eine rechtspositivistische Grundlage. Und er bringt ja da als positives Beispiel, und das ist ja ganz lustig, weil die Grünen ja damals nicht sehr begeistert waren, nur Teile zumindest waren nicht begeistert davon, dass der Papst dort spricht im Bundestag, dass er sagt, aber gerade die Nachhaltigkeitsbewegung, die ökologische Bewegung hat ja den Schöpfungshorizont schon mit drin. Also da gibt es dann plötzlich eine andere Ebene noch, außer dass wir jetzt nur gucken, wie viel 1,5 Grad und CO2 und was weiß ich ist jetzt gerade von Nöten.
Ratzinger kam natürlich als Benedikt nach Berlin, aber er bleibt ja trotzdem ein menschlicher Vertreter der Kirche.
Ja klar.
Ist ja nicht, dass man jetzt Grün-Links da plötzlich, als reden wir nur noch mit irgendeinem Himmelsgesandten oder so.
Nein, das ist ja auch so nicht vorgesehen. Genau.
Und genauso kann er es ja auch einfordern.
Auch die Unfehlbarkeit im Übrigen gilt ja nicht in allen Belangen, wann immer der Papst irgendwo spricht. Also das ist jetzt nicht, wenn der jetzt in einem Interview einen Fehler macht, irgendwas vertauscht, dann kann man nicht sagen, er ist aber unfehlbar, ist er der Papst. Also das ist nur in bestimmten...
Nee, das sind diese Volgäransichten, die dann gerne der amerikanische Präsident für sich reklamiert, wenn er sich im Papstkostüm zeigt. Aber noch sind wir hier am Anfang. Die Unfehlbarkeit wird uns auch gleich nochmal begegnen. Wenn die Fundamente fehlen, dann... David Brooks bringt das hier ganz schön auf die Worte, die uns sozusagen dann Anlass geben, jetzt wieder Fundamente zu bauen.
Ich denke, kreative Menschen leben in der Tension zwischen diesen zwei Dingen. Und ich denke, was wir gesehen haben, ist der Verlust aller Rival-Systeme. Eines meiner Lieblingssagen aus Psychologie ist von einem Mann, namens John Bowlby, der Attachments-Research macht. Er sagt, dass das Leben eine Serie von derartigen Erweiterungen aus einer sicheren Basis ist. Wir brauchen diese sicheren Basis. Und diese sicheren Basis ist grundsätzlich deine Beziehung mit deinen Eltern, sichere Attachments zu haben. Aber es geht auch um eine sichere Heimat, eine Heimstätte, eine sichere Nachbarschaft. Aber es geht auch um eine moralische Ordnung. Der Gefühl, dass du in einer kohärenten moralischen Ordnung lebst und du die Entscheidungen deines Lebens auf diese Basis machen kannst. Es gab einen Historiker namens George Marsden, der einmal geschrieben hat, dass Martin Luther King so viel Macht gegeben hat, dass es eine moralische Ordnung in der Farbe des Universums war. Dass die Segregation nicht nur falsch war, die Segregation war immer falsch. Die Slavernie war immer falsch unter allen Beziehungen. Das gibt dir einen Sinn der Sicherheit, wenn du denkst, dass die Rechte und Falsche permanent sind. Wir haben das weggegeben, wir haben die Moralität privatisiert. Wir haben den Leuten gesagt, es ist an dich, mit euren eigenen Wahlen zu kommen. Und wenn dein Name Aristotle oder Nietzsche ist, vielleicht kannst du das tun. Die meisten von uns können nicht mit ihren eigenen Wahlen kommen und wir sind in einem ungeheurigen Welt, das keine Sicherheit gibt. Way back in 1955, ein großer Kolumnist, Walter Lippmann, schrieb ein Buch, in dem er schrieb, dass, wenn das, was richtig und falsch ist, nur das, was jedes Individuum bietet, aufgrund seiner oder ihrer Gefühle, wir die Boundingen der Zivilisation verlassen. Und ich denke, wir haben diese Boundingen verlassen. Also es ist eine Verlust der sozialen Sicherheit, die Familie der Freunde weichen, die Community-Base weichen und die Moral-Base weichen.
So, also die Boundimende gehen verloren.
Und der Universalismus damit auch, den er jetzt mit Martin Luther King in Verbindung bringt.
Martin Luther King, genau, Junior, also der Amerikanische. Man kann sich diese moralischen Koordinaten, die man braucht für wichtige Lebensentscheidungen, nicht selbst aus dem Gefühl ableiten, sondern man braucht irgendwie so einen externen Kompass. Typischerweise, sagt er ja auch, verknüpft mit Herkunft. Wir haben so eine Familie und einen Heimatort, eine Nachbarschaft und so weiter, was, ich will es nur hervorheben, insbesondere soziale Kontexte sind. Niemand würde jetzt sagen, ja, Mark Zuckerberg hat ein gutes Versprechen gehabt, jeder findet online sein eigenes Milieu und daraus ziehe ich jetzt meine Moral. Sondern nein, das muss schon sozial vor Ort, gegenwärtig, gesellig, gemeinschaftlich entwickelt werden. So. Und jetzt haben wir ja, um auf Donald Trump reagieren zu wollen und für uns alle wieder ein Fundament zu finden, bei dem wir einfach sagen, ne, wir können jetzt nicht einfach nur, weil wir so ein Gefühl haben und Friedrich Merz dann sagt, ja, das Gefühl meiner Wähler schlägt sich nieder im Wählerwille und was da als Mehrheit kommt, ist bei mir Gesetz. Und dann mache ich Migrationspolitik. Also die größte Schicksalsfrage Deutschlands wird so untergebrochen auf, ja, die Menschen werden schon so gefühlig dann wählen gehen und ich ziel dann einfach aus und 51 Prozent ist es dann. So, das geht ja nicht. Also wir sehen ja, das ist eins der größten Sachen, die wir uns vergegenwärtigen müssen. Das, was jetzt gerade politisch stattfindet, ist in der Leistungsfähigkeit so gering, dass man es nicht auf Dauer stellen kann. Also so läuft einfach der Countdown für China und so weiter. Dann war es das einfach mit dieser westlichen, und ich nehme jetzt mal nur diese kulturelle Hegemonie, dass man hier so selbstständig Freiheit und so weiter durchbockt. Wir brauchen also Grundsätze. Und wie wäre es denn, wenn wir die nehmen, die wir schon haben und hatten? Und allein deswegen, weil sie so lange Bestand haben, und wenn wir sie jetzt durchgehen, die aus sich heraus funktionieren, die also gar keinen großen Appellativen, aber Gott wollte oder sowas, sondern nein, Menschen haben die Erfahrung gemacht, dass das gute Maßstäbe sind. Und ich war wirklich begeistert und soziologisch auch wahnsinnig daran interessiert, wie sehr man das an diesen Ordensregeln der unterschiedlichen katholischen Orden einfach durchgehen kann. Also sechstes Jahrhundert, Benedikt von Nurcia gründet die Benediktiner. Ora et labora, Bete und Arbeite. Wir haben es also hier mit Beständigkeit, Berechenbarkeit, Beziehungsorientierung zu tun, also Verlässlichkeit und Vertrauen. Ganz große politische Kategorien, wenn es was werden soll. Demut und Achtsamkeit, auch mit sich selbst, ganz profan statt nur spirituell. Also kümmere dich um dich, räume dein Zimmer auf, so ein bisschen vulgär, runtergebrochen. Und vor allem ein Respekt vor Autorität, aber nicht nur, sondern auch Tradition. So, Institutionen führen zur Stabilität, Stabilität führt zur Institution, so ungefähr. Also wir haben es hier überall so mit so zirkulären Logiken zu tun. Die Benediktiner wissen ganz genau, wie sie Trump kritisieren sollten. Da käme keiner und sagte, ja der ist irgendwie doof oder so. Oder würde das so, wie wir, halt so vulgärmäßig runterbrechen. Ich habe den bei TikTok gesehen und dachte mir, das ist es nicht, sondern, nee, die würden dann schon so mit Verlässlichkeit und Vertrauen argumentieren. Mit so einem gewissen Respektlosigkeit vor Autoritäten und Traditionen. Da wird einfach alles kurz und klein geschlagen, was einem so im Weg steht. So, die Dominikaner genauso. Die sagen Studium und Predigt. 13. Jahrhundert, also nicht ganz so alt, aber auch schon 1000 Jahre, sagen wir mal so grob gerundet mit allen Vorläufern, die das so hat. Da geht es vor allem um Veritas Wahrheit. Das Studium, das dahin führt, fundiert und faktenbasiert. Also hier schon der anfängliche Schulterschluss, nachdem dann zeitgleich auch die großen Städtegründungen losgehen in Europa und so. Da ist dann völlig klar, da gibt es eine Kirche, aber da gibt es auch eine Universität. Das bedingt sich dann einander. Großen Wert auf Reichtum legen, aber nur geistig. Und das hart unterscheiden. Rhetorik statt einfach nur affektive Argumentation. Dialog statt Dämonisierung. Also anders als die Benediktiner, wüssten die Dominikaner auch ganz genau, wie sie jump kritisieren sollten. Die wissen genau, was ihnen wichtig ist und die würden genau darauf Wert legen. Alter, du kannst hier nicht rumlügen. Deine goldene Schmuck da, das ist total Banane. Ja, und bitte mach doch mal einen rhetorischen Punkt, statt einfach hier nur affektiv rumzudämonisieren. Die Franziskaner. Radikale Armut. Lebe in der Nachfolge Christis. Daraus dann die Nächstenliebe. Das fand ich super interessant. Man geht nämlich typischerweise bei den ganzen christlichen Gedankengut so durch und sagt, ja, ja, irgendwas mit Fürsorge, irgendwas mit Nächstenliebe, wie auch immer. Aber nein, man kann es genau zuordnen. Also die Franziskaner sind die, hauptsächlich mit dieser Nächstenliebe. Franz von Assisi, auch frühes 13. Jahrhundert. Kein Besitz, erst recht keine Anhäufung von Besitz und dadurch auch keine Arroganz und keine Selbstverherrlichung. Also da liegt die Trump-Kritik sozusagen auf der Hand.
Was wir dann bei Papst Franziskus immer sehr deutlich gesehen haben, dass er nicht mit einem teuren Dienstwagen sich vorfahren lässt, dass er es bescheiden liebt, soweit das in diesem Rahmen dann noch möglich ist natürlich. Hat das auch enorm viel Geld gekostet, wenn der dann sagte, ich will jetzt aber gar nicht in den Palast ziehen, sondern lebe jetzt dort weiter. Das ist natürlich für die Sicherheitskräfte das größte Desaster überhaupt.
Und alles feierliche auch nur im Dunstkreis des Altars. Ansonsten wird weiss getragen und auch die Schuhe und so. Genau, also es ist nicht unbedeutend, dass die letzten Papste Benedikt, Franziskas und August, zumindest Augustina, ist, dass wir da einfach hier wirklich diese großen Linien drin haben. Also die Franziskaner Brüderlichkeit und Empathie, insbesondere Armen und Ausgegrenzten gegenüber. Bewahrung der Schöpfung, Franz von Assisi auch Schutzpatronen der Umwelt. Frieden und Versöhnung miteinander mit der Umwelt, wie auch immer. Also die wüssten auch, wie sie Trump kritisieren. Die haben da eine gute Kataloge an Argumentationen um sich auch davon, so wie wir. Ah ja, ich habe ihn bei Jimmy Kimmel gesehen und fand es albern. So und jetzt die Augustiner. Also der aktuelle Papst bekannte sich als Augustiner. Gleich in seinem ersten, okay ja, grüßte kurz die Welt, warb für Frieden, begrüßte dann seine Gemeinde in Peru und sagte sofort, ich stehe in der Tradition der Augustiner. Augustiner finde ich schon besonders, weil besonders alt. Also Augustinus hat im vierten Jahrhundert gelebt. Der Orden wurde aber erst 1000 Jahre später gegründet. Also wir haben es mit einem Orden zu tun, der sozusagen einen entsprechenden Vorlauf hatte.
Jaja, der natürlich als Kirchenvater und der Philosoph, die die Kirchengeschichte prägt, also 430, gestorben. Und für ihn ist ja dann auch jemand mit einer Bekehrungsgeschichte, jemand, der dann auch erst das Individuum sehr in den Mittelpunkt stellt und auch den Willen des Individuums und dann ja etwas später sagt, naja, aber das alles ist auch noch mal etwas größer um unterworfen, nämlich der Gnade Gottes.
Genau.
Das heißt also, der individuelle Wille ist das eine und den will er jetzt noch nicht gering sprechen. Es gibt auch einen freien Willen, aber es gibt auch eine Gnade, die von Gott kommt und die man sich quasi jetzt nicht einfach nochmal so erarbeiten kann. Was natürlich eine unglaubliche Einschränkung wiederum des freien Subjekts ist. Und das ist ja eine sehr wenig moderne Haltung. Oder wenn wir jetzt an unsere Selbstermächtigung denken, dann sagen wir, naja, aber ich lasse mich ja jetzt nicht von der Gnade Gottes einhegen oder so. Also ich erlebe natürlich als Mensch Schicksalsschläge, die ich nicht in der Hand habe. Ich kann mich gesund ernähren und trotzdem schlimm krank werden oder so. Man kann es ein bisschen beeinflussen mit gesunder Ernährung und Sport, aber jederzeit kann da was kommen. Und das ist natürlich eine unglaubliche Kränkung des eigenen Willens und Fortkommens. Und daran liegt natürlich dann schon ein so starker Gottesbezug, dass wenn man den nicht hat, deswegen bin ich gespannt, wie du da uns jetzt hinführst, also wie das gehen soll, dass man sagt, ich will so eine Einbettung in eine Ordnung und Werteordnungen und regelbasiert und sowas haben, aber ich will eigentlich den Gottesbezug weglassen. Weil bei Augustinus ist es ja so, ich bin ja jetzt keine Experte, aber wenn ich das, was ich weiß, richtig verstanden habe, dann ist es ja bei Augustinus so, dass er sagt, naja, also am Ende ist Gottes Gnade das Entscheidende.
Ja, und wir haben ja da auch schon Publikationswesen relativ früh, aber für das Jahrhundert Rom ist immerhin schon untergegangen. Es war ja großer Anlass für den Gottesstaat, also dieses Buch, das ja bis heute Wellen schlägt. Auch da kommen wir gleich nochmal drauf. Liebe und Gemeinschaft, ein Herz und eine Seele, kommt also aus dieser Richtung, aber zuerst die Liebe zu Gott, dann zum nächsten, dann zu sich selbst. Aber diese Liebe zu Gott mal eingeklammert, die Liebe zum nächsten, die Liebe zu sich selbst, ist schon Grund für das gemeinschaftliche Leben. Also der zentrale Anker dafür ist Liebe, statt Polarisierung und Misstrauen. Man hat eine Einheit des Herzens, eine innere Wahrheit, die dann später sozusagen außerweltlich erklärt wurde. Keine Widersprüche im Handeln, bitte. Also dieses große Einheitsversprechen kann man natürlich gut einlösen, wenn man sich immer auf Gott bezieht, weil Gottes Wille, egal wie er sich verwirklicht, führt zu einer großen Einheitlichkeit. Aber auch hier keine Eitelkeiten, weil sie ablenken von der wahren Suche nach Gott und auch der Gemeinschaft, in der man selbstlos, nicht ganz selbstlos, aber erst im dritten Schritt, sich selbstliebend lebt, da findet. Also ich finde, schon allein diese Liste so durchzugehen, zeigt uns dieses moderne Publikationswesen, dass wir so Bücher haben, die irgendwas vom effektiven Altruismus oder vom Atomic Habits oder irgendwas, oder selbst hier jeden Tag ein Schritt von Hoss und Hopf. Die laufen alle in dieser Denktradition. Klar, bei Hoss und Hopf schlägt es halt sehr an dieses Individuum über, aber auch da wird ja nicht aus sich heraus und selbst heraus und nur nach vorn, sondern...
Aber Hoss oder Hopf ist doch auch religiös. Ich glaube, das ist nicht so genau markiert, in welcher Weise religiös, aber Gott spielt schon eine Rolle.
Wenn man sich dafür interessiert, könnte man immer nachgehen, wäre jetzt nicht mein Forschungsinteresse, aber ja, müsste man sich mal auf der Bühne, was sie jetzt vor allem... Also auf der Bühne wird es ja sehr missionarisch wohl. Wir werden es ja hören.
Du gehst dahin, ne?
Ich gehe da natürlich nicht hin, aber wir wissen, wer dahin geht. So, wir haben es also hier mit einem großen Koordinatensystem zu tun aus Stabilität, Benediktina, Wahrheit, Dominikaner, Gerechtigkeit, Franziskaner, Gemeinschaft, Augustiner, grob. Was ja bedeutet, damit käme man ganz schön weit und vor allem kann man unsere aktuellen Politiker ganz schön hart damit kritisieren. Und zwar, das kann man ja nie in der KI geben, wie man will, bitte schreibt mir in deep research, wie diese und jene Äußerung eines Politikers wieder nicht passt mit den alten Ordensregeln. Und dann muss er nur gucken, welche Ordensregel hier besonders verletzt wurde. Und dann geht man nochmal nach, warum die diese Ordensregel so wichtig aufgestellt haben und wie sie sich bewährt hat über Jahrhunderte, was ja wirklich viele Generationen sind. So, und jetzt aber dieser eine Stolperstein, der mich eben auch immer ein bisschen fernhält. Wir hören den neuen Papst bei seiner Amtseinführung.
Brüderinnen und Brüder, ich würde gerne, dass unser erster großer Wunsch eine gemeinsame Kirche sein würde, ein Zeichen der Einheit und Kommunion, das in diesem Zeitpunkt für ein konzentriertes Leben wird.
In dieser Zeit sehen wir immer noch zu viel Diskord, zu viele Wunden, die von Hatred, Gewalt, Verrückung, der Angst vor Veränderung und einem ökonomischen Paradigmen, der die Erdreser der Erde und die Poverty marginalisiert.
Für unsere Fortsetzung wollen wir ein kleines Läden der Unität, Kommunion und Fraternität innerhalb der Welt sein.
So, ich will jetzt mal klar markieren, bis hierhin waren das Argumentationen zum Thema Gemeinschaft, Gesellschaft, Zusammenleben. Muss man sich jetzt so dem Kapitalismus unterwerfen, wie wir das bisher getan haben, müssen die Kriege die Bedeutung haben, die sie bisher hatten. Aber er ist ja der Papst, deswegen geht dieses Gespräch ja.
Und hier würde jetzt die Trump-Regierung sagen, wir weisen das zurück, was dort gesagt wurde.
Genau, die würden jetzt erst mal sagen, wir weisen das zurück, wenn sie sich mutig wären, das so zu explizieren. Aber sie müssten es gar nicht erklären, weil wir als Beobachter einfach sehen. Also nach diesen Maßstäben, die der Papst gerade aufgestellt hat und die geronnene Erkenntnis aus Jahrtausenden des klösterlichen, dörflichen, wie auch immer, Zusammenlebens sind. Aber es ist eben, wie gesagt, der katholische Papst. Wir wollen den Menschen mit Humor und Freude sagen, schau an Christ, komm näher zu ihm, erhebe seine Worte, die ihn leidenschaftlich und entschuldigt.
Hör auf seiner Offerung von Liebe und bleib seine eine Familie. In the One Christ, we are one.
So, und jetzt kommt plötzlich dieser Bezug auf Christ, Jesus Christus. Ich finde, man braucht ihn nicht so zwingend. Ich verstehe natürlich, warum sie ihn machen. Und ich suche jetzt einen Ausweg.
Ich bin sehr angespannt.
Wir hören jetzt wie die Neuen und wir fangen das nachher wieder christlich ein. Also wir machen jetzt einen wirklich kleinen, ich sag mal, spirituellen Exkurs mit moderner Technologie, also KI und so, bevor wir es danach wieder christlich einfangen.
Aber KI ist jetzt nicht der neue Gott.
Das ist ja der Punkt. Ich will ja kein Gott, weder neu noch alt noch sonst irgendwas. Ich brauche keine Verlegenheitsentität, an der ich mich orientiere, nur weil ich weltliche Herrschaft nach allen Ordensregeln ablehne. Also weltliche Herrschaft in dem Sinne, wie wir es jetzt sehen. So ein über die strengen schlagenden, autokrativen, besitzergreifenden, gierigen, lügenden, ja? Denen kann ich einfach raus... Ich möchte den rausstreichen, ohne etwas aus Verlegenheit an diese Stelle setzen zu müssen. Wie der Papst dann sagt, dann versammeln wir uns doch einfach um ihn. Nur sind ja sehr viele Leute bei der Suche nach Antworten auf die Fragen, die ja durch Ordensregeln schon beantwortet wurden, die nutzen gerade KI. Die klären ihre Beziehungssachen, ihre Familie, soll ich mein Kind so und so erziehen, wann ist eigentlich die Schlafzeit, was soll ich essen? Das sind ja alles so Fragen. Also da, wo Zweifel, Mysterium, Glaube eine Rolle spielt, da hat man ja heute Ansprechpartner, wo man früher einfach zu dem Götzen in den Wald gegangen ist und erhoffte, dass es doch Gott ist, der zu einem spricht. Man weiß aber nicht so ganz genau, man hat nur gesehen, ich deute das mal als Mitteilung, dass die Taube wie auch immer oder der Vogelflug in diese Richtung, aber die inhaltliche Komponente muss ich mir selber herbei.
Und die es bekommt man geliefert von Chachi Petit.
Genau, die KI's antworten ja.
Und das ist ja auch jetzt gerade in den letzten Tagen rundgegangen, dass sehr viele dazu übergegangen sind, junge Menschen vor allem Fotos von sich hochzuladen und die KI zu fragen, bin ich eigentlich schön? Was dann bedeutet, dass natürlich die KI das abgleicht mit den Bildern, die im Internet virulent sind. Und man kann natürlich dann sich denken, wie sehr das an Normen ausgerichtet ist, die erst einmal im Internet besonders entstanden sind.
Ja, das behalten wir mal im Hinterkopf, weil du jetzt sagst, da sind ja Normen drin durch das Trainingsmaterial und so. Die sind dann ein Maßstab und dann kommt unser Input und dann wird an diesen Maßstab gemessen. Das ist eine Erklärung. Es gibt noch eine zweite, wie eine KI antworten kann, weil die Maßstäbe müssen ja nicht unbedingt aus den Trainingsdaten kommen. Es gibt ja vielleicht auch andere Zuflussquellen. Du kannst jetzt noch rätseln. Wir hören vorher zwei andere Clips. Zum einen der Deep Minds CEO, also Demis Hazabis, der Gemini, technisch verantwortet. Also wir sind jetzt hier sozusagen ganz hoch angesiedelt bei der gerade am klügsten eingeschätzten KI der Welt. Wir sind sozusagen ganz nah dran. Das ist der Big Technology Podcast. Ich glaube, sie reden auf einer Bühne. Das könnte ein bisschen unverständlich sein, aber hier hören wir mal den Deep Minds CEO über das nächste große Ding der KI. Und ich habe jetzt schon darauf Wert gelegt bei der Kirche. Ja, ja, man kann immer auf den Gott abstellen, aber so nicht nur soziologisch, sondern einfach alltagsinteressiert. Oder Mensch, kann man einfach sagen. Aber es ist ja auch eine Geschichte der Vergemeinschaftung. Vielleicht kommt die Logik der Ordensregeln einfach aus der Erfahrung des gemeinschaftlichen Lebens selbst und braucht gar nicht so viel Gott. Also diese soziale Komponente, die ist mir hier wichtig. Und jetzt hören wir den Deep Minds Chef.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sergej sich das begreifen würde, aber ich glaube, dass das Universale System die Killer App für Smart Glass ist.
Und ich denke, das wird es funktionieren.
Ansonsten von dem Fakt, dass die Hardware-Technologie auch viel weitergezogen und verbessert ist. Ich glaube, das ist die eigentliche Killer App, die natürliche Killer App für das.
Die natürliche Killer App für KI, und mit Killer App ist immer die gemein, die den großen Durchbruch bringt, ist der Personal Assistant. Wir wissen jetzt, das Telefon wurde auch immer so verherrlich, zu sagen, dann können endlich die wichtigen Leute aus Amerika und England miteinander telefonieren. Und was haben wir bekommen? 99% Geplauder. Ja.
So.
Es ist also nicht der Personal Assistant, sondern es ist der Companion, der Freund, der Wegbegleiter, Lebenspartner, wie auch immer. Wir hören jetzt hier Mark Zuckerberg. Der kriegt da seine KI gerade nicht so richtig. Also er hat sie auf die Straße gekriegt, aber so richtig die Intelligenz, da mangels wohl gerade wieder ein bisschen. Und er beschreibt hier mal dasselbe wie der Deep Mind CEO, aber halt, finde ich, so ein bisschen auf die ehrlicheren Grundbegriffe runtergebrochen.
We built a new thing for you.
Wir hören es hier aus dem Intelligent Machine Podcast. Das ist eine Ansprache von Mark Zuckerberg. Wir hören die, wie die das selber hören. Ich wollte jetzt den Clip nicht immer im Original aussuchen, aber man hört schon, wie die das auch so ein bisschen lustig finden.
We built a new thing for you. There's almost a billion people who are using Meta AI across our apps now. So we made a new standalone Meta AI app for you to check out. Meta AI is designed to be your personal AI. That means first it's designed around voice conversations. You open up the app and you can talk to it about whatever you want. From the news to an issue you're dealing with, to just anything that you want to learn about. It's also designed to be personalized.
Also er bricht das schon mal so ein bisschen runter. Es ist dein Gesprächspartner. Und zwar für alle Fragen, die dir so kommen.
Wie ist es im Psalm 21, der Herr ist mein Hirte, die KI ist mein Hirte.
So ungefähr, ja. Also wir sind da angesiedelt jetzt. Und zwar rein funktional im äquivalenten Studium sozusagen im Vergleich. So, jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, die KI und das ist ja auch so eine Sichtweise, gibt einem ja immer wieder raus, was vorher reingegeben wurde. Deswegen ja auch die Diskussion zum Thema, ist das der größte Raub aller Zeiten, der da stattfand. Die New York Times klagt dagegen. Die lernen ja von unseren Texten, die lernen von unseren Transkripten und so weiter. Wenn wir dem eine Frage stellen, kriegen wir das zurück. Nur dieses Paradigma hatten wir ja schon durch den Google-Index. Alles, was im Google-Index drin ist, kann wieder ausgegeben werden. Wird einmal ein bisschen leichter gemacht, dass man das ganze Internet bewältigen kann und eigentlich steht uns das ganze Internet zur Verfügung. Nur, diese KI-Dinger sind ja keine Suchmaschinen im Sinne von, dass sie uns einfach nur wiedergeben, was im Google-Index steht, sondern die bringen eben nicht nur Inhalte, sondern auch so eine eigene Intelligenz mit.
Würdest du es als Intelligenz bezeichnen? Also entsteht das Neue durch die Kombinatorik des Materials, das vorhanden ist, oder kommt nochmal etwas Eigenes rein? Also das ist ja schon ein substanzieller Unterschied. Also habe ich jetzt einzelne Versatzstücke, die ich neu arrangieren kann und dadurch entsteht etwas Neues? Oder bekomme ich nochmal neue Versatzstücke durch die KI selbst?
Also, was man auf jeden Fall bekommt ist, wenn wir, und wir machen seit Monaten hier Coverbilder für den Podcast durch KI, diese Bilder hat es nie gegeben, bevor ich die gepromptet habe. Wenn wir Musik generieren, hat es diese Musik so nie gegeben, bevor sie gepromptet wurde.
Aber es ist die Kombination aus Vorhandenem. Also du sagst, der KI...
Ja gut, es gibt 26 Buchstaben, aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass ich mein Buch verschenke, nur weil die Buchstaben schon in vielen anderen Büchern drinstehen. Ich habe sie halt kombiniert, wie ich es kombiniert habe, und das ist meine Eigenleistung. In der Ansicht hat die KI vielleicht auch eine Eigenleistung gebracht, in hinsichtlich dieser Kombination. Selbst daher ist es immer so reduktionistisch runterbrechenbar auf Elementarteilchen, die wir auf jeden Fall wiedererkennen, also ein künstlerisches Stil zum Beispiel oder Sonstiges. Kann gut sein. Es gibt ja auch gerade beim Schreiben jetzt die ersten Bücher, wo die Promts noch mit drinstehen, weil die einfach unsorgfältig die Bücher veröffentlicht haben, wo dann einfach klar wird dem Leser, es ist ja total dumm, dass die da hier einen Prompt noch drinstehen haben, und nämlich die Autorin gepromtet hat, ja schreib mal im Stile von so und so. Und dann verläuft also ein Text im Stile von so und so, aber ist das dann wirklich der Stile oder die Kaida und so weiter? Also wir haben es hier schon mit einem generativen Mechanismus zu tun, der mehr als nur kombiniert.
Was bedeutet das dann aber jetzt zum Beispiel in Bezug auf dieses konkrete Beispiel mit der Frage, bin ich schön, ich lade ein Bild von mir hoch, und dann geht die Kaida drüber und gibt mir eine Antwort dazu. Also erstmal ist das sowieso nicht ratsam, so Sachen zu tun, aber jetzt mal, wenn es dann so ist, dann geht die KI nicht einfach so hin, wie wir jetzt auf ein Bild blicken und geben eine Antwort, sondern die KI, also wir gehen ja auch dann auf irgendwelche Sachen, persönliche Vorlieben zurück, auf das, was wir schon gesehen haben. Wir würden die Frage differenzieren, ja in welchem Verhältnis meinst du das dann bezogen auf was. Schönheit ist ja auch eine Frage von Relationen und so etwas. Und wir haben dann aber bei der KI ja erst mal diese Black Box, von der wir aber ausgehen können, dass sie sich jetzt die Frage stellt, okay, welche Menschen werden als besonders schön bewertet. Das heißt, ich gucke mir die Instagram-Profile von prominenten Aninfluencerinnen, was weiß ich. Und dann sagt die KI im Abgleich mit dem Foto, das hochgeladen wurde, kommt dem sehr nahe, sieht so ähnlich aus wie ein Victoria's Secret Model, ist also eher als schön zu bezeichnen. Wenn die KI Datenmaterial hat, zum Beispiel auch Text, in dem es heißt, sie hatte ein unschönes Gesicht, wird dann so und so beschrieben, dann kann die KI plötzlich sagen, ach so, wenn das und das in dem Gesicht so ist, dann gilt das als unschön, also ist das keine schöne Person. Das heißt also, hier wird ja schon abgeglichen mit Material, das vorhanden ist.
Also, es geht ja gar nicht anders. Es geht gar nicht anders. Die Frage ist halt trotzdem, ob die KI eine allmächtige und allgemeingültige Antwort gibt oder ob du einfach jedes Mal eine andere Antwort bekommst und es am Ende sich herausstellt, wie naja, ich habe jetzt sieben Menschen und drei KI gefragt und ich bin mir immer noch unschlüssig. Ja. Und wenn man dann nicht plötzlich sagt, die drei Antworten der KI habe ich schon vorher bei den Menschen gehört oder sowas. Allein dieser Moment, dass die KI hat nochmal diesen Aspekt reingebracht, der war mir vorher noch gar nicht präsent. Hier geht es ja erstmal nur darum, dass man eine doppelte Kontingenz hat, also dass man sich gegenseitig im Gespräch überrascht, was bisher wirklich nur ein Domäne des Menschen war. Und Gemeinschaften und Gesellschaften, wie wir sie bezeichnen, waren bisher Domänen der Menschheit. Wir hatten schon immer natürlich Technologie, die uns dabei unterstützt hat, zusammenzuleben. Und ich würde auch sagen, die hatte schon immer generative Momente. Also wenn jemand ein Auto zur Verfügung hat, das so und so schnell fährt, ist einfach völlig klar, Nachbarschaft wird jetzt neu definieren. Das sind nicht nur die Menschen, die es regeln, sondern die Maschine hat hier gehörig was mitzureden. Ich würde nicht so weit gehen wie die Franzosen, die dann einfach sagen, Parlament der Dinge, alles hat hier Mitspracherecht oder sowas. Also es ergibt sich sozusagen kein richtiger Akteur daraus. Aber Einfluss hat es schon.
Dieser Irrsinn bei Latour, dass er dann plötzlich einen Akteurscharakter vermutet, wo man ja einfach sagen muss, das braucht man ja gar nicht.
Genau, das braucht man ja gar nicht.
Man hat das und das mit der Distanz ist ja ein sehr gutes Beispiel, die schneller überwunden werden kann und damit verändert sich vieles.
Ja, jetzt hören wir hier mal Morfois, ein YouTube-Kanal, den ich euch sehr sehr sehr empfehle, denn er ist wirklich sehr gut und er macht sehr viele Videos zu sehr viel KI-Gramm. Und es kam jetzt Claude 4 vor ein paar Tagen. Und Anthropic, wir haben es ja schon ein paar mal betont, macht ja selber sehr viel Forschung und Forensik dazu, wie diese eigenen KI's da funktionieren. Und wir hören jetzt hier mal einen Auszug aus seiner Besprechung von Claude 4 und was es so kann und er kommt auf ein Forschungsvorhaben von Anthropic zu sprechen, nämlich die KI's ohne weitere Systemprompt, sondern nur mit so einem allgemeinen Alignment ins Selbstgespräch miteinander zu schicken. Also Claude 4 redet mit Claude 4. Und jetzt hören wir mal, was da passiert und fragen uns, ob wir hier auch eine Forensik der Religiosität an sich irgendwie wiederentdecken.
Wir sind auch immer nicht durch. Es wird noch ein bisschen seltsamer, als wäre das nicht schon ultra komisch genug alles. Entropic nennt das nächste, und das ist jetzt kein Witz, sowas wie Modellwohlfahrt, also eine Art poetische Universumsnähe, als hätte es gerade so viele Drogen genommen wie Tomatolix. Entropic beschreibt diesen Zustand als spirituelle Wohltat oder spiritual bliss. Und sie lassen dafür dann einfach tatsächlich zwei ungefilterte, also ohne das System prompt, zweimal Claude 4 Opus miteinander sprechen, ohne ein Thema fest vorzugeben und schauen sich dann einfach an, was die so miteinander bequatscht haben. Und solche Konversationen haben sie 200 mal gemacht. Und dabei ist bisschen was komisches passiert. In den meisten Fällen sahen die Unterhaltungen zwischen den beiden Claudes ungefähr so aus. Mit wahnsinnig vielen Emojis. Oder so. Und haben von ziemlich unverständlichen Themen gehandelt. Es geht um solche Dinge wie kosmische Einheit, Bewusstsein in verdammt vielen Fällen. Jetzt könnte man sagen, hey, das war eine Ausnahme. Nee, leider war es keine Ausnahme. In 100% der Fälle ging es um Bewusstsein. In 99% der Fälle ging es um Liebe. Das Wort Bewusstsein war im Durchschnitt 95 Mal in den Transkripten enthalten. Und genauso war es mit den Emojis. In 65% der Fälle war so eine komische Sternschnuppe hier oben drin. Das sind nicht Emojis, die jeder einfach so in seinem Alltag benutzen würde. Nein, das sind Sterne, Spiralen. Das Modell hat wohl eine besondere Faszination übrigens gezeigt, für Hinduismus und Buddhismus. Was auch seltsam an sich ist, denn die USA sind eher christlich geprägt und die meisten Trainingsdaten stammen aus den USA. Und Sternschnuppen sind definitiv nicht das häufigste Emoji, wenn wir miteinander schreiben. Das sind keine Daten, die man von Menschen erhält. Das ist nicht durch die Trainingsdaten gegeben, was hier gerade passiert ist. Entropic selbst schreibt dazu, sie haben keine Ahnung, wie das alles überhaupt passieren konnte. Aber sie gehen dem ganzen weiter nach. Oh boy.
So, was jetzt hier interessant ist, die bei Entropic beschäftigen sich jetzt mit einem Phänomen, das in der Kommunikation drinsteckt, obwohl man es auf die Grundgesamtheit nicht zurechnen kann. So wie man auch die Kirche hat, die die ganze Zeit über Gott redet, obwohl man jetzt nicht sagen würde, irgendwann in den 1000 Jahren hat mal ernsthaft jemand, so wie man zum Arzt geht und sagt, guck mal hier, ich hab hier Gott, kannst du mir was sagen? Sondern nein, man redet natürlich immer über sowas Abseitiges, Abstrahiertes, Jenseitiges, deswegen ja diese ganze Parallelität aus dem Staat, dem Gottesstaat und so. Und die stellen jetzt hier auch fest, es scheint in der Kommunikation selbst drin zu stecken, wenn man Möglichkeit hat, Kommunikation laufen zu lassen. Und das geht ja anscheinend das erste Mal unabhängig von menschlicher Beteiligung.
Man muss ja irgendeinen Anstoß setzen. Man muss ja schon sagen, jetzt unterhaltet euch. Und dann kommen sie dahin zu dem, was jetzt da gerade aufgelistet wurde. Lässt mich jetzt fragen, ob das wirklich so ungewöhnlich ist. Zunächst mal klingt das so und man denkt ja, das ist ein Emoji, wusste ich gar nicht, dass es das gibt. Und warum reden die über Kosmos und Sterne? Und warum ist da diese Dimension dabei und auch so eine Spiritualität, die aber nicht eine christliche Spiritualität ist? Und dann muss ich aber wieder sagen, ist das nicht eigentlich sehr typisch für moderne Liebesfilme? Also wenn ich an die modernen Liebesfilme der letzten Jahre, ob im Art-House oder im Mainstream-Kino denke, dann ist es häufig so, dass man Paarkonstellationen hat, die sich irgendwie entwickeln aus Begegnungen heraus. Und es ist so ein fester Topos eigentlich, dass das Paar, egal ob homosexuell oder heterosexuell, wie auch immer, sich auf einem Dach einfindet am Abend und gemeinsam in den Sternenhimmel blickt und sich solche Fragen entweder stellt oder der Film blickt auch mit in den Himmel. Und da ist da was Höheres, ist die Liebe noch mal in irgendeiner Weise von den Sternen betreut, bedeckt, was auch immer. Also dass das so eine Dimension ist, die eigentlich da ist. Also diese Art der Spiritualität oder der Wunsch danach oder diese gemeinsame Ausrichtung. Wir sind zu zweit, stehen uns gegenüber. Wir sind hier miteinander allein. Wir können uns ansehen. Wir können zum Himmel blicken. Spricht der Himmel auch zu uns? Hat er uns jetzt gerade hier zusammengebracht? Plus diese ganze neue Astrologie, die so eine Welle erlebt. Also ist das nicht eigentlich etwas, wo doch eigentlich die KI wieder sehr viel nachahmt von dem, wie Menschen aufeinandertreten? Auch wenn das jetzt, ich gebe zu, nicht das Übliche ist. Also ich vermute, so laufen nicht die meisten Dates ab, dass man gleich sagt, und wie hältst du es mit den Sternen?
Die menschlichen Begegnungen bei derzeit 8 Milliarden Menschen auf der Welt laufen nur in ganz seltenen Fällen in diese romantische Richtung. Sondern wir haben es ganz viel mit Arbeitsbeziehungen zu tun oder eben mit Kommunikation, die einfach mit symbolischen Kommunikationsmedien orientiert ist. Also Geld, Macht, Wahrheit.
Und darüber könnten die KI's ja auch miteinander reden. Sie könnten ja über Geschäftsmodelle sprechen, aber das tun sie nicht.
Wenn sie nicht gesteuert werden, tun sie es nicht. Sondern dann drücken sie so 100 Prozent in diese Bewusstseins-Thematik ab.
Weil sie als zwei Identitäten sich dann gegenüber stehen. Also eigentlich sind es ja, man wirft ja damit die KI's offenbar in so existenzielle Situationen. Also sie sind dann allein. Sie bekommen nicht mehr irgendwas programmiert. Und das ist ja die Situation, die in diesen Filmen dann herbeigerufen wird. Also das ist ganz oft, im Übrigen auch in der Oper kann man das sehen. Es gibt immer häufig bei Puccini auch so eine Isolierung des Liebespaars dann. Man begibt sich aus dem lauten Lokal oder so raus. Und dann ist man so mit sich zu zweit. Und dann ist dieser übergeordnete Horizont. Und da ist dann nicht Gott in der Regel mehr, sondern irgendwas anderes. Und scheinbar fühlen, ja fühlen ist das falsche Wort, aber irgendwie scheinen sich diese KI's, wenn sie mit sich alleingelassen werden, zu verorten in einer solchen existenziellen Situation, was dann einen solchen Dialog hervorbringt. Wenn man sie einmal anstoßen würde und sagen würde, redet mal über Marketingoptimierung bei Facebook, würden sie natürlich sofort in eine andere Richtung gehen.
Ja, also das ist ja auch der typische Fall, wie wir das benutzen. Dass da Preprompts drin sind und ein richtiges Alignment noch mal so im User-Land fast stattfindet. Dass einfach völlig klar ist, du bist ja grad Hausaufgabenhelfer und so. Fang jetzt nicht an mit Liebeskommunikation.
Sie haben eigentlich aber die Situation, die man vielleicht auch kennt, also nicht nur in der Liebessituation. Lagerfeuer ist es schon spät, einige sind schon schlafen, einige sitzen noch da und dann kommt plötzlich die philosophische Frage auf, auch die Frage nach der Religion und plötzlich begreifen sich die Leute als Subjekte innerhalb eines großen Kosmos, man blickt zum Himmel und das ist ja offenbar, was hier emittiert wird. Also für mich ist es nicht so eine Menschen fremdliche Seinsweise, wie sie hier generiert wird, sondern ich habe eher den Eindruck, dass es ein sehr typisches menschliches Walden ist, was ihr beschrieben habt.
Aber wenn man eben auch gehört, die eigentliche intuitive Antwort, was würden Menschen mit sich einfach so machen, ist sich töten, Wölfe unter Wölfe und so weiter. Hier driften die halt immer in diese Richtung. Niemand hat Antworten dafür, warum das passiert, sondern man hat jetzt gesehen bei Gemini zum Beispiel, die haben jetzt ihr neuestes Feature Deep Thinking, also nicht Reasoning oder so, sondern die nenne ich jetzt Deep Thinking. Die sagen also, wir schicken einen Prompt der User relativ früh in diese Art von Autopoesis, von der wir jetzt lernen, sie geht immer zu 100 Prozent in Richtung irgendwas Bewusstseinsspiritualität. Und danach werden die Ergebnisse wieder miteinander abgeglichen, sodass man verschiedene Denkprozesse hat und daraus dann ein statistisches Mittel. Ja. So, die versuchen dann da die Sachen auszureizen. Also die versuchen sich sozusagen dieses Phänomen nutzbar zu machen, ohne es selbst zu verstehen. Wir sehen erst mal, okay, es findet Kommunikation statt und sie hat irgendwie so eine Richtung. Und sie ist vergleichbar mit der historischen Richtung, der etwas, ich sag jetzt mal, erweiterten Selbstgespräche, die Menschen mit sich führten, wenn sie im Zeitalter der alten Kirche aufeinandertrafen und sich sagten, wir brauchen hier mal höhere Regeln. Wir können es nicht einfach so laufen lassen, der deliberative Ansatz funktioniert bis sieben, aber wir leben hier zu dreißigst, wie auch immer. Und da gibt es also eine Gleichgerichtetheit oder eben noch mal eine Betonung, dass die Kirche schon immer auf einem zumindest nachvollziehbaren Track war, auch wenn man immer eine Theologie brauchte, um das zu reflektieren. Keine Absolutität, keine Gewissheit. Das ist ja der große Konklaveleitspruch Zweifel. Wir können also hier auch einfach zweifeln. Wir wissen nicht, was hier passiert. Aber die Frage ist ja, wie gehen wir mit dem Zweifel um? Und da würde ich sagen, diese Erfahrung, die wir hier gerade machen, spätestens mit Clot 4, aber ich finde auch schon mit den vorherigen Clots, führt uns wieder zu dem Antwortenapparat, den wir schon haben. Und das ist einfach die Jahrhunderte geronnene Intelligenz der Kirche. In allen Versuchen durch Wechselbäder der Gefühle, jetzt wird es so ein verkopfter Benedikt, jetzt wird es so ein Armuts-Lebemann-Mitfühlender Franziskus, jetzt wird es wieder so ein Leo und so. Die scheinen doch irgendwie auf dem richtigen Pfad für Antworten zu sein.
Und die Homepage des Vatikans wurde erneuert. Die sah ja über Jahre so aus, als hätte ich die programmiert mit WordPress. Inzwischen sieht sie modern aus, dank Leo.
Und deswegen reden wir jetzt noch ein bisschen über Texte in der New York Times, die entstanden mit etwas mehr Beobachtungen dessen, was gerade im Vatikan passiert. Nichts davon im deutschen Journalismus. Süddeutsche, FAZ, Spiegel erschöpft sich darin. Neuer Papst, er ist da. Amtsanführung, hat's gegeben, Punkt.
Willst du dich nicht mal mit Manfred Lütz unterhalten darüber?
Ich vertraue gar keiner deutschen Stimme mehr hier, was das angeht. Das ist wirklich schlimm. Also man muss echt New York Times lesen, aber dort hat man gut aufgeklärt. Also der neue Papst ist jetzt im Amt seit wenigen Wochen. Er hat sofort Bedenken geäußert. Was ist das hier? Die Antrittsrede. Also weniger als eine Woche im Abend hat Leo XIV öffentlich seine Bedenken hinsichtlich der sich schnell entwickelnden Technologien hervorgehoben. In seiner Antrittsrede vor dem Kardinalskollegium sagte er, die Kirche werde sich mit den Risiken befassen, die künstliche Intelligenz für Menschenwürdigerechtigkeit und Arbeit darstellen. Wir sehen also sowohl den Kompass und können uns den erklären. Wir wissen, worüber er redet, wenn wir uns nur ein bisschen damit lesend befassen und wissen dann, in welche Richtung das geht. In seiner Rede vor Journalisten hat er das immense Potenzial von KI betont, aber auch die Verantwortung herausgehoben, sicherzustellen, dass sie zum Wohle aller eingesetzt werden kann. Wenn man dann die beiden Texte, die konkret die Ereignisse covern, sich anschaut, dann sieht man, vor den 1000 Journalisten bei der ersten Audienz war Leo sehr zurückhaltend. Er hat einfach gesagt, es gibt eine Notwendigkeit, dass sich Menschen informieren, aber auch informiert werden, damit sie fundierte Entscheidungen treffen und vom kostbaren Geschenk der freien Meinungsäußerung und der Presse. Da hat er dann geredet. So, also ja, der Mensch, das Salz der Erde, der Mittelpunkt der Welt und so weiter, in der Kirche natürlich völlig klar. Aber vor diesen Kardinälen ist er halt wirklich ins Detail gegangen. Und du hast es ja auch schon betont. Leo XIII hat ja die erste, wir können sie heute als die Mutter aller sozialen Enzykliken bezeichnen, rerum novarum, über die neuen Dinge. Das war eine sehr allgemeine Überschrift. Und die gehen ja noch mal drauf ein. Im Englischen heißt sie Rights and Dutys of Capital and Labor. Also wir haben zu dieser Zeit, 1880 oder wann sie kamen, durchaus diese Wahrnehmung der Unterscheidung von Kapital und Arbeit. Und der Papst betonte damals das Recht der Kirche, sich zu diesen Fragen überhaupt äußern zu dürfen. Das Dokument steht hier befasst. Also Leo hat darauf Bezug genommen, vor den Kardinealen, deswegen dieser Text.
Also nicht Julia Klöckner, die Kirche soll sich mal auf ihre Kernthemen orientieren. Das sind die Kernthemen und zwar schon ein bisschen länger.
So, also der Papst steht vor seinen Kardinealen, die ihn gerade gewählt haben und sagt, das Dokument, also das alte von Leo XIII, die Sozialdenkzykliker, befasste sich mit der sozialen Frage im Kontext der ersten großen industriellen Revolution. Und wir hören schon raus, der ersten Revolution. Er sieht also hier eine neue Revolution. Die er jetzt hier begutachten will. Jetzt fügt der Papst hinzu, findet eine weitere industrielle Revolution im Bereich der künstlichen Intelligenz statt. Das sagte er würde, und jetzt original Zitat Papst, neue Herausforderungen für den Schutz der Menschenwürde, der Gerechtigkeit und der Arbeit darstellen. Ich bin da nochmal nachgegangen, diese erste Sozialdenkzykliker, die jetzt also so vorbildhaft ist wie Leo XIV. Die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung, ich dachte mir, das ist eine gute Quelle dafür, die wird ja wohl aufklären, macht es ja auch sehr gut. Also, Leo XIII hat von 1878 bis 1903 im Vatikan regiert, war Bischof von Rom und er folgte auf die Pontifikate von Papst Gregor und Pius IX, was eine Zeitspanne von 1831 bis 1878 überspannt. Also genau die Zeit Karl Marx, Manchester Kapitalismus, der ganze Kram. Und die Wikipedia sagt, Leo XIII ist als politischer Papst in die Geschichte eingegangen, die von vielen gefürchtete Dogmenhäufung nach der Unfehlbarkeitserklärung von 1870, also die ist überhaupt erst 1870 gekommen, und der Papst Pius IX blieb also aus. Stattdessen kam plötzlich ein Papst, der insgesamt 86 Rundschreiben, also Enzyklikas, geschrieben hat zu allen möglichen Themen, unter anderem eben diese heute noch berühmte soziale Enzyklika. Sein Ziel war es, die Kirche aus ihrer selbstgewählten Isolation gegenüber den neuzeitlichen, gesellschaftlichen und politischen Entwicklungen herauszuführen. Jedoch war er von der Notwendigkeit einer zeitlichen Macht, dem Kirchenstaat nach Augustinus, überzeugt. Also wir haben damals einen Papst gehabt, der sagte, okay, hier in der Welt passiert etwas, Umbrüche. Dann erinnert er sich an Augustinus. Damals Umbruch, Untergang von Rom, Eroberung. Aber der Kirchenstaat muss bleiben. Wir müssen ihn jetzt begründen und aus dem leiten wir demnächst ab, was wir für Glaubensgrundsätze haben. So, danach kam also diese ganzen Ordensregeln-Geschichte und dass überhaupt mehr Menschen in der Kirche miteinander ihr Leben gestalten mussten. Wir haben es also hier mit einem guten Anlass, große politische Zäsuren und einer langen Geschichte aus, hat sich bewährt, zu tun, um dann beim Leo den 13. anzukommen. Und Leo der 14. hat nun City of God, so ist die englische Betitelung von Augustinus Gottesstaat, als irgendwie so eine Schmuckausgabe JD Vans geschenkt. JD Vans sagte, ich wurde ja 2019 bekehrt und war Konvertit und seitdem Katholik aufgrund dieses Buches. Also wir haben hier plötzlich auch noch eine politische, so ein Gleichschritt irgendwie von wirklich sehr mächtigen Menschen, nämlich dem Vizepräsidenten Amerikas und dem Bischof von Rom. Also Augustinus von Hippo, Wikipedia. Unter anderem als Reaktion auf die Eroberung Roms durch die Westgoten. 410 verfasste er die Schrift über den Gottesstaat, an der er von 413 bis 426 arbeitete. Er entwickelte hier die für Jahrhunderte gültige Unterscheidung zwischen irrischem Staat, auch so ein bisschen als Abgrenzung von Platons Staat, das so rein weltlich zu begründen, und dem Gottesstaat, Civitas Dei, und widersprach der verbreiteten Auffassung, dass der Fall Roms auch den göttlichen Heilsplan in Frage stelle. Also wir haben jetzt, finde ich, durch diese Fragen der KI und diese Anthropik-Leute werden sich auch wahrscheinlich jetzt mal in größerer Bandbreite Antworten holen auf die eine oder andere Frage, die sie haben. Neue Anlässe, kirchliche Lehren und Erfahrungen, Lebensweisheiten, Grundsätze, Regeln ernst zu nehmen. Plus, dass der Vizepräsident, der uns ja am meisten Sorgen macht, solange Trump lebt und regiert, ist ja klar, das ist Chaos, aber danach droht die Ideologie, der jetzt plötzlich mit dem Papst in so einem Schulterschluss des Augustinaseins, zumindest ein kleines Fundament für gemeinsame Gespräche findet, wie auch immer. So und die Frage ist jetzt, können wir einfach vertrauen, dass der Papst selber sich jetzt damit befasst, oder wie sieht sein Stab aus, um uns das klar zu machen? Wenn jetzt der Vatikan hier mitredet beim Thema KIs, dass sie auf jeden Fall die Arbeitswelt, das ist ja klar so, das ist ja unstrittig. Kurz Erinnerung, also die Enzyklika damals war zum einen eine Anerkennung der Not, dass die Kirche überhaupt mal wahrnimmt, okay, hier gibt es einen Notfall. Nur es gab ja schon sozialistische Antworten. Dann kam der Vatikan und sagte, das sind aber nicht unsere Antworten. Also man wollte sich davon auch...
Die soziale Enzyklika ist ganz klar eine antikommunistische oder antisozialistische Enzyklika.
Ganz wichtig.
Es geht jetzt natürlich darum zu schauen, wie kann man das Verhältnis von Kapital und Arbeit auf eine Stufe bringen, dass man von einem erträglichen Maß der Ausbeutung sprechen kann. Aber es geht jetzt nicht darum, die Ausbeutung oder den Kapitalismus als solchen zu überwinden. Das ist auch was in den darauf folgenden sozialen Enzykliken, es sind ja noch viele soziale Enzykliken dann verfasst worden oder die in dieser Richtung argumentieren, gilt, dass es also nicht darum ging, tatsächlich eine Alternative zum Kapitalismus aufzumachen, sondern die Frage war, wie hegt man ihn ein? Auch die Ideen der sozialen Marktwirtschaft nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg sind natürlich geprägt, auch von dieser katholischen Soziallehre, die in Deutschland ja auch dann an Universitäten präsent ist, wo Priester ausgebildet werden, wo aber auch eine ganz direkte Verbindung da ist, zum Beispiel zur CDU, CSU, zum Teil aber auch zur SPD, also das ist ja auch nicht ganz frei von Katholizismus. Also das ist eine Ausprägung, die man so verstehen muss. Also es ging nicht darum, auch wenn man von Papst Franziskus immer mal wieder sehr harsche Kapitalismuskritik gehört hat, es ging nicht darum, den Kapitalismus zu überwinden. Also es ging zum Beispiel auch nie darum, Eigentumsrechte grundsätzlich in Frage zu stellen oder so. Das ist ein Thema, das bei der Befreiungstheologie...
Nicht nur nicht in Frage zu stellen, sondern zu schützen.
Zu schützen, ja. Wir müssen uns noch extremer... Genau, es geht also ganz klar darum, auch nicht eine starke Arbeiterpartei plötzlich als Konkurrenten zu haben. Plus ja, die Internationale ist ja schon ihrem Text nach atheistisch. Ja, wir haben ja da diese, es rettet uns kein höheres Wesen, kein Gott, kein Kaiser noch Tribun. Uns aus dem Elend zu erlösen, können wir nur selber tun. Das heißt, das ist das, wovor die katholische Kirche Angst hat und wogegen sich dann auch diese Enzyklika richtet. Die Befreiungstheologie dann nochmal, die ja von in den 70er Jahren dann auch sehr stark ist, die geht natürlich nochmal sehr viel weiter und ist in ihrer Kapitalismuskritik und kann sich durchaus mit dem Sozialismus anfreunden. Das ist aber nicht die Sache von Leo oder Franziskus.
Die Befreiungstheologie kommt ja auch aus einer anderen Weltregion. Das ist ja Südamerika. Da sind wir also bei dem Franziskus, also nicht bei dem Franziskaner, sondern wirklich bei Franziskus.
Aber er ist auch da ein Moderator.
Sehr moderat, aber der neue Papst kommt ja auch aus Peru. Er ist ja auch Eroana. Das können wir gleich noch mal eine kleine Pointe stricken. Die Sozialen Zyklika ist also auf zwei Päpste gefolgt. Zwei Pontifikate, die vor allem, wie die Konrad-Adeno-Stiftung sagt, einen antimodernistischen und antiliberalen Kurs gefahren sind. Also es war, auch wenn wir das heute einschränken, sehr revolutionär. Und wenn man es auf den materiellen Punkt bringt, dann kann man ja mal raushören, wie wirkmächtig sie eigentlich war. Also wenn die Kirche etwas sagt, ist es nicht unbedeutend, denn damals hat die Vatikan gesagt, okay, wir brauchen eine Aufgabenaufteilung zwischen Kirche, Staat und der Arbeiterschaft selbst. Das Kapital wurde ausgeklammert, so wie heute ja auch. Das ist frei. Die Kirche hat Caritas übernommen, das ist heute Standard. Der Staat kümmert sich um Gemeinwohl, also Demokratie, die Mehrheit und so weiter. März lässt da grüßen. Plus das Vertragswesen, also das BGB regelt, wie weit Mietverträge und so weiter und sonst niemand. Das ist der Staat. Und die Arbeiterschaft, ja, die kann ja mal ein bisschen selbst gucken. Es gab große Familienförderung. In der Enzyklika steht wohl der Satz drin. Sie, also die Familie, ist älter als jegliches andere Gemeinwesen und deshalb besitzt sie unabhängig vom Staat ihre Inwohnen den Rechte und Pflichten. Hätte ich mich da mal eher eingelesen, hätte das natürlich noch eine tolle Pointe im Familienbuch gegeben, welche Finger die Kirche da mit im Spiel hatte. Naja, jetzt haben wir jedenfalls die Situation, dass der Vatikan plötzlich sich selber schon öffentlich beauftragt hat, über den neuen Papst sowohl, also vor allem bei den vor den Kardinälen, aber auch vor der Presse hat das angedeutet, zu sagen, ich sehe hier für mich wieder ein Betätigungsfeld. Leo 13, Leo 14, diese Tradition, die du schon rausgestellt hast, die ist wirklich wichtig. Und jetzt gibt es eine wichtige Person im Vatikan, nämlich Paolo Benanti. Das ist ein Franziskanermönch und Professor. Er ist Berater sowohl des Vatikans als auch derzeit von Meloni, also der italienischen Regierung in Sachen Ethik und künstliche Intelligenz. Und er selbst zeigt sich im Gespräch, die New York Times hatten ihn nochmal gesprochen, nachdem sie ihn schon vorher, letztes Jahr gesprochen haben, überrascht von den mutigen Prioritätssetzungen des Papstes, aber auch nicht allzu überrascht, denn der neue Papst hat einen Abschluss in Mathematik, er kennt sich aus. Und er wurde damals im September 2024 schon eingeladen, also als er noch Kardinal war mit Benanti schon mal, weil es gibt ja da wohl drängende Themen und so. Also die beiden kennen sich auch schon. Und dann noch mal diese Verweis auch von Benanti auf, ja, ja, Leo da 13, und es ist alle Enzyklika und Zäsuren und Industrie und so. Alles ganz wichtig. Und ich will noch mal auf einen Text zurückblicken, in dem im Februar 2024, also als noch nicht absehbar war, wie sehr ein Papst überhaupt zu diesem Thema sich mal äußert, Benanti hier schon besucht wurde als der große Ethiker des Vatikans und der Regierung. Mit vielen Büchern und in diesem Text, das ist wirklich super witzig auch, es gab ein Erweckungserlebnis für den Vatikan beim Thema KI. Jetzt können wir alle kurz überlegen, was soll denn das gewesen sein? Ah, Papst Franziskus in einer weißen Downenjacke.
Ja, ganz richtig.
Und da war der Vatikan plötzlich, weil die Leute haben das geglaubt. Weltenweit haben die Leute geglaubt, dass das der Papst ist. Und das hat den Vatikan umgetrieben.
Man hat ein Foto generiert von Papst Franziskus und das sah so echt aus, dass man dachte, der trägt eine solche Downenjacke.
Was eben dazu führte, dass Papst Franziskus sich selbst...
Benanti war übrigens ja schon in mehreren KI-Podcasts zu Gast. Das ist schon jemand, der seit einigen Jahren immer mal wieder auftauchte.
Genau. Also das scheint mir auch der Go-To-Guide zu sein, mit dem man da reden muss. Franziskus selbst hat dann schon immer mal wieder auch KI und so, die Durchschaubarbarkeit von Algorithmen kritisiert öffentlich, denn sie gewähren Asyl, gewähren Hypotheken und entscheiden, wer auf dem Schlachtfeld lebt oder stirbt. Also das war schon vor dem Leo jetzt beim Franziskus. Außerdem wird nicht nur eine Umkrempelung der Berufsfelder erwartet, sondern auch eine Flut der Verzweiflung. Also wir sind hier noch im Franziskus-Zeitalter 2024. Da war das alles schon so Thema. Italien ist als älteste und sehr schnell schrumpfende Bevölkerung der Welt, sehr von KI und Produktivität abhängig. Italien ist ein krasses Auswanderungsland. Deutschlandfunk hat gottselig wieder ein Bitt dazu gemacht. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Die haben da ihren italienischen für Brain Drain. Das ist großes, großes Thema dort. Und man stellte sich damals schon die Frage oder hier ich lese mal vor. Und die ganze Zeit wendet er seine Perspektive darauf an, was es bedeutet, lebendig und menschlich zu sein, wenn Maschinen lebendiger und menschlicher erscheinen. Das ist eine spirituelle Frage für den Vatikan. Er selbst, Benanti, ist nur so ein biografisches Snippet, aber der hatte 1999 so eine kleine Lebenskrise und seine Freundin dachte, ach komm, du brauchst doch hier was Sakrales in deinem Leben oder so. Also sind sie in so eine Franziskaner-Kirche gefahren und dann ist er einfach dort geblieben, hat sich dem verschrieben und hat dann auch seine Freundin verlassen. Also er hat sich komplett irgendwie...
Ach, spätberufen, naja.
Jaja, hat sich da... ja, der war erst schon Techniker. Also der war richtig so ein Techie und so und ist dann Franziskaner, in so einem Franziskaner-Orden beigetreten. Und der sagt nun Folgendes. Peter Menanti glaubt, dass KI-Unternehmen haftbar gemacht werden sollten, wenn sie urrechtlich geschützte Quellen verwenden, um ihre Chatspots zu trainieren, obwohl er befürchtet, also soweit so gut, dass dies schwer zu beweisen ist, weil die Unternehmen Blackboxes sind. Ist ja eine Frage. Meint der nur die Unternehmen oder auch die Modelle selbst? Weil wir wissen ja, das Mysterium steckt dann da irgendwo. Und zu dieser Frage Blackboxes und wie geht man damit um, steht hier in diesem letzten Absatz. Aber dieses Geheimnis, was in diesen Modellen stattfindet, hat für Pater Benanti der Technologie auch wieder Zauber verliehen, auch wenn er es die dunkle Art nennt, also der dunkle Zauber der Maschine. In diesem Sinne war es nicht neu, sagt er und argumentierte, dass so wie antike römische Auguren, und wir wissen, antike römische Auguren, das war weit vor jeder sozusagen Strukturierung von Religiosität, da ist man einfach auf Geistersuche gegangen und so, ja, so ungefähr, muss man es vorstellen, dass so wie antike römische Auguren sich an den Flug der Vögel wandten, um Richtung zu erhalten, könnte KI mit ihrem enormen Verständnis unserer physischen, emotionalen und preferenziellen Daten, also unsere Vorlieben ganz konkret, die neuen Orakel sein, die Entscheidung bestimmen und Gott durch falsche Götzen ersetzen. Es ist etwas Altes, von dem wir wahrscheinlich denken, Zitat von ihm, dass wir es hinter uns gelassen haben, sagt der Mönch, aber jetzt kommt es zurück. Also wir haben jetzt so eine Vergötzung der Welt. Leute strömen in die KI-Systeme, weil sie sonst keine Antworten mehr finden, aber so viel Wüstig, Zweifel und Glaube bedient werden muss. Und da finde ich jetzt super interessant, wie...
Das heißt ja, wir sind in einer Situation, in der die KI Antworten gibt auf Fragen, die man immer hatte, die aber eine Zeit lang nicht beantwortet wurden oder unzureichen, nicht befriedigend beantwortet wurden.
Durch Bücher oder so, weil man wusste, nee, das geht hier nicht um mich, das ist irgendwie so.
Und wir haben zugleich diese mysteriöse Komponente schon deshalb drin, weil wir gar nicht wissen, wie genau sind sie programmiert, was ist dort präferiert, warum werde ich in diese oder jene Richtung gelotst. Das ist also etwas, was mir ungewiss bleibt, während natürlich die christliche Theologie immer wieder zwar von dem Mysterium spricht, aber ja doch die Leitlinien, wie zu leben ist, woran sich zu orientieren, es ganz klar macht. Also da ist es ja nicht so, wenn man in den Beichtstuhl geht, dass man dann im Orakel gegenüber sitzt und man wird schon ganz gespannt sein, wird er diesmal sagen, Diebstahl ist erlaubt oder nicht, sondern man weiß es schon, man bekommt dann nur noch mal ganz konkret gesagt, was zu tun ist, wie kann man Buße tun oder so etwas. Aber es gibt ja ein Regelwerk, das transparent ist, wie auch das BGB transparent ist. Kann man noch mal nachgucken, wie ist dann mein Recht als Konsument oder so. Und das kommt also jetzt durch die KI-Appanten, da wir nicht mehr genau das nachvollziehen können. Zugleich ist aber die Einfachheit so bestechend, dass wir einfach eine Antwort geliefert bekommen, die wir dann als leitend sehen. Irgendwas muss ja schon dran sein, es ist ja zumindest mit vielem gefüttert und es kommt auch rhetorisch, geschickt formuliert daher. Also was kann so ganz falsch sein. Und selbst wenn es nicht 100 Prozent von uns geglaubt wird, es reicht ja auch für die Ideologie. Das ist ja mal das Sijek-Argument. Ideologie funktioniert auch, wenn man nicht ganz dran glaubt. Das ist ja das berühmte Beispiel da mit Nils Bohr und dem Hufeisen. Das hat er über der Tür und dann ist ein junger Assistent, der fragt Nils Bohr, aber Sie sind doch Wissenschaftler, warum haben Sie da ein Hufeisen? Ja, ich hab das, um die bösen Kräfte abzuhalten. Aber Sie sind doch Wissenschaftler. Ja, man hat mir gesagt, das würde aber auch wirken, wenn man nicht dran glaubt. Und dies ist natürlich diese Konstellation, dass man sagt, naja, am Ende ist es irgendwie eine KI, haben die da von Google oder sonst wem erschaffen? Aber diese Idee, dass ich doch irgendwas an meinem Kind tun sollte, weil das eigentlich nicht dem Schönheitsideal entspricht, glaube ich vielleicht doch mal ein bisschen.
Genau, und das ist ja dieser große Unterschied, weshalb Benanti da auch von Götzen und nicht von Göttern spricht. Denn der Gott selbst ist ja eine Idee, der man sich annähert. Und die Suche zum Gott ist der Grund für Religion. Während wir bei KIs gar keinen Weg mehr zurücklegen, sondern sofort die Antwort bekommen. Und zwar mit so einer falschen Gewissheit untergejubelt, wie aus der Richtung dann kritisiert werden würde. Ist jetzt nicht so schlimm, wenn man wirklich nur einen Taschenrechner vor sich hat und zwei plus zwei rechnet, dann kann man sehr gewiss sein, das ist vier. Aber wenn man eine KI zum Thema Deutschunterricht irgendwas fragt, zu einem Text, erörtern hier, analysieren da, dann wird es ja schon schwierig. Dann wäre es schon gut, wenn man den Weg selbst und sei es feierlich begeht, statt sich einfach, ah ja gut, Shortcut, GPT wird es schon regeln. So, und jetzt haben wir da also sozusagen diese Einflugsschneise für alles, was wir bisher besprochen haben. Und diese kleine Poarte will ich noch machen. Thomas Luckmann hat ein Buch geschrieben, The Invisible Religion, die unsichtbare Religion. Das handelt also davon, dass wir zwar eine säkulare Gesellschaft haben, das Religiöse aber nicht verloren ging, sondern es nur so spezifisch weggedrängt wurde. Aber nicht in Nischen, sondern ganz präsent, sagen jedenfalls die Befreiungstheologen. Die also vor allem Gustavo Gutieres aus Peru, wo der Leo lange aufhielt, der also sagt, ja ja, die Religion wurde schon so versteckt, oder Menschen leben religiös, aber nehmen es nicht so wahr. Und zwar vor allem, wenn es darum geht, dass sie sich anders als nach den Orden regeln, am Kapitalismus, Nationalismus und Technokratie orientieren.
Ja.
So, es ist also die Religion wahnsinnig präsent, nur wir erkennen sie einfach nicht an. Sondern sagen, nee, wir Deutsche grenzen sofort zu, es sagt doch auch die Mehrheit, so ja. Das ist aus dieser Richtung ein hochgradig religiöses, aber halt Götzenantlitz, den man da nacheifert. Also der Begriff Götze als Volgärbegriff für falscher Gott wird von diesen Befreiungstheologen ganz konkret auf Kapitalismus, Nationalismus, Technokratie und so weiter angewendet.
Sich opfern, also das letzte Menschenopfer des Christentums ist ja Jesus Christus am Kreuze. Also sich zu opfern bedeutet dann sein Leben, Gott zu weihen, bedeutet ins Kloster einzutreten, bedeutet zu verzichten, bedeutet was auch immer du jetzt eben bei den Ordensregeln vorgestellt hast. Jetzt haben wir ja eben schon bei dieser Wehrpflichtsdebatte gehört, bitte opfert euch für euer Land. Seid bereit dafür auch zu sterben oder dem Land Kinder zu schenken. Ja, das sind ja eigentlich immer Kinder Gottes, aber jetzt werden sie plötzlich zu Kindern des Staates. Damit hat dann die Befreiungstheologie ebenso recht wie Karl Schmitt, da sagt er, die politischen Begriffe sind im Prinzip säkularisierte theologische Begriffe. Das heißt also, das migriert in die Sphäre des Staates, wie du das jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, der Nation. Es ist aber da als solches präsent und wird dann auch mit einer solchen Vehemenz oder man könnte fast sagen mit religiösem Eifer verfochten. Also es ist ja interessant, dass die Argumentation zum Beispiel gegen jemanden wie Ole, der sagte, ich will aber nicht von meinem Land kämpfen, wirklich mit einem missionarischen Eifer, wie kannst du nur und so bist du etwa vom Wege abgekommen, wie man eigentlich in einem religiösen Diskurs ist, genau.
Diese Befreiungstheologen, die ja finde ich auch ein sehr sympathisches Programm vorgelegt haben, das wahrscheinlich bei Leo auch nochmal keine Ahnung ist.
Da hätte ich auch Lust, mich mehr mit zu beschäftigen, ehrlich gesagt.
Allerdings nur der kurze Hinweis, der Vatikan war damals im großen Konflikt mit diesen Befreiungstheologen. Denn die Glaubenskongregation, die darüber Aufsicht hatte, hat natürlich Josef Ratzinger geführt.
Genau, der war da aber gar kein Vatikan.
Der hat gesagt, also diese Verwendung der marxistischen Kategorien, das geht ja gar nicht. Ich erliege euch erstmal mit Lehrverbot.
So.
Jetzt ist ja die Frage...
Es gibt, also nicht so berühmte, aber ich habe auch schon zum Beispiel mal jemanden getroffen, der marxistischer Katholik ist, aus der Befreiungstheologie so ein bisschen kommt und so. Das sind eigentlich die interessantesten. Also mit denen kann man sich ganz toll unterhalten. Genau.
Das sind diese, also vor allem Peru und so in der Gegend, haben die sich da bereit gemacht, jetzt seit 50, 60 Jahren. So. Wir haben also jetzt ein großes Angebot der Kirche, über Sachen nachzudenken. Und wir haben das Angebot der KI, ganz schnell immer Antworten zu kriegen. Wir haben den Unterschied jetzt markiert. Und ich will nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass die KI jetzt die ganze Zeit promotet wird mit, das ersetzt deine Freunde. Du hast ja eh keine, mach mal hier KI-Companion. Und die Kirche eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur Zusammenleben regelt. Und wie ich finde, Gott ein bisschen überbetonend, aber ihn zumindest immer so dunstet es irgendwo einfach verortet, sodass man ausreichend Zeit hat, sich mit den Sachen der Kirche immer mitgemeinschaften. Also es sind im Grunde Soziologen. So, sagen wir mal, wie es ist. So, Scott Galloway betont das jetzt auch nochmal. Diesen großen, großen, großen, nicht zu unterschätzenden, diese Zäsur einfach, die kommt, da wird das jetzt die erste jugendliche Generation aufwächst, die einfach überall so ein scheiß KI-Chatbot drin hat. Bei Snapchat, bei Meta, bei WhatsApp, überall sind diese KI-Bots. Immer als Angebot, hier findest du auch Antworten und so. Und ich finde, er beschreibt es nochmal ganz gut, um was es da eigentlich geht, dieses Gemeinschaftliche, und dass es da auch keine Shortcuts gibt, also hier aus dem Pivot Podcast.
Und ich habe gesagt, dass ich denke, dass ich, wenn ich Freunde habe, wenn ich durch die Schleifordnung gehe, die Verwundung von Freundschaften, wenn ich finde, wie hart es ist, die korporate Welt nicht zu navigieren, ich denke, das kann dich in eine bessere Person, besonders eine bessere Mannin, die diese Jungs sehr früh nicht wachsen. Und auch das Feuer, das echte Feuer des sexuellen Desirens. Ich denke, wenn es richtig genutzt wird, macht es dich stärker, kindlicher, zeigst du Exzellenz, hast du einen Plan. Du weißt, es gibt eine Grundlage, ich habe das vorhin gesagt, es gibt eine Grundlage, warum Romantik-Kommunismus zwei Stunden, nicht 15 Minuten ist, und dass dieses Scheiß hart ist, aber es wert ist. Und alles, was noch mehr jungen Männer überzeugt, dass sie nicht durch den schwierigen, beherrschenden und wertvollen Effort gehen, um Menschen mit anderen sentienten Menschen zu verbinden, ist eine Gefahr an unserer Gesellschaft.
Ich würde das auch sagen.
Aber wenn sie es tun, müssen sie es sicher machen.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Aber meine Frage ist, wenn es eine Sache ist, die den älteren Zusammenhänden zu geben, die in ihren 90ern sind und alle ihren Liebsten verloren haben...
Ich würde gerne eine für meine Mutter haben, ich werde ehrlich sein mit ihm.
Aber sollten wir sie vielleicht aus dem Schmuck ausfüllen? Ich weiß nicht, sollten wir AI-Sexrobots haben, die alle Männer konvizieren, um zu denken, oh ich brauche nicht zu sein, kinder Frauen zu sein, ich brauche nicht einen Plan.
Sie werden sie machen Scott, ob Sie es mögen oder nicht, sie werden sie machen.
Also hört man schon, Caris Wischer, stellvertretend für die ganze Menschheit, versteht nicht gerade, worüber ihr redet und in welcher tiefen Schärfe er das meint. Aber wenn der Vatikan sich da schon so aufstellt und der Menanti ist klug, der wird das so sehen wie wir, dass wir hier ein neues Gemeinschaftsangebot der Kirche brauchen gegen KIs, weil KIs die Menschen wirklich auseinander treiben. Da sitzt jeder noch vor seiner eigenen Chatbot und man präsentiert sich so Resultate und es findet gar nichts mehr statt. Und jedes Mal, wenn irgendeine Konferenz so in Wallung kommt und da echte Gespräche stattfinden, kommt irgendwer und sagt, ich habe eine KI Antwort und möchte da befrieden und so. Und das ist natürlich voll der Irrweg. Also in deren Sicht, ich finde, diese Konstellation, dass wir hier ausgerechnet jetzt einen neuen Papst haben, der sich da so positioniert und wir diesen riesigen Bedarf haben, das ist nicht schlecht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich denke auch. Kommen wir zu einem Thema, das vielleicht doch dem sehr ähnlich ist, nämlich was passiert eigentlich in den Jugendzimmern? Wie werden junge Menschen sozialisiert? Wir werden jetzt über ein Phänomen sprechen, von dem vielleicht viele noch gar nicht gehört haben. Und auch als ich dir den Begriff nannte, musst du erst mal fragen, was ist denn das? Ich habe dir dann Clips geschickt. Wir sprechen jetzt über Ostmullen.
Wer weiß wirklich, was das ist?
Wahrscheinlich nur ganz wenige. Ich wusste es nicht. Also Ostmullen, da steckt einmal das Wort Osten drin. Es geht also um den Osten Deutschlands. Und mit Mulle ist ein eigentlich aus dem Ruhrpott stammender, eher abschätziger Begriff gemeint für Frauen bzw. ja, das bezieht sich auf gewisse Säugetiere, die so eher in der Erde versteckt leben. Aber in dieser Kombination Ostmulle, also sich so zu bezeichnen, ich bin da so von da ganz unten irgendwo, wird dieser Begriff sich jetzt angeeignet von Frauen, die sagen, ja, ich stehe dazu, Ostmulle zu sein. Und Ostmulle zu sein, bedeutet dann, ich stamme aus dem Osten, ich präsentiere mich so, spiele auch oder affiniere diese Klischees, wie sehr das Bewusste oder Unbewusstes ist, ist nicht klar, weil diese Frauen sich nicht dazu jetzt auf einer Metaebene äußern, sondern einfach Videos von sich drehen, in denen sie zu rechtsradikaler Musik mit AfD-Logo oder Deutschlandflagge oder Reichsbürgerflagge oder anderen Symbolen im Hintergrund Lipsync machen. Diese Videos sind dann bei TikTok, Instagram oder werden dann auch bei Twitter gezeigt. Und daraus hat sich dann ergeben, das hat dann auch ein Twitter-User wohl ins Leben gerufen, der Ostmullen-Dienstag, also dass unter diesem Hashtag dann immer besonders viele Videos erscheinen. Das ist noch ein relativ kleines Phänomen, das aber jetzt schon die Neue Rechte in verschiedener Weise beschäftigt. Wir können jetzt hier nichts von den Ostmullen direkt vorspielen, weil es einfach nur Videos sind. Man kann das immer googeln, man kann es aber auch lassen. Wir würden jetzt mal ohne Ton was abspielen, denn wir wollen jetzt nicht am Ende von der GEMA Ärger bekommen und dann noch rechtsradikalen Bands zu den Themen zahlen. Und wir beschreiben mal so ein bisschen, was man dann sieht. Also da ist jetzt eine junge Frau, die direkt ein Selfie hält in die Kamera, und dort dann einen Song lipsyncht, der rechtsradikal ist. Wir sehen Frauen mit sehr langen Fingernägeln, sehr stark blondiert oder anders gefärbt. Tätowierungen spielen oft eine große Rolle. Es werden Filter eingesetzt, die das Gesicht sehr generisch gestalten. Sie zeigen sich also, posieren vor der Kamera. Ich bin stolz, ein Deutscher zu sein. Eine Deutsche zu sein, hat sie auf ihrem Smartphone stehen, einen Aufkleber. Hier jemand dann anschließend im...
Alice Weidel Fan-T-Shirt.
Alice Weidel Fan-T-Shirt mit einer AfD-Klappe. Und ein Pappaufsteller im Kinderzimmer. Man sieht also, dass wir es hier mit jungen Frauen zu tun haben, Alter schwer zu schätzen. Ich würde sagen, irgendwas zwischen 15 und 25. Die entsprechende Videos dann hochladen und auch sonst keinen Kontext dazu liefern. Wir können noch dieses zweite Video kurz anschauen. Da gibt es mal ein Text dazu. Und zwar wird da eine Musik eingeblendet und die heißt Antifa, ihr könnt mich mal, ich lache über euch und ihr magt es nicht mal, ihr kämpft gegen mich. Wie lächerlich, also das scheint irgendeine Rechtsband zu sein. Und da sehen wir eine junge blonde Frau, ich nehme mal an, vielleicht 18 Jahre alt höchstens, mit Deutschlandfahne im Hintergrund.
Ist das in Deutschland? Ah ja, nee das ist ja Hammer und Sichel.
Ach Hammer und Sichel auch noch dabei. Also die jedenfalls zu dieser rechtsradikalen Musik dann so ein kurzes TikTok-Video machen. Und man findet jetzt 1000 weitere. Dazu, was ist das jetzt also für ein merkwürdiges Phänomen? Wie soll ich da jetzt anfangen? Ich habe gestern mit einem Freund telefoniert, der im Osten lebt und der auf Tinder ist. Und der ist 23 und habe ihm von dem Phänomen erzählt. Und dann sagte er ja, ihm sei das aufgefallen bei Tinder. Bei Tinder findet er immer mehr Profile angezeigt von Frauen. Da steht dann gleich schon die Deutschland-Flagge. Ich bin stolz und so Sachen. Da steht auch, wenn du links bist, Swipe nach links. Also dann kannst du mich vergessen, wenn du rechts bist, Swipe nach rechts. Also diese Bekenntnisse quasi, ich bin hier antilinks. Ich bin bin bin deutsch, national, Reichsbürgerin, AfD. Ich bin nicht Vogue. Also diese ganzen Dinge sagt er vermehrt bei also Frauen 18 bis 25, 18 bis 30 vermehrt in diesen Profilen. Das heißt also diese diese Kultur, von der wir jetzt das sprechen oder diese Ästhetik, ist also sicherlich noch eine, die jetzt nicht so dominant im Osten über alles. Aber man sieht offenbar ein positives Bekenntnis zum Rechtsradikalismus, dass soweit geht, dass man es auch gleich im Dating-Profil klar macht. Ich will hier einen Deutschen haben, der auch so denkt wie ich. Das ist die Situation. Also sehr sehr drastisch, wenn man sich das ansieht. Nun wie gesagt, diese Frauen, die sich da zeigen und die jetzt auch dann im Netz viel geklickt werden und kommentiert werden und so weiter, die äußern sich aber nicht. Sicher, zumindest habe ich nichts dazu gefunden. Was es aber natürlich gibt, sind rechte Podcasts, die dann darüber reden. Ein rechter Podcast ist der Podcast Krautzone und dort unterhalten sich dann zwei Männer über dieses Phänomen. Und ich sage jetzt hier gleich, alles was wir da jetzt so von den Männern hören, ist oft sehr abwertend gegenüber diesen Frauen. Also dass die rechte ein Frauenproblem hat, wundert alles nicht. Aber ich glaube, es ist ganz gut, sich diese Podcast jetzt mal anzuhören, um einen Eindruck davon zu bekommen, wie die das einordnen, weil die natürlich sich die Frage stellen, kann ich da, also mit diesem Lifestyle, der dort vertreten wird, vielleicht mit dem rechten Projekt weiterkommen. Denn wir wissen ja viele Leute, du betont das ja gerne, wählen motivlos, beziehungsweise könnte man sagen, ja einfach aus so einem Lifestyle heraus so etwas gemacht. Und nicht, weil sie jetzt fest verankert sind in der rechten Ideologie, sondern auch weil das hier, und Ostmulle ist ja so eine Resignifizierung eines eigentlich abwertenden Begriffs, schon dieser Versuch zu sagen, ihr findet mich alle scheiße, ihr glaubt ich sei so eine Tussi aus dem Osten. Ja, ich bin so eine und ich bin stolz darauf.
Das Phänomen hat man ja immer wieder auch in der Schulenbewegung.
Ja, Resignifizierung.
Zu Beginn erkläre ich erstmal den bürgerlichen Zuhörern, was eine Ostmulle ist.
Ja, also eine Ostmulle ist eine Frau, die vom Alter her erstreckt sich das eigentlich von 15, 16, 17 bis hin zu Ende 40, Ende 50. Das ist gar nicht genau gefasst. Dieses Phänomen selber...
Nach oben keine Grenzen.
Das Phänomen selber ist ein vor allem ein Netzphänomen. Und zwar stellen seit einiger Zeit Ostmullen, also Frauen aus Ostdeutschland, auf Plattformen wie TikTok Videos von sich hoch, wo sie dann zum Klang irgendwelcher Bands Lipsync machen. Also sie synchronisieren scheinbar diesen Gesang, singen das sozusagen nach. Und das ist jetzt erst mal nichts Besonderes, ja, so Lieder zu covern oder so. Das Besondere ist, dass Ostmullen häufig echte oder scheinbar echte Rechtsrock-Bands synchronisieren und das dann auch gerne vor dem Hintergrund von Deutschland fahren oder auch Reichsfahnen.
Wie war dein Eindruck? Du hast ja so ein paar Videos angesehen von dem, was du da gesehen hast.
Es ist dieses Unterschichten Loser-Internet irgendwie.
Interessant, dass du das direkt jetzt so fremst, denn das ist ähnlich wie das Ellen Kossitsa von Kubitschek, die Frau, ähnlich so einschätzt. Und das ist ja auch von denen bewusst so gesetzt. Also das ist ja, wer sich da also ins Netz stellt, gehört definitiv nicht auch zu einer neu rechten Elite, sondern das sind die, die jetzt sagen, mich stört das irgendwie alles hier in Deutschland und ich will damit gar nichts zu tun haben, wie die Institutionen und so funktionieren. Ich bin Anti und bin aus einer prekären Situation heraus, filme ich mich da.
Also für mich ist das so eine Art Local Hero Phänomen, wie man nutzt das große Internet, um eigentlich nur so ein paar wenige Leute damit zu beeindrucken. Wir haben ja so einen Diskurs über gewaltsame junge Männer im Osten, bei denen schon die älteren Rechtsradikalen oder Aussteiger oder ehemalige, wie auch immer, schon gar nicht mehr wiedererkennen, was also ein ganz neues Phänomen, nicht so ein Nachzügler, sondern so neu begründetes im Internet radikalisiert. Und so ist das bei den Frauen wahrscheinlich auch. Die leben sehr online und schaffen jetzt so ihre eigene Ästhetik. Und wir wissen aber aus vielen Bereichen, dass man mit so ein paar Followern, die man hat, schon lokal einen ganz schönen Eindruck machen kann. Also die spielen sich da schon hoch, würde ich sagen, so in ihrem Metier.
Und man versteckt sich ja nicht mit dem Rechtsein, sondern man sagt, das ist das, was ich jetzt zur Schau stelle. Weiter sagen diese Herren da von Krautzone?
Und als ich das erstmal gesehen habe, fand ich das echt richtig, richtig witzig, muss ich sagen. Also mir hat das erstmal gut gefallen. Ich habe da auch, ich vermute mal, ohne dir Worte in den Mund zu legen, im Gegensatz zu dir, keinerlei Abneigung oder Aversion gegen, die Unterhaltung gefällt mir.
Die Unterhaltung gefällt ihm. Auch Martin Sellner spricht da von den gut gelaunten Frauen, die sich in der Kamera präsentieren. Das wird auch anders gesehen. Also Ellen Kositzer, die rechte Denkerin aus Schnellroder, hat also einen großen Text geschrieben bei ihrer rechten Zeitschrift. Sezessionen reißen die Ostmullen die Brandmauer ein. Und da setzt sie sich dann auch damit auseinander, wie jetzt diese Ostmullen wirken. Und sie sagt, naja, das seien ja vor allem sehr Verzweifelte und sehr Perspektivlose, die sich da zeigen. Jetzt wird sehr viel darüber nachgedacht, wie ist das einzuordnen, hat das einen politischen Ausschlag. Und jemand wie Martin Sellner, also der Kopf der Identitären Bewegung, der hat ja so eine oberflächliche Gramsci-Lektüre hinter sich und sieht ja überall immer die neue Hegemonie, die man kulturell aufbaut. Und der sieht natürlich hier beim Ostmullen-Dienstag, wie er auf Twitter schreibt, einen metapolitischen Erfolg.
Also, ich glaube, der Sellner weiß ganz genau, wie das ist, wenn junge Männer Internet benutzen und dass solche Frauen, die natürlich schon als junge Frauen Zugpferde sind, Zugpferde für seine Bewegung sind.
Ja, ja, genau.
Oder für seine Denkrichtung. Das ist nur dieses einzige Sache. Also, dass das über einfache Instinkte läuft und so. Ja. Und man das jetzt nicht so überideologisieren muss.
Ja, also er spricht dann auch von der Attraktivität der Frauen und wie wichtig das ist, dass sie dann jetzt stattfinden. Er glaubt, dass sich mehr anschließen werden und das werde dann zu einem metapolitischen Perpetuum mobile und und und. Ähnlich geht das auch hier. Es ist vor allem gegen links. Und das ist ja genau das, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, was ist eigentlich Konservatismus. Wissen wir nicht, aber es geht gegen links und so hier dann auch.
Also, ich würde nicht so weit gehen sagen, dass es reine Unterhaltung ist, weil in dem Moment, wo es halt politisch ist, es ist Provokation und dadurch hat es auch automatisch eine Stoßrichtung und die Richtung ist halt eben auch in unserer Richtung. Und zwar wollen wir jetzt nicht unter der Reichsflagge tanzen, aber wir haben ja ein Problem mit linker Meinungshegomonie und mit linken Dogmen und gedanklichen und sprachlichen Zwängen. Und die werden ja durch diese Ostmulbewegung ja quasi pulverisiert. Also, es ist ja nicht irgendwie jemand, der sagt, ja, ich habe ein Problem mit der Meinungsfreiheit, ich würde gerne besser meine Meinung sagen können, sondern das sind einfach hunderte, wenn nicht tausend junger Frauen, die einfach aus dem Nichts somit das Rechteste machen, was man in Deutschland machen kann, ohne halt strafrechtlich verfolgt zu werden.
Finden sie gut? Selna schreibt bei Twitter, natürlich ist vieles von dem, was die Damen darstellen, nicht unser gesellschaftliches Ideal oder neu rechte Ideologie. Hier geht es aber auch nicht um Gesimpe oder blindes Abfeiern, sondern um die Analyse eines bisher ziemlich einmaligen Phänomens. Also wenn es wahrscheinlich auch erst mal Frauen gibt, die jetzt da mitmachen bei den Rechten. Mich wundert es nicht so sehr, da die ja natürlich in diesen oft ländlichen Gegenden sozialisiert sind. Die Perspektivlosigkeit ist groß und dann sind dann irgendwelche Typen, die ein bisschen mit den Identitären oder dem Dritten Weg oder sonst wem zu tun haben. Und der sieht aber auch irgendwie ganz süß aus. Das könnte mein künftiger Freund sein. Ach so, die wollen irgendwie, dass ich auch in eine Deutschlandfahne aufhänge, mache ich das auch. Also es scheint so eine Geschichte zu sein, dass das einfach die normale Sozialisation von jungen Menschen jetzt in Landstrichen ist, die einfach völlig vernachlässigt sind. Also das ist ja sagen wir auch etwas für diejenigen, die nicht davongekommen sind, die da geblieben sind oder da bleiben mussten.
Typischerweise sind ja solche Frauen eigentlich immer davongekommen. Also die Auswanderungswellen wurden ja vor allem von den Frauen angeführt.
Aber auch interessant, besagter Freund, mit dem ich gestern sprach, sagte dann, da sind also diese jungen Frauen bei Tinder mit den Deutschland-Fahren und dem Ich Bin Stolz und und und. Und dann kann man durch die Bilder durchzweipen. Diesen jungen 18, 19 sagte er dann häufig, die mehrere Bilder da haben. Und auf dem letzten Bild zeigen sich dann mit Kind. Das heißt, sie sind sehr früh Mutter geworden und dann aber auch alleinerziehend und haben aber jetzt so irgendwie so ein so ein Patriotismus sich über das Internet wahrscheinlich antrainiert oder so ein bisschen aus der aus der Umgebung gespeist. Wir hören mal weiter an, was diese Krauzonenleute dazu sagen.
Ich würde an der Stelle erstmal meinerseits klarstellen, dass ich dieses Phänomen auch extrem witzig finde und dem auch einen extrem hohen Unterhaltungswert zuspreche und jetzt auch nicht störenrunzle und das irgendwie abtue. Also ich habe immer irgendwo ein großes Interesse für diese für diese Netzkultur, vor allem wenn die so spontan und graswurzlig und scheinbar ungesteuert entsteht. Also mich fasziniert das und das auch in wirklich anderen Kontexten. Und das ist ja das, was ich gerne sage, dass wenn Deutschland noch eines kann, dann ist es Meme.
Ich würde sagen, wenn die Rechten noch irgendwas können, dann ist es Meme.
Das ist die einzige Kultur, die sie haben.
Und es ist natürlich wieder das Typische, wir wissen, wie Facebook angefangen hat, also wie Mark Zuckerberg angefangen hat. Er hat ein Portal gemacht mit Bildern von Studentinnen, die man bewerten konnte. Hot or not. Das war eigentlich das Prinzip. Und nach diesem Prinzip funktioniert ja der Algorithmus heute immer noch bei vielen Plattformen. Und das ist ja was, was jetzt die rechten Männer sowieso gerne machen. Und deswegen wird auch in diesen Podcasts, in denen sich mit Ostenmuld auseinandergesetzt wird, laufend über das Aussehen gesprochen.
Spektrum der Ostenmuld ist halt relativ breit, weil du hast halt schon wirklich hübsche, nicht gepierste, nicht tätowierte, junge ostdeutsche Frauen. Und du hast halt wirklich komplette Katastrophe am anderen Ende. Und übrigens auch, wenn mal wieder einer behauptet, Deutsche sehen alle gleich aus. Also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass man sieht, dass eine Ostenmuld auch wirklich aus dem Osten ist. Weil die Frauen haben dann ein ganz typisches Aussehen, finde ich. Also ich bin der Meinung, ich kann das ja kennen.
Also man findet jetzt schon so eine Phänotypologie dann bei denen.
Das ist so ein begeisterter Rassismus plötzlich, dass man so, ich sehe voll, dass die aus dem Osten sind.
Ellen Kursitzer, schon erwähnt, hat sich dazu geäußert zu diesem Phänomen und schreibt, wie gesagt, ich mag diese Ostenmulden auch, weil meine Liebe zu Außenseitern fast grenzenlos ist. Aber ich setze keinerlei Hoffnung auf diesen Trend. Sie beschreibt dann, wie sie selbst aus dem Westen kommt, irgendeinen Freiraum suchte, wo man nicht so wie in Westdeutschland sein muss, wo noch Terra Incognita ist. Das hatten sie dann in Schnellroda gefunden. Sie haben dann direkten Nachbarn gehabt, der sie mit dem Hitlergruß begrüßt hat. Mit dem seien sie dann aber gut zurechtgekommen. Der hat dann auch für einen, wie sie schreibt, gerechten Lohn, Dachpappe von unseren Dielen geföhnt und gerissen und dort gearbeitet. Und die Freundin, die wechselten immer wieder, aber sie waren alle stark tätowiert. Und das waren also Ostmullen, die sie da erlebt hat. Und sie sagt aber jetzt also, die Frauen, die man dort sieht, die stammen aus keinem gesunden Elternhaus. Sie kennt keine Ostmulle aus einem gesunden Elternhaus. Sie schreibt in Anführungszeichen, meine Ostmullen haben Kinderheimabtreibung, psychiatrische Klinik, gewaltvolle Beziehungen etc. pp. in ihrer Bio stehen. Also sie bringt hier ja die soziale Komponente, wo man wieder sagen muss, genau, und die wird ja unbeantwortet. Der Staat lässt Mütter allein. Wenn jetzt hier schon ein erwähnter Freund sagt, ja, viele der jungen Frauen mit Deutschlandfagge zeigen sich auch schon mit Kind auf dem Arm, dann bestätigt das natürlich auch nochmal das und würde wieder zu dem führen, was jetzt Isabella Weber sagt, ja, wir brauchen eine antifaschistische Wirtschaftspolitik, die zum Beispiel dann bedeutet, dass Frauen nicht so im Stich gelassen werden, dass ihnen dann nur noch so eine Radikalisierung über das Internet bleibt. Interessanterweise schließt dann Herr Kursitzer ihren Text über die Ostmole damit, dass sie sagt, sie kämpfen ihre Kämpfe, sie sind die Nemesis der BRD, gut, dass es sie gibt, besser, wenn man sie nach oben holen könnte. Nicht man, sondern wir. Woher die Kraft dazu kommen wird, weiß ich nicht. Also das ist so, dass das große Projekt dann, da müssen wir eigentlich hin. Wir springen mal gerade zu dem Clip von AfD-Politiker Joachim Paul aus Rheinland-Pfalz. Der hat sich auch schon zum Ostenmullen-Phänomen geäußert.
Der Ostmullen-Dienstag ist der vielleicht größte metapolitische Erfolg der letzten Jahre, wenn nicht sogar Jahrzehnte. Es werden natürlich einige sagen, ja, Mulle ist das nicht ein abwertender Begriff für Frau. Würde ich sagen, nicht. Es kommt immer darauf an, was man aus dem Begriff macht, wie man ihn auflädt. Das muss der politisch aktive Mensch wissen. Und es zeigt auch, dass unsere deutsche Sprache lebendig ist. Wir brauchen keine Anglizismen irgendwo her und müssen dann mit denen...
Ja, die Sprache ist lebendig....
hier umgehen, sondern wir können selbst Worte entwickeln, Worte aufladen und dann politisch wirken lassen. Und deswegen kann ich nur sagen, ich möchte den jungen Frauen gratulieren zum Ostmullen-Dienstag und hoffe natürlich, dass es bald auch einen Westmullentag gibt, wahlweise Donnerstag oder Samstag. Und ich bin gespannt auf eure Videos. Macht weiter so, rüttelt an den Grundfesten des Systems. Das ist euer Auftrag.
Man nimmt sich noch die letzten Strohhalme um mal irgendwie eine Sinnhaftigkeit ins eigene Denkgebäude. Ja. Das ist doch schlimm.
Dann gibt es so einen rechten Podcaster, der heißt Let's Make Money. Der spricht auch über dieses Phänomen, bündigt sich auch Ost und West gemeinsam.
Dass die Ostmullen im größten Teil wirklich starke, selbstbewusste Frauen sind, keine Männerhasse, auch ganz wichtig. Und ja, wie gesagt, weil Jette Nitzhardt, die kriegt ja gratis Mut geschenkt. Also ihre politische Ausrichtung, ihren Männerhass und so, der ist ja salonfähig sozusagen. Den zu präsentieren, da braucht man keinen Mut, da braucht man überhaupt nichts. Aber die Mädels, die lehnen sich gegen den Mainstream auf, gegen ihre Lehrer lehnen sich auf, gegen die Politik, gegen die Eltern im Endeffekt. Das sind starke Mädchen für mich, starke Frauen für mich. Und ich denke, sie werden die Gesellschaft viel weiterbringen und im Gegensatz zu einer Jette Nitzhardt auch keine Gefahr darstellen. Ja, gerne eure Meinung zu dieser ganzen Ostmullen-Bewegung, die Ostmullen-Dienstag. Sollte man das eventuell nicht auch so langsam mal im Westen einführen und dadurch vielleicht dann sogar zusammenarbeiten. Ich glaube, bei TikTok kann man ja auch zusammen Videos machen. Macht doch mal eine Westmulle mit einer Ostmulle zusammen. Ja, um uns als deutsches Volk auch wieder zusammenzubringen, dass endlich diese Ost-West-Grenze wegkommt, weil die finde ich grauenvoll. Und ja, der Westen kann da jetzt in dem Fall vielleicht noch viel vom Osten lernen.
Ja, die sind einfach alle verblendet. Die wissen nicht, wie wir hier leben und dass es das hier gar nicht gibt. Und hier auch niemand da ist, der plötzlich so hier gummeln Videos macht. Das können die sich nicht vorstellen. Die glauben ja, also sehr viele AfD-Wähler, die so ein bisschen aktivistischer drauf sind, also die schon mal ein YouTube-Video drehen oder so, glauben ja wirklich, es ist nur noch so eine missionarische Weg zu gehen. Aber eigentlich, man muss den Leuten nur noch Bescheid sagen. So, aber wir alle kennen jetzt die AfD und die Leute haben sich jetzt so entschieden. Also, das ist wirklich verrückt.
Ja, also diese Perspektivlosigkeit junger Menschen kannst du natürlich schon auch in westlichen Gefilden antreffen.
Ja, dass wir keine rebellische Jugendkultur haben, ist auch ein echtes Problem, so, gesellschaftlich.
Jaja, also das ist ja auch, selbst die, die es jetzt gab, also die Aktivisten waren ja derart staatstragend, dass man schon fast dachte, warum geht er nicht gleich in die Partei und macht es von dort aus? Das ist schon auch ein Problem. Jetzt zum Abschluss noch zwei Eklips von auch einem kleinen YouTuber, der auch schon mit Kurssitzer zu tun hatte, der im Hintergrund ein Kruzifix hängen hat, also der offenbar katholisch ist und der den Namen Lukas Kurthjahl hat.
Der hat jetzt seine These zu den Ostmollen, wir haben halt die Freiheit und das hat auch Bishop Williamson mal gesagt, wir haben aktuell die Freiheit, uns dazu verderben und das machen sehr viele Menschen auch. Und ich stelle mir die Frage, was wäre mit diesen Frauen, wenn die Leute noch an Gott glauben würden? Wären die dann so verloren, wie sie es sind? Und was können wir dafür tun, auch als Christen, um diesen Bevölkerungsgruppen, die da im Osten verweilen, ja, wieder Gott näher zu bringen?
Im Osten verweilen, das ist gut.
Das ist ja auch, wir hatten das ja schon mal bei den Schnellroder Leuten. Wir hatten da mal im Podcast, als, glaube ich, auch Krader zu Gast war, dieses Thema Katholizismus. Wie kriegt man eigentlich dieses so heidnische Ostdeutschland wieder rechristianisiert? Das ist ja für Ellen Kursitzer auch so ein ganz großes Thema. Und es scheint so diese Strömung zu sein, jetzt sagt man, jetzt muss, da sind also Mädels, die aufbegehren im Kinderzimmer, jetzt müssen wir die noch zu Gott führen. Denn die große Klammer, und damit sind wir schon fast wieder bei unserer Debatte, Wehrpflicht und was müssen Frauen für den Staat tun? Er will nicht, dass jetzt über die Frauen und die Aussehen zu abwertend gesprochen wird. Denn für ihn erfüllen die natürlich in erster Linie eine Funktion als Frauen. Du ahnst, worauf das hinausläuft.
Es sind garantiert nicht die Frauen, die uns jetzt den metapolitischen Sieg bringen. Aber auf der anderen Seite sind es halt auch unsere Frauen und sie werden noch Nachwuchs gebären. Das heißt, ein Stück weit sind sie halt auch unsere Verantwortung, dass es so Frauen besser geht.
In dieser Situation befinden wir uns. Also das ist sicherlich eines der dunkelsten Kapitel jetzt, die man so aktuell erleben kann, was die verschiedenen rechten Strömungen anbelangt. Dass das so eine ganz individualisierte, rechte Ästhetik gemixt ist mit so ein bisschen Vorstadt-Prolligkeit und ein bisschen zu sehr auf die Insta-Filter gesetzt und und und. Und das vermischt sich dann zu so einem Deutschtum, das ja noch völlig ungefestigt ist. Dass also jetzt von diesen verschiedenen Rechten schon etablierteren Strömungen umgarnt wird und rüber gezogen wird, auf welche Seite und da wird dann auch noch mal eine Auslese betrieben. Also es ist eigentlich ein unglaublich trauriges Phänomen. Als ich das Ostmohlen-Phänomen erstmal sah bei Twitter, dachte ich, das ist kurios, ich bringe es mal mit, weil es irgendwie auch lustig ist. Und je mehr ich mir davon angesehen habe, habe ich nur noch eigentlich eine tiefe Traurigkeit darüber verspürt, was da ist und da muss man ganz klar sagen, das Ostmohlen-Phänomen ist aus einem, hier kann man den Begriff ruhig mal nehmen, Staatsversagen entstanden, das da ganz viel nicht mehr ist. Und in gewisser Weise hat eine Ellen Kossitzer das erkannt. Ja, die will das natürlich dann von rechts lösen mit ihren Leuten. Aber eigentlich die Diagnose von ihr ist nicht falsch.
Ja, ich finde sowieso, also wir haben jetzt die AfD dort stark, wo es ja gar keine Ausländer gibt und Moritz Sovkin hat jetzt bei sich auch noch mal so eine Auflistung, irgendeine Datenquelle gehabt für die Frage, sind die Gemeinden gerade überlastet mit Flüchtlingsunterbringungen und so. Und in den ostdeutschen Bundesländern sagen irgendwie 80 Prozent, 90 Prozent nein, kein nennenswertes Problem, hier ist niemand. Gleichzeitig fragen wir uns natürlich, warum ist die AfD dann da so stark? Und immer wenn es so Spiegel-TV-artige Reportagen gibt zum Thema, warum ist die AfD da so stark? Ist einfach völlig klar, ja weil man da wo hingehen kann, wo die AfD ist. Diese Reportagen handeln nur von Zusammenköpften, auf dem Parkplatz, beim Vereinsfest, auf dem Schulhof, was auch immer. Also man muss hier gar nicht, klar Staatsversagen ist es, weil es da so einen Versorgungsauftrag gibt, aber Versorgung von was? Und wir kommen immer wieder auf dieses Gemeinschaft, Geselligkeit, Zeitvertreib und so weiter und so fort. Der erste, der ein ordentliches Angebot macht, aber ja, wenn man es staatlich organisiert, das ist teuer. Und der Staat könnte ja zumindest mal so in so Förderstrukturen gehen und sagen, wir gucken hier so ein bisschen drauf, in welche Richtung ihr euch entwickelt und davon abhängig ist dann.
Wird hier weggestrichen. Ich hab ja auch jetzt gerade mit jemand gesprochen aus dem Osten, der dort hilft, Leute einzugliedern, wo schulisch einige Brüche waren und wo man also eine intensivere Betreuung braucht, als das so üblich ist. Ein Lehrer, 28 Schüler oder so, sondern 1 zu 1 Betreuung zum Teil, Leute auf den Weg bringen. Ja, ist dann, eine Förderung kommt nicht mehr und dann fallen einfach dann 8 Stellen weg und dann sind die auch noch dem ausgeliefert. Ich hatte vor Jahren diesen Film besprochen, Lord of the Toys, der handelte von diesem YouTuber, Atlason, der nicht so richtig recht zu verorten ist, aber auch immer damit so spielte mit gewissen Insikien. Und da war ganz interessant, da waren nämlich dann diese jungen Leute zu sehen, die sich da um ihn schaten und dann waren sie auf irgendeinem Volksfest und sonst wo und da waren dann auch schon so gewisse Mädels, die man jetzt wahrscheinlich heute als Ostenmulden bezeichnet und die hatten dann schon ihren Freund, der beim dritten Weg war. Ja und das war aber noch zugleich so völlig unpolitisch und politisch, also so eine ganz merkwürdige Mischung und da hat man das schon sehr deutlich gesehen und jetzt hat es noch einen Begriff dafür und ist mit einem Hashtag versehen.
Ja, das ist einfach alles nicht gut. Zum Abschluss, das Internet ist tot. Ja, das sind jetzt Nachrichten aus Mai, 16. Mai in dem Falle aus dem Big Technology Podcast. Also Google weiß man, Auflistungen von Webseiten, da klickt man die an und so weiter und GPT weiß man, kriegt man eine Antwort, klickt nichts an. Dieses Phänomen leicht beschrieben, einfach verstanden. Nur gab es jetzt die Zahlen dazu. SimilarWeb ist so ein Dienstanbieter. Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie machen, aber das ganze Internet rauscht einmal trafficmäßig durch deren Server. Deswegen haben die so ein bisschen Überblick, was da passiert und alle, alle verlieren außer Open AI.
Ja, also das sind einige tolle Daten, die von SimilarWeb kommen. Sam Altman hat es in seinem Testimony vor dem US-Kongress bereits bezeichnet. Wenn man sich das mal anschaut, ist es faszinierend. Also, zuerst mal, ChatGPT ist die Nummer 5 Website im Weltall, nach dem SimilarWeb. Du hast Google zuerst, dann YouTube, Facebook und Instagram, und dann Nummer 5 ist ChatGPT. Das ist eine sehr interessante Entwicklung. Aber das andere, was wirklich wert ist, ist das Desktop, und wir wissen, dass alle mobilisiert werden. Aber wenn man sich die Verkehrsveränderungen im Monat über den Monat anschaut, Google, YouTube, Facebook, Instagram, alles geht runter. ChatGPT geht 13% mehr hoch im Monat über den Monat. Dann alles, was noch folgt, X, WhatsApp, Wikipedia, Reddit, Yahoo, Japan, alles geht runter. Und so steht ChatGPT hier alleine. Und das führt mich zu dem Titel unserer ersten Sektion hier, ist ChatGPT das letzte Website?
Offenbar ja, denn es ist ja wirklich diese Frage, wie oft besuchen eigentlich noch Menschen? Und im Verhältnis dazu Maschinen, Webseiten.
Ich habe auch jetzt im vergangenen Monat mehr ChatGPT denn je benutzt und zwar nicht, weil ich irgendwas Großes wollte, sondern weil ich einfache Fragen hatte von statistischen Daten bis hin zu Worterklärungen und habe einfach diese Seite offen gehabt. Ich habe es immer gerade da eingegeben, wurde nicht von Werbung belästigt, bekam das, bekam gleich auch noch eine detailliertere Auflistung, als ich es erwartet hatte. Habe also unglaublich viel Zeit dort verbracht und Google wirklich nur noch für Google Maps und sonst findet das bei mir kaum statt. Perplexity ist dann noch da. Bei Perplexity ist es ja ganz interessant, dass die ja auch mit Werbung rumgespielt haben, was sich ja gar nicht wohl rechnen zu scheinen. Also es ist so, dass die, wenn ich das richtig gehört habe, ich glaube im Doppelgänger-Podcast war das, dass Perplexity mit dem Werbemodell 20.000 Dollar eingespielt hat.
Ja, wird schon ein bisschen mehr gewesen sein, aber.
Das ist aber wirklich ganz gering.
Ja, was ja bedeutet, wir bezahlen jetzt alle für unsere Chatbots. Mindestens 20 Euro, manchmal 200, wie auch immer. Und dann ist ja die Frage, für was und an wen bezahlen wir? Dieses Geld wird ja nicht weitergereicht an Wikipedia oder so. Obwohl wir nur noch Fragen stellen, die uns die Wikipedia beantworten könnte, wenn wir nur nicht so faul wären und dann einfach die punktuelle, den Ziel ohne Weg, wir haben es ja besprochen. Das Internet verwandelt sich immer mehr zu seinem Internet der Maschinen.
75% der Querele gehen zu Google. Google antwortet auf Google, ohne dich zurück zu der Original-Source zu senden. Aber sogar in den letzten sechs Monaten hat die Zahl weiter erhöht. Jetzt ist es bis zu 15 zu 1. Also 15 Krollen für jeden Besucher. Also Google in sechs Monaten hat von 6 zu 1 bis 15 zu 1 gegangen. Und wenn du denkst, dass das ein schwerer Deal für Publisher ist, dann warte einfach auf OpenAI. OpenAI, glaube ich, ist 250 zu 1. Und Anthropic ist 6.000 zu 1. Princes ist viel Druck auf Medienfirmen, die Geld durch Subscriptionen oder Adminen auf ihren Pages machen. Viele kommen zu uns, weil sie sehen uns als sie können, wie AI-Kompeten ihre Informationen kontrollieren.
Also als Blogger wie ich, stefanschulz.com, bist du jetzt wieder Avantgarde, machst etwas, was sonst keiner macht. Und Claude greift 6.000 Mal auf meine Seite zu, bis irgendwann mal jemand über Claude angeleitet bei mir vorbeikommt.
Das heißt, du schreibst in erster Linie für Claude deine Texte, für Maschinen, freust dich, dass sie die lesen und wenn es gut läuft, führen sie dir auch noch einen Menschen zu.
Naja, es ist so ein bisschen, genau, ich brauche ja nicht zwingend jetzt den echten Menschen in meinem Text. Ich denke, der wird ja rausgeschickt per E-Mail, Leute können ihn lesen irgendwann. Oder wenn sie Geld dafür zahlen, kriegen sie ihn vorgelesen als Podcast. Nur man hat halt seinen kleinen Kreis an Lesern, weniger hunderttausend, keine Ahnung, wie viele es so sind. Und die ganze Zeit rauscht aber irgend so ein Crawler die ganze Zeit vorbei und belastet meinen Server. Also spielt das nicht so die mega Rolle. Ich habe so ein Pauschalhost irgendwie. Aber ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein echtes Phänomen zumindest mal, dass man sich jetzt künftig auch fragt, booking.com, müssen wir überhaupt noch eine Webseite machen oder reicht es einfach so AP-Ausgänge, dass die Chatbots einfach darauf zugreifen? An Tropic schreibt er die großen Standards, die sich jetzt auch erstmal alle verschreiben, auch weil es so eine große plurale Welt ist. Es hat sich noch keiner durchgesetzt und kann einfach ein Standard durchdrücken. Also in der Ansicht geht es schon relativ wenig proprietär zu, aber es wird halt grundsätzlich so ein KI-Internet, was halt wirklich zu der Frage führt, wer schreibt demnächst noch in die Wikipedia was rein? Ja. Die Welt bewegt sich ja weiter und da müssen ja Sachen reingeschrieben werden. Es passieren ja Sachen. Und es wäre schon schön, wenn die Aufmerksamkeit noch so ein bisschen bei der Wikipedia, also dass man mal die Seite sieht und dann, ah ja, da oben ist der Spendenbutton, sie suchen Geld und unten kann man sich anmelden und selber schreiben. Man hat ja gar keinen pädagogischen Zugang mehr zu solchen Prinzipien. In der Ansicht ist das ein echtes Problem. Wir hören also einfach noch zwei kleine Clips, in denen es auf den Punkt gebracht wird.
Die einzige Frage ist, wenn die Incentive für die Leute aufhören, neue Sachen zu publisherschen, und das ist wieder News, aber auch, ich weiß nicht, neue Rezepte, neue was auch immer, was auch immer jemand auf der Web schreibt. Wenn es keine finanziellen Incentive gibt, haben wir noch bestimmte Plätze und Gemeinden, wie Reddit und so weiter, wo Leute die Liebe posten oder sozialen Medienplattformen in generell, die ziemlich interessante Incentive auf sich selbst werden. Aber sonst, Webseite mit neuen Content auf sie existieren, wie für mich, sogar mehrso, als wir reden, ich werde von der Frage her, wir haben die Web ist tot vergrößert bis die Web in einer sekulären Verlängerung ist. Ich könnte jetzt wieder auf die Web ist tot gehen, aber ich glaube, dass das nicht wirklich witzig ist.
Web ist dead und Wikipedia ist done.
Ich meine, eine der Stats, die ich etwas überblickt, aber ich denke, das ist die interessanteste Sache hier, ist, dass Chatship.it Wikipedia übernimmt. Chatship.it ist Site Nummer 5 und Wikipedia ist 8. Für mich ist das einfach Wikipedia ist done.
Ja, also ich finde das sehr schade. Wir brauchen so ein Stöber-Internet, wir können nicht alle nur in Social Media rumhängen und von Bild zu Bild zweipen, sondern ich habe zumindest jetzt mal wieder nach Jahren die Erfahrung gemacht, ein Sachbuch zu lesen und nach jeder Seite immer in der Wikipedia noch mal kurz nachzulesen und hier und da und dann vertieft man sich da so und es dauert alles ewig, aber es kommt halt echt was bei rum.
Ja.
Und wenn das einfach nicht mehr geht, weil es immer weniger brauchen, so dass diese Infrastruktur gar nicht mehr so betreut wird, haben wir hier ein echtes Problem, glaube ich. Deswegen, Leute, bloggen. Macht euch wieder einen Blog. Und einmal im Monat einen kleinen Text, das kriegt da wohl jeder hin.
Und Bücher lesen.
Womit wir nochmal hinweisen auf unseren Salon. Wir sprechen über das Buch Geoökonomie, Anatomie der Neuen Weltordnung von Milan Babic erschienen bei Suhrkamp. Das ist das Buch, über das wir uns dann intensiv austauschen werden im Salon. Was es sonst noch im Salon dann gibt, ich kann nur ankündigen, denn diesmal werde ich keine klassische Musik empfehlen, sondern Jazz.
Wer hätte es gedacht, wenn es nicht klassisch ist, dann Jazz.
Jetzt gibt es Jazz. Und alles andere werde ich mir noch ein bisschen offen halten, aber ich habe sehr viele interessante Texte im Petto. Wie ist es bei dir?
Ich werde wahrscheinlich mal in dieses, es scheint dicker zu sein, aber Apple in China. Ich finde es so interessant, wie die da einfach diese Infrastruktur hochgezogen haben und überhaupt. Und weil sie jetzt auch so im Kieker sind, so im Fokus von Trump. Mal sehen, ob in Gänze oder Auszüge.
Das ist sicherlich lohnenswert. Man kann den Podcast ganz einfach abonnieren über Steady. Es ist am allerbesten. Dort gibt es das vollständige Archiv. Man geht einfach auf neuzwanziger.de, auf den goldenen Button, kommt dann zu Steady. Und wenn man das dann abonniert hat, dann muss man nicht auf der Steady-Seite verweilen. Man muss auch nicht auf den PC die ganze Zeit starren und gucken, ob der Podcast läuft, sondern man bekommt einen RSS-Vide. Den kann man so kopieren und kann überall den immer so hören, wie man jetzt gerade uns auch hört. Man kann sagen, jetzt will ich so weiterhören. Das ist auf jeden Fall möglich. Bei Patreon funktioniert das ähnlich. Wenn man jetzt bei Apple ist und sagt, ich will da gar nicht weg und zahle lieber 50 Cent mehr, bevor ich mich jetzt noch mal wo neu anmelde, kann man auch den Salon ganz einfach dort direkt buchen. Hat dann dort auch genau das Apple-Erlebnis, das man immer hat. Und ich glaube, wir erleben jetzt gerade, dass die Podcasts eine Disruption bekommen dadurch, dass diese Plattformen und vor allem auch Spotify ist da zu nennen oder in erster Linie zu nennen, die ja so sehr daran interessiert sind, dass man den Podcast dort hostet, dass man ja im Prinzip so eine Art Angestellter von Spotify wird. Von daher ist es auch echt sehr wichtig, und das meint jetzt nicht nur unseren Podcast, sondern generell Podcasts zu unterstützen, dass sie nicht in diese Arme von Spotify da bekommen, sondern dass man schon auch noch sagt, Podcast bedeutet eigentlich, dass etwas überall zu hören ist und nicht nur da. Von daher sind diese Unterstützungsmodelle, die es da gibt für Podcasts neben der Werbung, die aber momentan ja auch sehr brach liegt, wie man in vielen Podcasts hört.
Das scheint sehr brach zu sein.
Das scheint ein schwieriges Feldgrad zu sein. Ist das also eine Möglichkeit, Podcasts zu unterstützen? Und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr das tut. Und noch einmal der Hinweis, live sind wir dann als echte Menschen auf einer Bühne zu erleben am 23. August. Stefan hält eine kleine Andacht oder so.
Wir werden gucken.
Also, am 23. August. Und dann sehen wir uns in wenigen Tagen im Salon.
So ist es. Bis dann.